TODAY'S- BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY'S
HEARING IS OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
COMBO HEARING FOR THE UC AND
CSU A SYSTEM AS ALWAYS THIS IS
A- A DISTANT- HEARING A VIRTUAL
HEARING SO WILL HAVE LIMITED-
PARTICIPATION FROM THE PUBLIC
HERE TODAY WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENGAGE LATER- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT BY CALLING IN AT THE
NUMBERS ON THE AGENDA WILL BE
ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THAT NUMBER- LATER IN THE
AFTERNOON JUST AT THE OUTSET
WITH WE DO WELL WHAT TO KNOW
THAT IF WE DON'T FINISH BY NOON
HOPEFULLY WE WILL BEGIN OFFICE
BY NOON. WE WILL TAKE A RECESS
AT NOON AND THEN- RECONVENE-
BETWEEN A ONE AND ONE THIRTY
DEPENDING ON WHAT TIME ARE OUR
RESPECTIVE CAUCUSES AND- AGAIN.
TODAY'S HEARINGS ABOUT THE UC
AND CSU AND- BOTH SYSTEMS HAVE
HAD BAD TO DRAMATICALLY IT
ADJUST HOW THEY OPERATE IN.
CERTAINLY HAD IMPACT ON
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF THIS-
PANDEMIC AND WE KNOW THAT. OUR
STUDENTS HAVE FACED A SEVERE
JOB LOSSES LOSSES- TECHNOLOGY
CHALLENGES HOUSING CHALLENGES-
WALK CAMPUSES FACED A NEW COST
AND LOST A LOT OF REVENUE
RELATED TO HOUSING. AND AND
PARKING BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME SOME GOOD NEWS ON THE
HORIZON AND SOME GOOD NEWS
THAT. RECENTLY HAPPENED THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATURE- THE AND THIS
BODY IN THE GOVERNOR THAT- THE
MEASURES THAT WE VOTED ON. THE
THE MID YEAR BUDGET- COVER
NINETEEN PACKAGE THAT WE- VOTED
ON TWO WEEKS AGO RESTORES THE
CUTS THAT WE MADE TO UC AND
CSU. THAT ARE BEING BEEN THE
ASK NUMBER ONE FROM THOSE TWO
SEGMENTS SEGMENTS- IT SEGMENT
WE'LL GET ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDING BACK
STARTING ON JULY ONE. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT CONGRESS IS ON THE
VERGE OF PASSING A THIRD ROUND
A FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDING THAT
WILL HELP ALL UNIVERSITIES- WE
ANTICIPATE LATEST ROUND
EXPECTED PROVIDE. ABOUT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING TO CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES CLEANED
COMMUNICABLE **** SOME OF THAT
FOR THE SEGMENT SOME OF THAT'S
TO A STUDENTS FOR FINANCIAL AID
WE THINK THAT YOU SEEN CSU
WILL. RECEIVE AT LEAST ONE
BILLION OF THAT SO WE WANT TO
HEAR- SOME PRELIMINARY INSIGHT
FROM THE UNIVERSITIES.
UNIVERSITIES I ABOUT THE- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT- OUR STUDENTS
ARE STILL HURTING AND CAMPUSES
ARE STILL PLANNING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO IN PERSON
LEARNING IN THE FALL- THIS
BUDGET IS A GOOD STARTING POINT
TO HELP US REFOCUS ON STUDENTS
NEEDS ENSURING THAT CAMPUSES
HAVE THE ADEQUATE. RESOURCES SO
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN-
TODAY'S HEARING WE HAVE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FIRST
WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- LMAO AND- IN SE HA
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT SO. ISSUE NUMBER ONE-
BASE FUNDING ENROLLMENT.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I CAN'T
HEAR YOU SO LET'S START OVER.
GAINES HOW GOOD MORNING BRIAN
CAN HEAR YOU. I'M THE OPERATOR
I HEAR YOU EITHER BRENT OKAY.
SO MAYBE IT'S NOT SHOWING UP IN
THE HEARING ROOM. YEAH WE HEAR
SO GO AHEAD YEP. THANK YOU SO
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR
THE CHANCE TO REPRESENT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A 3%
BASING CREASE FOR THE UNIVERSAL
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S A HUNDRED
AND THREE POINT NINE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. WHICH
FOR UC CAMPUSES AND EIGHT POINT
NINE MILLION FOR THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT YOU SEE PATH
AND YOU SEE DIVISION OF
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. IN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS PART OF
THE EARLY ACTION AGREEMENT
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED A FINANCE
LETTER WAS ISSUED TO PROVIDE
YOU SEE THREE HUNDRED AND TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND. YOU SEE IS
ENCOURAGED TO USE THESE
RESOURCES FROM THE SPRING
LETTER TO PROVIDE SUPPORT.
CAMPUS IS- THEY'RE CHANGING
OPERATIONAL PROBLEM
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS IN TOTAL
COMBINING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND THE EARLY EARLY ACTION
AGREEMENT. YOU SEE IT WOULD
RECEIVE FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND WHICH
EXCEEDS THE AMOUNT OF UC'S
BASED GENERAL FUND REDUCTION.
FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT. AND IT ALSO RECEIVED TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET 3% BATES AUGMENTATION
COMES WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT
THE UC WILL TO THE FOLLOWING.
SUBMIT A REPORT BY JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DETAILING PLANS FOR ACHIEVING
20% ANNUAL REDUCTIONS IN EQUITY
GAPS AND THAT'S A LIMITING
LIMITING EQUITY GAPS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. TO ADOPT POLICIES
BY JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO REQUIRING CAMPUSES TO
MAINTAIN 10% OF POINTS MORE
ONLINE COURSES AND PROGRAMS
THAN THEY HAD BEFORE COBIT
BASED ON THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ACADEMIC YEAR. TO
CREATE A NEW DUAL MISSIONS
PROGRAM ENABLING FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN TO RECEIVE GUARANTEED
FUTURE ACCESS TO UC CAMPUS IF
AND WHEN THEY COMPLETE AN
EIGHTY T. OR ANOTHER ESTABLISH
TRANSFER PATHWAY AND A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WITHIN TWO ACADEMIC YEARS. TO
BETTER ALIGN STUDENT LEARNING
OBJECTIVES WITH WORKFORCE AND
INDUSTRY NEEDS. AND FINALLY THE
LAST EXPECTATION IS TO HOLD
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE TUITION
AND FEES FLAT FOR THE ACADEMIC
YEAR. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. I
THANK YOU WE ARE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU L. A. L.
CHASING CONCENTRA SALLY- ISSUE
ONE HAS THREE COMPONENTS TO IT
ON THE FIRST IS THE LEVEL OF
BASE SUPPORT THAT THE STATE
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU SEE
THE SECOND COMPONENT IS
EXPECTATIONS TO ATTACH TO THE
BASE SUPPORT AND THEN THE THIRD
ISSUE- IS ON A ROLL THAT
MATTERS SO I'LL TALK ABOUT EACH
COMPONENT. FIRST AS TO THE
LEVEL OF BASE SUPPORT AS HAS
BEEN NOTED THAT FEBRUARY
AGREEMENT THAT WAS RECENTLY
RELEASED- RESTORED REDUCTIONS
THAT WERE MADE TO YOU SEE IN
LAST YEAR'S PROJECT PROBLEMS
THAT THIS RESTORATION FUNDING
WOULD ALLOW YOU SEE TO COVER
CERTAIN COSTS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND FUND SOME RESTORATION
ACTIVITIES LIKE THROWING UP
PORTION OF VACANT POSITIONS.
WERE ADDRESSING A UC'S ANY
DEFICITS THAT WORKER DURING THE
CURRENT YEAR H. THE QUESTION
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE THEN IS
WHETHER TO STOP IT THIS
RECOVERY REMOTE OR TO GO
FURTHER. FOR EXAMPLE- DOCKING
THE WITH THE PER ADDITIONAL- 3%
ON MEDICATIONS. I KNOW THERE
ARE A FEW FACTORS TO CONSIDER-
THERE ARE THE COST PRESSURES
THAT ARE CITED ON PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA THAT YOU SEE IS
FACING. THERE'S A STATE BUDGETS
LIMITED CAPACITY FOR ONGOING
SPENDING AND PROJECTED OUT YEAR
DEFICITS. AND THEN AS NOTED
THERE'S ALSO THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FEDERALLY FUNDING I
PROVIDED TO YOU SEE INCLUDING
THAT THAT I'M NOT POTENTIALLY
THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED UNDER
THE UNDER THE NOOSE AROUND. I'M
WITH ALL THESE FACTORS IN MIND
WE RECOMMEND YOU REVISIT THE
ISSUE OF BASE SUPPORT IN MAY
REVISION. IN A REVISION- YOUR
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ON THE STATE. OF
BUDGETS- OVERALL CONDITION. AND
WILL ALSO HAVE SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON THE NEW ROUND OF
FEDERALLY FUNDING. ALSO THE
SECOND COMPONENT ON THE OTHER
BASED EXPECTATIONS IF YOU TURN
THE PAGE SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA
ALL THE BULLETS ON PAGE SEVEN
LIST THE THREE CORE
EXPECTATIONS THAT ARE PROPOSED
FOR THE BUDGET BILL UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I'M GOING IN
THE ORDER THAT YOU SEE THERE ON
THAT FIRST EXPECTATION FOR-
EQUITY. WE HAVE THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF CONCERN WITH THIS
PROPOSAL- AS NOTED IN THE STAFF
COMMENTS OF YOUR AGENDA ALL THE
SEGMENTS ALREADY HAVE. PLANS IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES
OTHER CERTIFICATION OF LARGELY
I RECOGNIZE THOSE EXISTING
PLANS THE ONE EXCEPTION HERE IS
THAT IN THE CASE OF YOU SEE THE
EXPECTATION WOULD BE A FASTER
TIMELINE THAN WHAT WHAT YOU SEE
HAD ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED. I
JUST LIKE I WOULD LIKE TO SET
THIS EXPECTATION WE HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ALIGNING
SOME OF THE STATE'S EXISTING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ON
STUDENT OUTCOMES. TO ENHANCE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
UNIVERSITY'S IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS SOME EQUITY PLAN. I'M NOT
SECOND VOTE ON ONLINE
EDUCATION- WE HAVE MORE
CONCERNS WITH THIS EXPECTATION
WE UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DESIRE TO WANT
TO SUSTAIN EFFORTS AROUND
ONLINE EDUCATION LINE OF CODE-
BUT WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
SPECIFIC- PROPOSED TEN
PERCENTAGE POINT TARGET. OTHER
TARGET APPEARS ARBITRARY TO US
LACKING IN JUSTIFICATION. IT
ALSO RAISES POTENTIAL TRADE
OFFS OF THE LEGISLATURE WANT
MORE INFORMATION ON TRADE OFFS
AND THINGS LIKE COSTS AND THE
IMPACT ON STUDENT OUTCOMES. SO
THIS CASE WE RECOMMENDED
REJECTING THIS. PROPOSAL
REPLACING IT INSTEAD WITH THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ON EACH
OF THE SEGMENTS EXPERIENCES
WITH EDUCATION. THAT WOULD GIVE
THE LEGISLATURE MORE DATA SO
THAT IT COULD MAKE MORE AND
MORE FOR BUDGET DECISIONS AND
FUTURE YEARS ON ON THE
EDUCATION. I'M NOT I'M NOT
BULLET TO ADMIT HERE WE HAVE
THE MOST CAN. AND OUR CONCERNS
AROUND- A LOT OF THE BASIC
INFORMATION THAT'S MISSING ON
THE NEW PATHWAY. ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T CLARIFIED HOW MANY
STUDENTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
UNDER THE NEW PATHWAY WHICH
KINDA STUDENTS SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO GAUGE THE
POTENTIAL EQUITY PATENT PACKS
OF THE NEW PATHWAY. AND IT
HASN'T CLARIFIED HOW THE NEW
PATHWAY WOULD INTERACT WITH THE
OTHER EXISTING TRANSFER
PATHWAYS LIKE THE EXISTING
TRANSFORMATION GUARANTEES THAT
SEVERAL UC CAMPUSES. THIS IS AN
AREA WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
COULD WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CLARIFY THESE
BASIC ISSUES AND I THINK IN
FAVOUR INFORMATION IS NOT
FORTHCOMING BY ANY REVISION THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL REVISITED IN THE
FUTURE YOUR ONE. MORE
INFORMATION IS MADE AVAILABLE.
AND THEN ON THE FINAL COMPONENT
ON A MOMENT THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
THE SIMPLEST ISSUE OF ALL OF
THIS ISSUE ONE BECAUSE THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO PROPOSAL HERE.
ADMINISTRATION IS CONTINUING
ITS LONGSTANDING PRACTICE OF
NOT PROPOSING AN ENROLLMENT
TARGET FOR YOU SEE. HEARD A
STATE AND MANY PREVIOUS
HEARINGS AND IN PREVIOUS YEARS.
WE THINK THIS APPROACH IS POOR-
CREATES CONFUSION AS TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S EXPECTATIONS FOR
ENROLLMENT FOR YOU SEE. AND
HEAR WE RECOMMEND- SETTING A
TARGET FOR YOU SEE AND WE
RECOMMEND SETTING THAT TARGET.
FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR SO FOR
THE ACADEMIC YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. THAT WAS-
ENSURE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER INFLUENCE
FOLLOWING MISSION DECISIONS.
I'M NOT A LOT OF GROUND TO
COVER AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
FURTHER EXPAND ENTITIES POINT
START. OKAY THANK YOU. LET'S
NOW GO TO THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA. GOOD MORNING CHAU
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M SORRY EVER
CANON AND I AM REPRESENTING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP
ON THE GOVERNOR TO FULLY
RESTORE UNIVERSITIES BASED
BUDGET REDUCTIONS STARTING JULY
FIRST. RECEIVING THESE FUNDS
BACK IS CRITICAL TO AVOIDING
STEEP REDUCTIONS WHAT SERVICES-
THE RESTORATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY SPACE BUDGET ALLOWS
US TO MOVE AWAY FROM CRISIS
MANAGEMENT WHICH COULD HAVE
MEANT HUNDREDS OF LAYOFFS
ACROSS THE SYSTEM THIS
RESTORATION YES YOU SEE BACK TO
THE SAME LEVEL FUNDING. AS IN
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL YEAR NOW WE
CAN INSTEAD DISCUSS HOW THE
UNIVERSITY'S OPERATIONS CAN BE
SUPPORTED AND EVEN ENHANCED TO
ALLOW OUR STUDENTS STAFF STAFF
AND FACULTY DESCRIBING YOU
START SKILLS TO PROVIDE.
INNOVATION THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS. THE UNIVERSE OF HELP
FIRST TO COVER NINETY AND BURKE
OUR- ROLE OF RESEARCH. PUBLIC
SERVICE INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
TREATING PATIENTS PROVIDING
COVERT TESTING THE COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING OUR CAMPUSES ARE
PROVIDING REMOTE INSTRUCTION.
EVEN THOUGH THE INITIAL MONTHS
OF CODE NINETEEN WERE
ECONOMICALLY STRAINING ON C. R.
LEADERSHIP EXPRESSED A STRONG
DESIRE TO ACCOMPLISH. LAUDABLE
EMPLOYEES WHILE PRESERVING AND
EVEN STRENGTHENING OUR
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH
ACTIVITIES. FROM THE START THE
PANDEMIC TO JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THERE WERE NO
CORPORATE RELATED LAYOFFS
NUMBER CITY. AS OF THE END OF
JANUARY UNIVERSE'S TOTAL
CORPORATE RELATED COSTS
AMOUNTED TO OVER THREE POINT
ONE BILLION. OF THAT AMOUNT ONE
POINT SIX BILLION WAS COST. TO
CAMPUS OPERATIONS. HELP COVER
THIS ONE SIX BILLION THE TWO
RELIEF BILLS PASS SO FAR HAVE
BEEN THE CAMPUS WITH NEARLY OR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITION TO PROVIDING STUDENTS
WITH TWO HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
EMERGENCY EIGHT. THE FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE HAS HELPED GREATLY
BUT THE UNIVERSITY CONTINUES TO
FACE GREAT FINANCIAL PRESSURES
MAKING THE BASE BUDGET
RESTORATION CRITICAL IN
AVOIDING TEACHER LAYOFFS. BUT
ALSO VERY PERSONABLE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHICH PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN BC STUDENTS. WE
WILL DISCUSS SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS IN GREATER DETAIL
LATER IN THE HEARING BUT RIGHT
NOW ALL FOCUSED ON THE BASE
BUDGET GROWTH FUNDS. UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA NEEDS HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
TO SUSTAIN FOR OPERATIONS IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIRST
SCRIBNER. HE'S FUNDS ARE NEEDED
TO PAY FOR COSTS THAT COME FROM
BEING DRIVEN INSTITUTION AND
INCLUDE ITEMS LIKE COMPENSATION
INCREASES REPRESENTS LABOR
ADDITIONAL RETIREMENT COSTS AND
HEALTH CARE COST INCREASES. IF
THE NEW FUNDING IS NOT RECEIVED
UNIVERSITY WILL NEED TO FIND%
OTHER WAYS TO COVER THESE COSTS
SUCH AS CUTTING EXISTING
SERVICES. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES HUNDRED FOUR MILLION
IN NEW FUNDING FOR OUR
OPERATION INCREASES REQUESTING
BURKE WHO OPENS FUNDS. THESE
FUNDS ARE TIED THE TWO CHILDREN
OF POLICY GOALS THAT ARE
DISCUSSED IN YOUR AGENDA AND
WERE MENTIONED BY THE L. A. O.
TO SOUTH. UNIVERSITY SHARES THE
STATE'S GOALS OF ACCESS AND
INCLUSION BUT WE DO HAVE TO
REQUEST A REGARDING THESE.
PROPOSALS ONE OF THE GUY
OUTLINE GOALS TO READ REDUCE
GRADUATION LIKE TWENTY FIVE.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SO
ALREADY HAS BROAD. RATE OF 88%
FRESHMAN AND FRIENDS SIX YEARS
AND 89% OR TRANSFER AND
TRANSFER FOR YEARS. STILL WE
RECOGNIZE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR IMPROVEMENT UC
REGENTS ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED
TO. EQUITY AND INCLUSION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
AND WITH THESE GOALS IN MIND.
THE FRAMEWORK TWENTY THIRTY
PLAN. THIS PLAN SEEKS TO CLOSE
GRADUATION. EQUITY GAPS- AT THE
UNIVERSITY BY TWENTY THIRTY THE
FIRST YER OF IMPLEMENTATION OF
PLAN WAS ESTIMATED SIXTY
MILLION. AND WE'RE ENTHUSIASTIC
TO UNDERTAKE THE WORK OF
CLOSING GRADUATION EQUITY CAPS
BUT CANNOT DO SO WITHOUT
RESOURCES. BECAUSE OUR OF OUR
EFFORTS OF CLOSING GRADUATION
GAPS HAVE NOT BEEN PREVIOUSLY
FUNDED- WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS
BECAUSE A 20% INCREASE IN
GRADUATION RATES NOW I'M
TWENTY. FIVE AND REQUEST THAT
FOR YOU SEE WE BOTH RECEIVE NEW
FUNDING FOR THIS EFFORT AND THE
TIMELINE JUST THE FACT LIKE
THIRTY. ANOTHER POLICY GOAL
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IS TO
INCREASE THE ONLINE COURSES BY
10% OVER EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY STUDYING DIFFERENT
ROLES AND CHALLENGES OF REMOTE
INSTRUCTION. INITIAL INDICATORS
ARE THE REMOTE INSTRUCTION HAS
NOT BEEN EQUALLY BENEFICIAL FOR
ALL STUDENTS. WE'RE REQUESTING
TIME TO COMPLETE OUR ANALYSIS
BEFORE DECISIONS ARE MADE AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT SHIFTING TOWARDS
ONLINE EDUCATION IT'S
DESIRABLE. THE GOVERNOR'S
LANGUAGES THAT WAS A 10%
INCREASE FORGET ABOUT PROVIDING
YOU FUNDING FOR COURSES WHICH
WOULD MEAN NOT ADDING THE FULL
NUMBER OF COURSES OFFERED BUT
SHIFTING EXISTING COURSES
ONLINE PEDAGOGY. THAT HAVING
BEEN SAID WE DO SEE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INCREASING
ONLINE COURSE OFFERINGS AS A
WAY TO SEARCH STUDENTS SUCH AS
DURING SUMMER WHEN STUDENTS
RETURN HOME WITH THEIR PARENTS
OR TRAVEL. OR DURING THE
ACADEMIC YEAR TO ALLOW STUDENTS
TO INTERNSHIPS AND OTHER AT
OTHER LOCATIONS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY MAKING ACADEMIC
PROGRESS. WELL WE SEE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE EXPANSION
OF ONLINE EDUCATION WE REQUEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NOT ADOPT
THE SPECIFIC ARGUMENTS I'M- AND
FINALLY I WANT TO SHARE SOME
GOOD NEWS. OF ALMOST
UNIVERSITIES NATIONALISTS ARE
DROP IN ENROLLMENT LAST FALL
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
BALTIMORE CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES. MEETING THE
LEGISLATURE SKULL FOUR THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY NEW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES OVER
TWO YEARS. THESE NEWLY ENROLLED
STUDENTS COMPOSE OUR LARGEST
EVER CLASS OF UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY STUDENTS. ALSO OUR
APPLICATIONS FOR FALL TWENTY
ONE ADMISSIONS ARE THE HIGHEST
EVER AND NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND APPLICATIONS
RECEIVED. APPLICATIONS FROM
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
INCREASED BY ALMOST 22% OVER
LAST YEAR AND APPLICATIONS FROM
BLACK NEXT STUDENTS ROSE BY
OVER TWELVE PERCENT. UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE MISSION
AMONG CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS. OF
RESEARCH INCORPORATED WITH
EDUCATION AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
WE EDUCATE OVER TWO HUNDRED.
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
AND EMPLOYS NEARLY HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND FACULTY AND
STAFF. WE CONTRIBUTE EIGHTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL ACTIVE
HELP. ANNUALLY OUR FACULTY IT
OVER FOR IN REECE FOR AND
PRODUCED NEAR FORTY. DATE THE
COUNTRY TO HELP NO ECONOMY AND
THIS BOROUGH THE WORLD AND
REYES LEADER. YES BENEFIT FROM
THE CALL EDGE. IN OUTLOOK
SUPPORTED BY BEING BY WERE
CLASS. WE'RE THAT ENDED TO THE
BUDGET PROVIDE UNIVERSITY AIDED
BY MILLION AND ONGOING FUNDING
CAMPUS OPERATE COSTA. AND
EQUITY TO GROW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU I WE'LL
HAVE QUITE A FEW QUESTIONS HERE.
AND I WANT TO START OUT
FOCUSING ON- ENROLLMENT AND-
JUST MAYBE SAVE YOU CAN FIRST
FOCUS ON. YOU KNOW W'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS PANDEMIC AND
UNIVERSITIES ARE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT NEXT YEAR
GRANTED WE'RE IN MARCH AND YOU
KNOW MOST UC'S DON'T START
UNTIL LATE SEPTEMBER YES.
BERKELEY STARTS A LITTLE
EARLIER THIS SEMESTER SYSTEM SO
WHAT'S THE TIME LINE FOR A
UNIVERSITY TO ANNOUNCE THEIR
PLANS FOR THE FALL FOR STUDENTS.
WE WILL BE ANNOUNCING OUR PLANS
BY APPROXIMATELY MID APRIL- WE
ARE STARTING STUDENT ADMISSIONS
NOW APPLICATIONS ARE BEING
CONSIDERED AT THE MOMENT- OUR
CURRENT PLAN IS TWO FOLD- IN
ROMAN FLAT. FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE ARE ALSO NOT
PLANNING ON A TUITION INCREASE
YEAH I'M SORRY I'M NOT SURE HE
ENTERED THE QUESTION. I MEAN IN
PERSON VERSUS VIRTUAL WELL I'LL
GET TO AND ROLLED IN THE SECOND
SO WHAT. ARE YOUR PLANS AS FAR
AS ANNOUNCING. WHAT TYPE OF TAX.
UC'S WILL HAPPEN. AT THAT NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES. AT THE
MOMENT SIR WE ARE HOPING TO
HAVE A HYBRID INSTRUCTION
PRIMARILY IN PERSON WITH- SOME
OPTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE- BEING.
INVOLVED IN PERSON INSTRUCTION-
WITH THE HELP SOME SECTIONS
HAPPENING ONLINE WHETHER OR NOT
WE CAN. IMPLEMENT THAT WILL
DEPEND ON THE AMOUNT OF
VACCINATIONS THAT ARE PROVIDED
WITHIN THE STATE AND- GETTING
TO HERD IMMUNITY WHERE OUR
FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS CAN
SAVE ATTENDED PERSON
INSTRUCTION- IT APPEARS THAT
FROM SOME OF THE STATEMENTS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THERE MAY BE ENOUGH
VACCINE BY THE END OF MAY. TO
ACHIEVE THAT SO AT THAT TIME WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO STATE- FROM
WHAT THE INSTRUCTION WILL BE
FOR NEXT FALL. SO AGAIN THAT
THE GOAL FOR HYBRID INSTRUCTION
THE DECISION THAT THAT'S THE
GOAL AND THE DECISION WILL BE
MADE. IN MAY OR LATER IN THE
SUMMER. A WE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THAT DECISION BY THE BEGINNING
OF SUMMER ALL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
PLAN AND IN ORDER TO HAPPEN
FORCES EITHER- ON MIGRATED BACK
TO REMOTE INSTRUCTION OR-
PROVIDE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
SO WE ANTICIPATE KNOWING BY THE
END OF HEY WE CAN HAVE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION ALL. OKAY
THANK YOU I WENT OF ON A PIVOT
NOW TO THE ENROLLMENT AND
ACCESS TO. TO THE UC SYSTEM FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
I MAY SOUND LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD THIS IS MY SEVENTH YEAR
BUT I VENTURE TO SAY THIS IS
THAT THE TOP ISSUE THAT WE GET
WE GO BACK HOME TALKING ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION. WE INEVITABLY
RUN INTO PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SOCCER FIELDS ARE
GROCERY STORES TALKING ABOUT
THEIR NEIGHBOR THEIR CHILD
THEIR GRANDSON OR NEPHEW
SOMEONE THEY KNOW WHO HAS.
STELLAR HIGH SCHOOL. GRADES AND
TEST. NO LONGER NEED THE DEATH
TEST SCORES BUT BUT A STELLAR
GRADES THEIR- APPLYING TO THE
UC AND THEY CAN IN IN SO BEEN A
PRIOR FOR. ALL NUMBER AND
BUDGET TAKING A I WORKED REALLY
TO. COME UP WITH THAT I CAP ON
NON RESIDENT ROLE MEANT
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENTS WHICH-
WE SUPPORT THERE ARE SOME
EFFORTS TO PUSH THAT DOWN WHICH
I KNOW MR TANG'S WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT A BIT. BUT WE HAVE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT ROMAN AS
YOU SEE ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
AGENDA IN A LARGE PART IT'S
BECAUSE- WE PUSHED A TARGET TO
THAT WE WANTED THAT- A NUMERIC
TARGET TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD. FALL
BACK ON FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
SHOWING THAT WE'RE INCREASING
ACCESO A UC HAS HISTORICALLY
NOT WANTED THAT THEY WANT TO. A
LINE ITEM OVERALL FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET AND- YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT WE PUSHED BACK
HAVING IT AT TARGET AND SO I
KNOW THAT JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
YOU SEE REPORTED. THAT WE HAD A
RECORD NUMBER OF APPLICANTS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH IS
GREAT THAT SHOWS THAT MORE AND
MORE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING. COLLEGE READY A
THREE G. READY- WE HAVE A BIG
INCREASE IN LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN APPLICANTS AS WE KNOW.
ESPECIALLY WITH LATINO
APPLICANTS WE KNOW THAT THE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION NUMBERS
ARE JUST CHANGED DRAMATICALLY
OVER THE YEARS AND SO MORE AT
MORE STUDENTS. IT'S HAPPENING
ON THE NATURAL ANYWAY BUT
NONETHELESS. YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
PLEASED ABOUT THAT WHAT WHAT
CAN WE- DO. TO GUARANTEE MORE
ADDRESS. WHAT WE HAVE- INCLUDE
RESTORED THE MONEY FROM LAST
YEAR WE HAD THE BASE INCREASE
FOR JANUARY YOU'RE ASKING FOR
MORE MORE FEDERAL MONEY COMING
IN THAT'S THAT'S ONE TIME PER
SE NON OWNER BUT WE WANT TO
LOCK IN. INCREASE IN DEMAND-
YOU SEE ENROLLMENT ABOVE THE
CURRENT YEAR FOR NEXT YEAR SO
WHAT CAN YOU SEE. IN OUTLINED
TODAY THE COMMITMENTS ARE MORE.
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA FRESHMEN
STUDENTS NOT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION START- FOR YOU TO
CHOOSE TO PROVIDE ENROLLMENT
FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY WE
REQUEST THAT WE RECEIVE THE
FULL MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION FOR EACH NEW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE US TO ENROLL IN
ORDER FOR US TO ENROLL MORE
STUDENTS WE ARE YOU NEED THAT
BASS RESTORATION AND WE DO NEED
OUR CAMPUS COST INCREASES
COVERED IN ADDITION TO THAT.
NEW ENROLLMENT FUNDING IF YOU
WOULD CHOOSE TO PROVIDE IT TO
US- ALSO HE- CLOSING EQUITY
GAPS LANGUAGE ARE- FUNDING THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING THE THIRTY
POINT FOUR MILLION FOR THAT.
WOULD ALLOW US TO START MOVING
SOME STUDENTS THROUGH THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM FASTER WE
HAVE A CURRENTLY MOST OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE TAKING FOR YEARS
AND ONE TERM. TO GRADUATE AND
IF WE GOT THEM TO GRADUATE A
LITTLE BIT FASTER WE WOULD- BE
ABLE TO INCREASE OUR EACH
INCOMING OR COURT. APPLIED THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT WE GET
TO GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS YEAH.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S QUITE WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT I THINK THAT
WE WERE GIVING THE BASE
INCREASE OF 3% WE'RE INCREASING
THAT THAT. WE'RE RESTORING THE
CUTS FROM LAST YEAR. AND YOU
KNOW WE THINK WITHIN THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE A LINE ITEM. FOR IN
ROME AND THAT'S WHAT WE WILL BE
HAPPY. GLOBAL COMPETITION ARE
BY IN A THINK HE KNOW THAT'S
THE THAT'S GOAL OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS THAT. YOU KNOW
THE TRUST BUT VERIFY I THINK
THAT- WHEN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON OUR TOP
PRIORITY- AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ADEQUATE RESPONSE BUT
THIS IS. THAT'S YOUR POSITION
AS YOU SEE AS WE GO TO GO
THROUGH THIS DANCE EVERY YEAR
SO WE WILL. SPEND OUR FINAL
BUDGET WILL FOCUS ON IT AROMA
TARGET TO MAKE SURE WE-
INCREASE ACCESS- FOR
CALIFORNIANS. I WILL FIGHT I
ALSO FOUGHT I KNOW THERE
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS ON
THIS ISSUE ALL DAHLE STOP HERE.
I MAY COME BACK I KNOW THAT I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT- IT'S
NOT. QUITE A CHEN DICE HERE BUT
AS FAR AS ENROLLMENT AND ACCESS
FOR UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT TERM IT
DENIED OTHERS THE WORKING ON.
IS ADMISSIONS AND ADMISSIONS-
REFORMS THAT YOU SEE HAVE BEEN
TAKING TAKEN SENSE- THE
ADMISSIONS- YOU KNOW- SCANDAL A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. WITH WE SAW
WITH YOU KNOW WEALTHY DONORS
AND SLAVERY AND SO FORTH GAME
IN THE UC SYSTEM SO WE HAD.
SOME REFORMS TWO YEARS AGO THE
STATE AUDITOR CAME OUT WITH
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS I KNOW MR
GALLAGHER WHEN ASKED IF WE
COULD SPOKE ASKED IF HE COULD.
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
TODAY SO IT'S NOT A GEN DIS SAY
HOW BUT I IF YOU COULD PLEASE
HELP US AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES SO- WITH THAT-
MISTER MEDINA. THANK YOU ARE.
YOU MENTIONED- UP. IN A OF. TO
YOU. AND WE MADE REFERENCE TO
THE DIVERSITY. AND OTHER THAN
THE NUMBER OF APPLICANTS. AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT I.
LIKE MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
EXCITED ABOUT. BUT- LAST WEEK
THERE WAS A- OP ED PIECE IN THE
LA TIMES THE TALKED ABOUT YOU
SEE. THE HAVES AND THE HAVE
NOTS. WONDER IF YOU MIGHT HAVE
SEEN THAT OP ED PIECE. IN THE
L. A. TIMES. DO SO SEE YA I
BLOCK THEM UC MERCED. THANK YOU
MR MEDINA- I BELIEVE THE ISSUE
HAS TO DO WITH YOU I'M NOT A
FUNDING FOR CAMPUS STUDENTS AND
HOW HE FUNDING WAS ALLOCATED
BETWEEN CAMPUSES- WHEN THE
STATE PROVIDES APPROPRIATIONS
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA- THE
WAY WE DIVIDE THE FUNDING WHEN
YOU APPROPRIATE FUNDS TO US. WE
PROVIDED TO OUR CAMPUSES FOR A
PROCESS CALLED RETENTION OF
FIRST FROM THOSE FUNDS YOU
PROVIDE TO US WE TAKE CERTAIN
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE ALL
STUDENTS- THOSE ARE FUNDED OFF
THE TOP THAT INCLUDES PROGRAMS
LIKE THEY PROP- AND CERTAIN OF
SYSTEM WHY PROGRAMS LIKE
AGRICULTURAL EXPERIMENT
STATIONS- THEN WE ALSO REMOVE
FINANCIAL AID- BECAUSE THAT
GETS DIVIDED. BETWEEN CAMPUSES
BASED ON STUDENT NEED- AND THEN
THE REMAINDER OF THOSE FUNDS
ARE PROVIDED CAMPUSES BASED ON
A FORMULA WHERE EACH
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT RECEIVES
THE SAME AMOUNT OF FUNDING THIS
WAS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
EQUALITY BETWEEN THE CAMPUSES.
NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN USING THE
SYSTEM FOR- MULTIPLE. HERE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. WE
REALIZE THAT THERE MAY SOME
ISSUES WITH HOW THE FUNDS ARE
TO. AND THE REGIONS ARE
EXAMINING THE FORMULA- WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT CHANGING IT TO
WHERE NO CAMPUS WHERE YOU'RE
RECEIVING- LESS THAN FIVE
PERCENT. OF IN THE UNWEIGHTED
STUDENT AMOUNT- FROM OTHER
CAMPUSES. AND THAT IS IT MUST
BE BETTER THAN WHAT AT THE 95%
SO YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
ISSUE. THE TWO AUTHORS- I
BELIEVE PROFESSORS AT UC MERCED
SOCIOLOGY IS ALSO. PUBLISHED A
RECENT BOOK CALLED BROKEN. THAT
EXAMINES THE FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY AT UC RIVERSIDE
AND UC MERCED SO A QUESTION AND
THEY THEY THEY COME TO SOME
VERY- I THINK STARTLING
PROVOCATIVE CONCLUSIONS SO IF
WE WERE TO SUBTRACT THE NUMBER
OF. OF LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS. IN UC FROM-
UC RIVERSIDE UC MERCED UC SANTA
BARBARA. AND UC SANTA CRUZ- WE
WOULD CERTAINLY HAVE A MUCH
LESS DIVERSE UC- THEN WE HAVE
AT PRESENT SO THE AUTHORS MAKE
THE POINT THAT YOU SEE IS ABLE
TO- YOU KNOW- EXPOUND ON ON THE
DIVERSITY OF THE UC- ENROLLMENT.
BUT THE AUTHORS POINT OUT THAT
THAT A LOT OF IT IS
CONCENTRATED AT UC RIVERSIDE
AND UC MERCED. WHICH HAPPENED
TO BE THE MOST UNDERFUNDED-
CAMPUSES OF THE UC SYSTEM- WE
TALK ABOUT OUT OF STATE AND
INTERNATIONAL STUDENT
ENROLLMENT AND I UNDERSTAND AS
ALL OF US DO HERE. HOW YOU SEE
HAS A RELIED ON THAT AS
ESPECIALLY DURING. THE TIME OF
LESS FUNDING FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT AS WE LOOK TO
SEE HOW WE CAN BETTER- B. MORE
EQUAL IN THE TREATMENT OF ALL
THE CAMPUSES. I DON'T MIGHT
PROPOSE THE IDEA THAT HAS BEEN
SUGGESTED BEFORE THAT THE
INCOME THE REVENUE THAT IS
PRODUCED BY INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS- AND- OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS BE DIVIDED. AMONG ALL
THE CAMPUSES BECAUSE CERTAINLY
NOT ALL THE CAMPUSES HAVE THE
SAME- RESOURCES TO ATTRACT. HOW
TO STATE AND INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS- SO I DO THINK THAT-
THE CONCLUSIONS THAT THE
AUTHORS COME OUT WITH IN THEIR
BOOK I IN THEIR OP ED PIECE IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT YOU
SEE NEEDS TO LOOK AT MORE MORE
CAREFULLY. BECAUSE OF THE OTHER
POINT IS THAT- THE FORMULAS
THAT HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR SO
LONG. WORKED TO THE DETRIMENT
OF THOSE MOST DIVERSE CAMPUSES
AND WORK FOR THE DETRIMENT TO
THE AREAS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT UNFORTUNATELY
ARE MORE IN THE HAVE NOTS THAN
THE HOUSE SO SOMETHING TO LOOK.
AT MORE CLOSELY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR GALLAGHER. IT WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO PAY FOR THE RESPONSE
FROM THAT- JUST ESTá OUT IF-
IF WE COULD MAYBE HAVE A
RESPONSE TO. THE IDEA OF
SHARING REVENUE. OF FOR
INTERNATIONAL AN OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS YEAH. CURRENTLY
STUDENTS ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
FOR THE FULL COST OF THEIR OWN
EDUCATION WHICH MEANS A LOT OF
THEIR FEES GO TO THE CAMPUS
WHERE THEY ARE SO THAT THE FULL
COST OF THEIR EDUCATION CAN BE
COVERED. EACH INTERNATIONAL
STUDENT DOES HOWEVER- HEY MORE
THAN WHAT IT COSTS TO EDUCATE
THEM SO THERE IS FUNDING LEFT
OVER FROM THE CAMPUS OF WHERE
THEY ARE CURRENTLY STUDYING.
THOSE FUNDS ARE BEING USED BY
THOSE CAMPUSES TO PAY FOR THEIR
FACULTY AND OTHER STUDENTS
SERVICES OR OPERATIONS ON BOTH
CAMPUSES SO IF THERE WAS ANY
MOVEMENT OFFUNDING AWAY WE
HAVE TO BE VERY COGNISANT. OF
SUDDEN DRASTIC REDUCTIONS TO
OUR CAMPUS BUDGET. THIS IS AN
IDEA THAT- I THINK WE SHOULD
TALK MUCH MORE. ABOUT- ONE ONE.
OF COURSE WOULD BE- IF JUST THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF NON RESIDENTS
WITH INCREASED SYSTEM WIDE. OR
REVENUE DISTRIBUTION BUT I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE A FAVOR OF
THAT IDEA BUT WE CAN HAVE A
FURTHER CONVERSATION THANK YOU
SIR. I YEAH I ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE WHAT WHAT MR
MEDINA SAID ABOUT THE DIVERSE
CITY NUMBERS WITH THE TWO
THINGS ONE. THE LATINO HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATE HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY IN THE
LAST TEN TWENTY YEARS THE
NUMBER OF LATINO GRADUATES WHO.
ARE A THREE G. READY AND YOU
SEE ELIGIBLE SO YOU SEE
OBVIOUSLY IS TAKE NOTE OF THAT
AND PATTING OURSELVES ON THE
BACK FOR THAT. OKAY BUT I THINK
MR MEDINA'S POINT IS WELL TAKEN
IF YOU LOOK AT. THE THAT NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES YOU KNOW
IF YOU REALLY THAT THAT THREE
OF THE MOST SOUGHT AFTER WITH
UCLA. BERKELEY AND- SAN DIEGO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THE
DIVERSEY NUMBERS FOR THOSE.
THOSE ARE STILL VERY
DISCOURAGING FOR US AS AS AS
GOOD AS DATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
AFTER SO KEEP THAT IN MIND- MR
GALLAGHER. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- SO. YOU'RE RUNNING
SOME OF THE NUMBERS. YOU SEE
ENROLLMENT GREW BY SEVEN POINT
6% FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. HOWEVER WITHIN
THIS GROWTH NONRESIDENT ROAMING
GREW BY 17% WELL RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT GREW BY FIVE POINT
7% THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS AS A
RESULT OF THE CORONA VIRUS
PANDEMIC NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT
DECLINED. FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY BY THREE POINT
7% WELL RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
GREW SLIGHTLY BY ABOUT 1% SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU SEE IS DOES
THIS PRESENT AN OPPORTUNITY
NOW. FOR YOU SEE TO RE BALANCE
THE RATIOS OF NON RESIDENT AND
RESIDENT ENROLLMENT ESPECIALLY
AT CAMPUSES LIKE BERKELEY AND
UCLA WITH THE HISTORY OF MORE
THAN 18% NONRESIDENT.
ENROLLMENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SIR- WE DON'T THINK
THAT THIS IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
TO REBALANCE OUR NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT BECAUSE THE STUDENTS
DO YOU ONLY A LOT OF MONEY TO
ALL THE CAMPUSES WHERE THEY
ATTEND- AND IF WE REMOVE THOSE
FUNDS FROM THE CAMPUS BUDGETS.
THEY WILL HAVE TO MAKE CUTS TO
EXISTING SERVICES. THANK YOU.
OKAY WELL I MEAN I THINK LIKE
YOU'VE HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUES
I DON'T FEEL LIKE THAT'S AN
ACCEPTABLE ANSWER- YOU KNOW FOR
ALL THE REASONS STATED BEFORE
BUT MOST ESPECIALLY YOU ARE A
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
SYSTEM AND WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY
WANTED OUT OF YOU THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE WANT IS
TO SEE THAT THOSE RATIOS. NINE
GET TO WHERE THEY SHOULD BE
WHICH IS THE SHOULD BE- SYSTEM
THAT SERVES. FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SO I MEAN I THINK YOU
KNOW EXACTLY WHERE WE'RE GOING
FROM THERE BUT I THINK FOR US.
WE'RE HEARING VERY CLEARLY FROM
YOU SEE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
PLANS- SO I THINK THAT SHOULD
GO INTO OUR PLANNING AS- HOW WE
WANT TO HELP. HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS- ON THE ISSUE OF.
ANOTHER VERY FRUSTRATING THING
FOR ME I WENT TO UC BERKELEY I
WAS VERY FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE
TO GO THERE BUT YOU KNOW I
WORKED REALLY HARD. YEAH YOU
KNOW IN HIGH SCHOOL AND- NO DID
THE WORK OUT A LOT OF SUPPORT
FROM MY COMMUNITY AND WAS
FORTUNATE TO GET IN THERE I'LL
TELL YOU WHAT I NEVER HAD
ANYBODY WRITING A LETTER FROM
ME. THERE WAS NO TRUSTEE.
WRITING A LETTER FOR ME TO GET
ME INTO- UC BERKELEY- SO IT'S
VERY. FRUSTRATING TO HEAR OF
EVEN AFTER THE SCANDAL. YOU
KNOW FOR THIS AUDIT TO COME
OUT. AND SHOW THAT LOOK THESE
PRACTICES ARE STILL HAPPENING
AT UC. CAMPUSES THOSE WHO HAVE.
FRIENDS IN HIGH PLACES ARE
GETTING IN. AND STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF AND MANY STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THIS- YOU KNOW
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. MANY
STUDENTS OF COLOR WHO HAVE
WORKED REALLY HARD AND HAVE AND
HAVE GOTTEN THE GRADES AND I'VE
GOTTEN THE SCORES- THEY DIDN'T
GET THAT PLACE. IN IN THE AUDIT
SHOWS A VERY CLEARLY THERE'S
PEOPLE THAT DID NOT GET THAT
PLACE IN THAT SEAT. AND INSTEAD
SOMEONE WHO HAD CONNECTIONS-
EVEN CASES OF YEP TRUSTEES UC
REGENTS WHO WROTE LETTERS ARE
NO BIG DEAL I WROTE IT FOR MY
COUSINS KIDS. IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
YEAH I DO THAT ALL THE TIME. HE
GETS IN. THAT'S A PROBLEM AND
SO WHAT I DO WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU SEE IS. WHAT HAVE YOU DONE.
TO ENSURE THAT THIS DOESN'T
EVER HAPPEN AGAIN THAT YOU WHAT
WHAT CHANGES HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
MADE. YOU KNOW SO THAT.
REGION'S MAJOR DONORS.
POLITICALLY CONNECTED PEOPLE
ARE NOT ABLE TO INFLUENCE THAT
ADMISSIONS PROCESS IN THE WAY
THAT WE KNOW IS DOCUMENTED DID
HAPPEN. AT YOU SEE WHAT CHANGES
HAVE WE IMPLEMENTED AND WHAT
CHANGES ARE WE GOING TO WHAT
OTHER CHANGES ARE WE GOING TO
IMPLEMENT IT YOU SEE. TO ENSURE
THAT THIS IS. EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL EDUCATION. THANK YOU
SIR AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING BURKE
FAMILY SCHOOL STUDENTS WORK
VERY VERY HARD TO GET INTO UC
TO HEAR ABOUT INSTANCES LIKE.
SOME OF THE CHANGES THE PROCESS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IS THAT-
OTHER OFFICES WITH IN THE
CAMPUS LIKE THE DEVELOPMENT
OFFICE- THAT'S THE FUNDRAISING
ARE NO LONGER ALLOWED TO HAVE
CONTACT WITH EMISSIONS OFFICE
REGARDING. APPLICATIONS WE'RE
ALSO IMPLEMENTING- A MULTI
STARRER READING YOU ARE
STUDENTS WHO ARE- GETTING IN
THROUGH THE ADMISSIONS BY
EXCEPTION PROCESS THAT IS THE
STUDENTS WHO OF FOR SOME REASON
DON'T HAVE- HIGH SCHOOL GRADES
OR- HAVE SOME OTHER ISSUE.
THROUGH WHICH THEY ARE GETTING
INTO THE UNIVERSITY- SO THOSE
WERE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
AUDITOR THERE ARE EMPLOYMENT
AND- WE DO HAVE A TEAM OF
INTERNAL AUDITORS WHO ARE
LOOKING AT THE- CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
TO SEE HOW THEY CAN IMPLEMENT
THAT. WITHIN THE UC SYSTEM AND
TO MAKE. THE PROCESS BETTER FOR
ALL STUDENTS. IBM IN OF THOSE.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME. I DON'T
HAVE THE LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS IN FRONT OF ME
TO SAY HOW MANY OF THEM WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED IT BUT I BELIEVE
THAT TWO OF THOSE HAVING THE
MULTI STEP PROCESS OF REVIEW OR
ADMISSIONS BY EXCEPTION AND-
I'M NOT ALLOWING ANY CONTACT
WITH THE DEVELOPING OFFICE.
WERE AUDITORS RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN- COULD YOU I
WOULD LIKE IF YOU GUYS COULD
REPORT BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE
YOU KNOW THROUGH A LETTER- NO
STADIUM WHICH RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU GUYS HAVE AGREED TO
IMPLEMENT. WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
DO THAT. YES SIR WE CAN DO THAT
FOR YOU- WILL WILL REGION'S BE
ABLE TO WRITE LETTERS OF
SUPPORT FOR ADMISSION EXACTLY
IS THAT PROCESS GOING TO
CONTINUE. I BELIEVE THAT
PROCESS- WILL NOT BE CONTINUING
AS WELL. THAT WILL BE ENDED.
OKAY WILL BE GOOD ENOUGH THAT'S.
IT WOULD YOU BELIEVE IT WILL OR
WILL. I'M SORRY SIR I DON'T
HAVE THE LIST OF ACTIONS IN
FRONT OF ME TO SAY WITH
COMPLETE CERTAINTY BUT WE WILL
GET YOU A LETTER THAT OUTLINES
WHICH ACTIONS UNIVERSITY HAS
TAKEN. AND WHICH WE ARE STILL
EXAMINING. OKAY WILL BE GOOD
JUST TO GET A DEFINITIVE LIST
AND SOMETHING THAT'S CLEAR WHAT
WHAT ARE YOU DOING THAT'S
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING FOR.
THANK YOU I'M I'LL JUST WANNA
NOTE MR GALLAGHER THAT THIS WAS
A VERY. DISTURBING- US DAYS
WERE VERY DISTURBING STORIES
BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE THAN ONE
THAT CAME OUT A FEW YEARS AGO
WE HAD A PACKAGE OF BILLS AND
IT WAS OPERATION VARSITY BLUES
OF COURSE AND- FEDERAL
INDICTMENTS AND- PEOPLE WENT TO
PRISON INCLUDING NOTABLE
CELEBRITIES WHICH MADE THE NEWS
BUT- IT JUST. YOU KNOW IT SHOOK
THE CONFIDENCE OF THE UC.
ADMISSIONS AND IT'S GOOD CUT
THAT COUPLES WITH THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE MORE STUDENTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY. AND EVEN IF
IT WAS HALF A DOZEN OR DOZEN OR
WHATEVER THIS THAT'S A SLOT
THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE FOR
SOMEBODY WHO'S QUALIFIED SO. WE
DID IT DOT SOME REFORMS- I
ADDED I HAD A BILL IN THERE MR
TEEING IT- QUICK SILVA AND-
TASHA BOERNER HORVATH HAD AN
AUDIT THAT- THE WORK STILL
CONTINUES OUR THREE BILL'S
GOING TO THE HIRING COMMITTEE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS GONNA BE
EVALUATING THIS YEAR. BUT IN
THAT OUR FINAL BUDGET ACTION I
THINK WE WILL DO SOME OVERSIGHT
ON THIS AND REQUEST SOMETHING
THAT YOU JUST BROUGHT UP MR
GALLAGHER. IS TO HAVE YOU SEE
MAKE SURE THEY CAN REPORT. AND
THESE THINGS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE WHAT WHAT
THE AUDITOR FOUND OUT. IS THAT
EVEN WITH THE REFORMS THAT WE
ADOPTED THERE ARE STILL SOME
PIECES THAT WERE. SLIPPING
THROUGH THE CRACK AND DOCTOR
CHOI HAS A BILL TO WORK ON ONE
OF THOSE ISSUES AS WELL SO.
IT'S AN ONGOING. ISSUE THAT
THAT WE THINK IS OF CONCERN
WE'RE GONNA KEEP KEEP AT IT
AND- LIKE I SAID EARLIER YOU
KNOW. TRUST BUT VERIFY TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU SEE IS STEPPING
UP AND DOING RIGHT. BY THIS- I
WITH THAT- MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU KNOW STATURE JUST
JUMPING ON YOUR COMMENTS TO MR
GALLAGHER'S COMMENTS. DID YOU
KNOW OF ANY UC REGENTS WROTE
LETTERS THIS YEAR. IN SUPPORT
OF ANY POTENTIAL. ENROLLEES IN
THE UC SAN. I DO NOT HAVE THAT
INFORMATION SIR I DON'T. THAT
THAT THAT SHOULD BE BANNED I
MEAN THAT THAT'S A NO BRAINER
TO ME ESPECIALLY AS WE PULL
AWAY FROM THE SAT AND THE ACT.
IT BECOMES MORE OF A
QUALITATIVE EXERCISETHAT A
QUANTITATIVE EXERCISE QUITE
FRANKLY IN ENROLLING STUDENTS.
AND IT SHOULDN'T BE. WHO YOU
KNOW WHAT SHOULD BE WHAT YOU
CAN DO. SO THAT THAT THAT'S OF
GREAT CONCERN TO ME AND AS WE-
GET RID OF SOME OF THESE
STANDARDIZED TESTS THIS IS A
NATURAL THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN- SO WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL TO IT TOO. TO MONITOR
THIS BECAUSE I AM VERY
CONCERNED AS WE GET AGAIN READ
THESE TESTS. SO HOW DO YOU GET
ADMITTED. IS IT JUST GPA OR IS
IT HEY A GPA PLUS WHO YOU KNOW
THESE LETTERS YET WHAT IS A
RECOMMENDATION WILL. A LOT OF
TIMES IT MATTERS WHO THE LETTER
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM QUITE
FRANKLY- AND NOT EVERY STUDENT
POTENTIAL STUDENT. HAS ACCESS
TO CERTAIN YOU KNOW. NO LEVELS
OF POWER IN THE STATE QUITE
FRANKLY AND- THAT'S THAT'S OF
GREAT CONCERN TO ME AND THAT'S
SOMETHING- I THINK WE SHOULD
MONITOR AS AS AS A LEGISLATURE
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF FOLKS
AROUND HER SUPPORT GETTING RID
OF SOME THESE STANDARDIZED
TESTS. ARE THEY GIVE ME A BIT
OF CONCERN. BECAUSE THAT WHAT
NEXT WHAT THEN DO WE GO TO IS
IT ONLY TO STUDENTS AT ADDED
ACCESS TO OUR HONORS CLASSES IN
HIGH SCHOOL AP CLASSES. WHERE
THOSE WHO DIDN'T DON'T GET THAT
HIGHER GPA. DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HIGH THAT TO
HAVE THAT HIGHER GPA OR-
INTERNATIONAL BACCALAUREATE
STUDENTS EAGER HIGH SCHOOL
DOESN'T HAVE. AN IB PROGRAM.
MIGHT YOU NOT THEN BE ABLE TO
GET INTO THE UC SO THERE'S A
LOT BILL TEND. TO THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS THE
ADMITTANCE PROCESS. HOLDING TO
RECOGNIZE THAT JUST FOLLOWING
TWO GPA AND RECOMMENDATIONS MAY
NOT BE THE BEST PRACTICE SO I
HOPE I HOPE THE UC IS THINKING
ABOUT I HAVE A KIND OF A SIMPLE
QUESTION IS PROBABLY SOMETHING
I SHOULD HAVE ASKED SEVEN YEARS
AGO BUT IT MORE IS ABOUT YOUR
BUDGET PRACTICE AND IT'S
OUTSIDE REALLY THE STUDENTS
ARENA I'D CALL YOUR ENTERPRISE
ARENA LIKE YOUR HOSPITALS. SO
JUST A QUESTION WITH REGARD TO
LET'S SAY YOUR HOSPITALS THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH WHAT I WOULD LABEL
ENTERPRISE FUNCTION RIGHT
SEPARATE. MOSTLY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY. SO WHAT LIKE. WHEN
THERE'S A HOSPITAL I'M SEEING
SOME THINGS ON HERE. RETIREMENT
HELP BENEFIT INCREASE INCREASES
CAPITAL OUTLAY. I WOULD ASSUME
THAT A HOSPITAL ON THE UC PIECE
OF PROPERTY LEASES THAT
PROPERTY FROM THE UC I WOULD
ASSUME THAT THEY- OUR TAKE AND
FUNNY THEIR PORTION. OF THE
BENEFIT INCREASES OF EITHER
CURRENT EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE RETIRED IS THE GENERAL
FUND THE STATE GENERAL FUND IS
NOT SUPPORTING THAT. THE THOSE
INCREASES BUT THOSE THOSE THOSE
MONIES COME FROM WITHIN THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM OR THE
ENTERPRISE. EFFORT IN OF ITSELF
WOULD THAT BE ACCURATE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SIR. YES
THAT'S ACCURATE THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM AND THE OTHER
ANCILLARIES LIKE THE
DORMITORIES AND PARKING. HEY
THERE US SHARE OF THE COST
INCREASES WHAT WE COME HERE AND
REQUEST FROM THE LEGISLATURE IS
JUST FOR FUNDS ON THE CAMPUSES
THE- TUITION AND THE STATE
GENERAL FUND. COMPONENT. OF
THOSE COST INCREASES. SO I I'M
NOT SURE I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
YOUR COMPLETELY UNDERSTOOD YOUR
YOUR ANSWER THERE SO THERE IS A
WALL SO IF THERE IS- COST
INCREASES THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
THOSE EMPLOYEES THAT RETIRED
FROM THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM FOR
EXAMPLE IT WOULD BE WAITED AND
THAT THEY WOULD BE THAT THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM WOULD BE
BURDENED WITH THOSE OUT YOUR
INCREASES AS WELL. EIGHT WHAT
ONE STATE EMPLOYEE RETIRES
THEY'RE GETTING BENEFITS FROM
THE RETIREMENT PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE GETTING FEET UP FROM
THE INTEREST THAT THAT. THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDS IN THERE.
IS ACCUMULATING AND THE MONEY'S
COMING OUT OF THAT HOLE. BEFORE
THEY RETIRE THERE ARE PAYMENTS
TOWARD THEIR RETIREMENT ARE
BEING PAID BY THE HOSPITAL
ENTIRELY SO THE CENTRAL IF IT'S
A HOSPITAL EMPLOYEE THE CENTRAL
CAMPUS IS NOT PAYING TO WORK
THERE THAT INDIVIDUALS
RETIREMENT OR THEIR HEALTHCARE
OR ANY OTHER EMPLOYEE COST
EXPENDITURES THOSE WOULD BE
COVERED ENTIRELY BY THE
HOSPITAL SO YES THERE IS A
FIREWALL BETWEEN THOSE EXPENSES
HE EVEN IN THE OUTER SO THEY'RE
RETIRED NOW. RIGHT THEN ALL
SUDDEN WELL WE FIND OUT THAT
THE PENSION SYSTEM IS STRESSED
AND IT NEEDS ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
THE HOSPITAL BE BURDEN FOR
THEIR PORTION. OF THAT STRESS
IF YOU WILL. IS THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM HAS TO PAY FOR THE
EXPENSES RELATED TO ANY
OPERATION OF THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM THAT INCLUDES THEIR
CAPITAL OUTLAY DEBT SERVICE YOU
KNOW ALL THE BONDS- ANY LEASE
REVENUES SO FOUR. BUT THE WAY
THE RETIREMENT PROGRAM WORKS IN
UNIVERSITY PUTS- PAYMENTS INTO
THE TOTAL PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF
ALL OUR EMPLOYEES AND WHEN THAT
EMPLOYEE RETIRES THEY CLAIM
THOSE FUNDS BACK FROM THE
RETIREMENT PROGRAM. WELL THEY
THEY WOULD FILE FOR THEIR
PENSION RIGHT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
CORRECT. AND IN THE OUT IN THE
OUT YEARS. WE FIND THAT. MAYBE
THAT WAS THAT WAS UNDER FUNDED.
AND GENERAL FUND DOLLARS ARE
USED TO SUPPORT THAT SHOULDN'T
TO THE HOSPITAL. OR THE
ENTERPRISE EFFORT FUND THAT.
FROM THE BENCH I'M USING A
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE YES AND I BUT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ENTERPRISE FUNDS ARE SUPPORTING
EITHER THE- BUT NOW IN THE LAB.
WITH REGARD TO THE OUT YOUR
COSTUME. I'M NOT SURE YOUR
ANSWER MY QUESTION MAYBE YOU
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION AND
ANSWER TODAY. IF YOU CAN
RESEARCH THAT AND GET BACK TO
ME AND I'M VERY MUCH
APPRECIATIVE AGAIN MIKE MY
QUESTION. ARE THE ENTERPRISE
FUNDS- PARTICIPATING IN. IN IN
SOME OF THE- THE LONG TERM
EXPENSES NOT JUST TODAY NOT
JUST WRITING A CHECK TODAY HEY
WE'RE DONE. BUT THERE MIGHT BE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH WITH WITH
WITH THEIR OPERATIONS IN THE
OUT YEARS THAT THEN ARE
BURDENED ON TO THE GENERAL FUND.
IT IS CORRECT THAT OUR
RETIREMENT PROGRAM IS NOT- AT
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. FUNDING
CURRENTLY YOU SEE R. P- DOES
DOES HAVE- SOME UNFUNDED
LIABILITY CURRENTLY I WOULD
NEED TO HAVE- AN EXPERT COME
AND SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT THAT WE
DO HAVE AN ACTUARIAL ANALYSIS.
THANK REPORTED ANNUALLY THANK
YOU YOUR I THINK WE GOT TIED UP
ON THE PENSION FUND IT'S NOT
JUST THE PENSION FUND IN ASKING
ABOUT- SO BUT I THINK I ASK THE
QUESTION AND PROBABLY IN A
REQUIRE FURTHER RESEARCH SO WE
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION OFFLINE
DOWN THE ROAD. WHEN MAYBE WE
CAN GATHER SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON M. AND AGAIN MY
CONCERN IS THAT THE GENERAL
FUND THE BURDEN. WITH
ENTERPRISE FUND- COSTS. AYE
THERE'S MOSTLY LONG TERM BUT WE
CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AT A
DIFFERENT DAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VITAS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
SO THE PROPOSED BUDGET LANGUAGE
DOESN'T IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
EQUITY GOALS TO BE ACHIEVED BUT
IT REQUIRES A YOU SEE THE
REPORT. TWO A DETAILED
ACTIONABLE SPECIFIC PLANS TO
ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF FULLY
CLOSING EQUITY GAPS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE SO WHAT EQUITY
GOALS IS THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTING THE PLANS TO REFLECT
IN A CHEAP BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND SINCE ARE NOT
SPECIFIED HOW IS YOU SEE
INTERPRETING- WHAT EQUITY GOALS-
ARE. THE FIRST QUESTION IS A
DEMONSTRATION. BRIAN RUTLEDGE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SO I CAN
ADDRESS THE WHAT THE
EXPECTATION IS AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUE CAN RESPOND AT ARE
THEY MIGHT INTERPRET IT BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING AN
AMBITIOUS BUT ACHIEVABLE-
INCREASE IN IN ADDRESSING
EQUITY GAPS. BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. WE VIEW THIS AS A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES WERE
PROPOSING HERE. THE REAL. THE
REAL ISSUE THAT YOU'RE RAISING
HERE OUR FOCUS IS ON ALIGNING
THE VARIOUS SEGMENTS SO WE'RE
NOT CALLING OUT OF SPECIFIC
WHAT'S DEFINED THANK YOU EQUITY
TAX HERE AND THE REASON IS
BECAUSE I WAS AS THE L. A. O.
NOTES- AND AS WE WORK WITH OUR
OUR PARTNERS OVER THE YEARS
THEY THEY EACH OF THE SEGMENTS
HAS EXISTING EQUITY GOALS. BUT
WE DON'T WANT TO SPECIFIED UP
FRONT BEFORE THEY CAN GET
TOGETHER- THAT'S WHY WE HAVE. A
DATE FOR SETTING THESE GOALS A
YEAR OUT FROM NOW SO THAT THEY
THE SEGMENTS TO WORK TOGETHER
TO ALIGN THE DEFINITIONS AND
METRICS. SO THAT WE'RE ALL
MOVING IN THE SAME DIRECTION
AND MOVING ON THE SAME TIMELINE
SO THAT'S OUR PERSPECTIVE- I'LL
PASS IT OFF TO SAY HERE. THANK
YOU IN TERMS OF THE UNIVERSITY
WE- DO HAVE A PLAN FOR CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS- THAT'S OUR
FRAMEWORK TWENTY THIRTY GOALS
THAT COST SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION- THE WAY WE ARE
DEFINING AN EQUITY GAP. IS THE
TIME IT TAKES A STUDENT TO
GRADUATE SO WHAT WE ARE FINDING
IS THOSE STUDENTS ARE PELL
ELIGIBLE TAKE LONGER TO
GRADUATING STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
FOR EXAMPLE- AND BY CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS WE WOULD. TAKE
ACTIONS LIKE ADDITIONAL ONE BY
USING- HIRING FACULTY TO TEACH
BOTTLENECK COURSES AND SO FORTH
IT GETS TUDENTS THROUGH FASTER
SO THAT THEY'RE GRADUATING. AT
THE SAME RATE THAT'S OUR GOAL.
THANK YOU AND MY NEXT QUESTION
HERE IS RATHER THAN CREATING A
NEW DUAL IMMERSION PATHWAY.
WHICH WOULD ONLY STIR FIRST
TIME FRESHMAN APPLICANTS ARE
THERE OTHER WAYS TO STREAMLINE
OR EXPAND EXISTING TRANSFER
PATHWAYS BETWEEN UC AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND. ONE OF
THEIR UC'S A PREFERRED UC'S
UPON SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF
CLEARLY IDENTIFY TRANSFER
COURSES OTHER LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND WHY WOULDN'T WE BE
ALSO- ADDING THIS TO THE EQUITY
GOALS PLAN. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
WE CAN INCREASE TRANSFERS BASED
ON THE EXISTING SYSTEMS AS OUR
NEW TRANSFER PATHWAYS PLUS
PROGRAM. WHERE THE STUDENT IS
GUARANTEED ADMISSION TO
SPECIFIC CAMPUS BUT ALSO
THROUGH COMPLETING THE TRANSFER
PATHWAYS AND- ANY. UC CAMPUS SO
LET'S SAY THEY WANT TO GO TO UC
IRVINE- AND COMPLETE THE
TRANSFER PATHWAY BUT THEN
DECIDED THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY RATHER GO TO UC SANTA
BARBARA- THEY WILL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR BOTH CAMPUSES SO WE ARE
TRYING TO ELIMINATE THOSE
BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS. OUR
FACULTY ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
ON THIS AND THAT THIS DEBATE TO
COMPLETE THE WORK BY TWENTY
TWENTY TO- I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WHEN WE GUARANTEED
ADMISSION FOR A GROUP OF
STUDENTS. IF WE DON'T INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF SEATS AVAILABLE
IN THE ENTIRE SYSTEM WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS PUSHING SOME
STUDENTS AWAY WHILE OTHERS ARE
GUARANTEED ADMISSION. SO THAT
WOULD BE AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER S. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. REGARDING THE
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS- IT YOUR
NOTED THAT INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS PAY MORE THAN THE COST
TO EDUCATE THEM. AND AT I AM A
LITTLE CONCERNED WITH THAT THAT
WOULD BE SUCH AN IMPORTANT.
STATEMENT TO MAKE- THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PAYS FOR
THE EDUCATION OF SO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS I THINK THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DESERVES TO HAVE
GREATER DIFFERENCE WHEN IT
COMESTO WHAT IS DONE WITH OUR
STUDENTS AND WHAT IS DONE ON
OUR CAMPUSES I THINK WITH THE
QUESTIONS ASKED BY MY
COLLEAGUES REGARDING EQUITY I
AM EXTREMELY CONCERNED. OF THAT
THERE ISN'T A MORE DEFINITIVE
ANSWER ON WHAT WILL BE DONE TO
INCREASE EQUITY ESPECIALLY WITH
OURLATINO STUDENTS AND OUR OUR
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS- AS
COMPARED TO INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS SO THE- I WILL ASK THE
QUESTION AGAIN I KNOW THAT IT'S
BEEN ASKED. SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WILL BE DONE TO INCREASE EQUITY
FOR OUR LATINO AND BLACK
STUDENTS. IT SPECIFICALLY WITH
ADMISSIONS TO THE UC'S. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- IN
REGARDS TO. INCREASING STUDENT
EQUITY WE ARE REQUESTING THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP CLOSE
GRADUATION GAPS WITH WHICH WE
WOULD- HIRE ADDITIONAL
ADVISORS- WE FIND THAT STUDENTS
ARE FROM LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS
DO MUCH BETTER WHEN THEY HAVE
ROUTINE AND FREQUENT MEETINGS
WITH ACADEMIC ADVISORSAND
VISORS ON CAMPUS WHO CAN HELP
THEM WITH FINANCIAL AID AND
BASIC NEEDS. AND ACTIVITIES
LIKE THAT- IN THE CURRENT YEAR
YOU SEE WAS TAKING ACTIONS TO.
UP BUDGETARY SERVICE- WE SHOP
EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED PLUS
MILLION DOLLAR CUT- IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET AND WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO INCREASE SERVICES
BECAUSE WE'RE BALANCING- OUR
FUNDING BUT WE WERE ABLE TO USE
THE SERVICE AND FEDERAL FUNDS
TO NOT HAVE IT CUTS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. THOSE ARE ONE
TIME ACTION SO WE DO APPRECIATE
THE RESTORATION WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE SERVICES
AT OUR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY LEVELS FOR OUR STUDENTS-
IN ORDER EXPAND SERVICES
BECAUSE CAMPUSES ARE ALREADY
USING. ALL OF THESE FUNDS WE
HAVE VERY LITTLE IN RESERVES-
WE DO NEED. MORE FUNDING IN
ORDER TO HIRE PEOPLE WHO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES WERE VERY
PEOPLE BERMAN INSTITUTION- MOST
OF OUR FUNDING GOES TO SALARIES
AND BENEFITS. AND SO IN ORDER
TO INCREASE- THE NUMBER OF
COURSES IN ORDER TO INCREASE-
NUMBER SERVICES BEING PROVIDED.
WE DO NEED TO HIRE PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF WHAT IS BEING
CURRENTLY FUNDED UNIVERSITY
DOES HAVE ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED. CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS FOR WHOM WE HAVEN'T
RECEIVED ANY MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION BERMAN ADMITTED
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN. SO THAT-
GREATER NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN
OUR SYSTEM FOR HOME HAD NO
FUNDING. MEANS THAT THERE'S
FEWER DOLLARS REALLY PER
STUDENT. GOING AROUND THANK YOU.
IF I'M MISTER. IF SEEMS TO ME
THAT THAT M. IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THE ANSWER IS. THIS IS THE
MONEY WE HAVE IN THIS IS HOW
WE'RE CHOOSING TO SPEND IT AND
IT'S NOT ON INCREASING EQUITY.
I THINK THAT TO WEAR IT
WHENEVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EQUITY AND- WHATEVER WHATEVER
DECISION WE MAKE IT HAS TO BE
INTENTIONAL IF WE ARE INTENT ON
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF LATINO
THE NUMBER OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHICH HAVE BEEN UNDER
REPRESENTED AT UC'S. THE
DECISION HAS TO BE INTENTIONAL
AND EVEN WITH WHATEVER THE
LIMITED FUNDING IS WHATEVER THE
LIMITED BUDGET IS TO SAY THIS
IS A PRIORITY AND THIS IS HOW
WE WILL SPEND THE MONEY IF WHAT
WHAT WHAT YOU RECEIVE IF YOU'RE
SAYING IT ISN'T ENOUGH WE
CANNOT TAKE CARE OF THE ISSUE
OF EQUITY. THEN WHAT WOULD GIVE
US THE CONFIDENCE TO BELIEVE
THAT IF WE GIVE ANOTHER THIRTY
MILLION THAT REGULAR SLEEP IT
WILL NOW BE A PRIORITY. I AM
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AND
I SHARE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE
REGARDING THE ARTICLE THE OP ED
AND THE BOOK IT THAT HE HAS
MENTIONED I THINK THAT THESE
ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES AND I'D
LIKE TO SEE. MORE
INTENTIONALITY MORE OPEN MORE
OF AN INTENTIONAL ATTITUDE
TOWARDS INCREASING EQUITY. YEAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY SOMETHING FOR
SOME OF THE NEW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE TOO SO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
SAYING THAT THEY'VE BEEN ROLE
THE STUDENTS AND THE NOT
ADEQUATELY PAID BY THIS
MARGINAL COST- WELL THAT'S
THAT'S NOT TRUE AND HERE'S
HERE'S THE FAX TWO YEARS AGO WE
HAD THIS BOMBSHELL OF AN AUDIT
THAT TALKED ABOUT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT WAS SPLIT
SPENDING RESOURCES AND
SCROLLING MONEY AWAY THAT WE
DID NOT DEEM. WAS APPROPRIATE
WHEN WE HAD ALL THESE OTHER
NEEDS THAT WHEN WE BOIL DOWN TO
IT WE FOUND THAT THERE WERE
SOME OF THAT WAS ONE TIME SOME
OF THAT WAS ON GOING. SO WHAT
WE DID IS WE RE DIRECTED SOME
OF THAT MONEY FROM THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. COUPLED WITH
NEW MONEY GENERAL FUND MONEY TO
FUND ON GOING. TO ENROLLMENT
WHICH WAS THAT THE ADEQUATE.
MARGINAL COST YOU SEE SAYS THAT
WAS UNFAIR THEY ARE RE
LITIGATING- PRIOR BUDGET TWO
YEARS AGO SO PLEASE DON'T
CONFUSE US- WE KNOW EXACTLY
THAT YOU ARE COVERED THAT THE
AT THE AMOUNT. YOU THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA ISN'T LIKE A
DECISION THAT THAT WAS MADE.
BUT YOU ARE RECEIVING MONEY
THERE IS MONEY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY WHICH WAS
REDIRECTED. PLUS NEW GENERAL
FUND MONEY TO COVER. THE
MARGINAL COST FOR EACH
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS SO. THANK
YOU MISTER LEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ASEAN SEE HOW I
HAVE SOME RAPID FIRE QUESTIONS
ARE GONNA BE QUICK SHORT
ANSWERS SO. I WAS VERY WITH ME
ON THIS. IS IT ACCURATE TO SAY
THAT A RESIDENT PER YEAR THE
AVERAGE TUITION AND FEES OF
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA'S FOR
FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ROUGHLY. FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THIS IS THE RIGHT FEES ARE
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS FOR TUITION AND
STUDENT SERVICES AND EACH
CAMPUS HAS CERTAIN CAMPUS BASED
FEES. BY CAMPUS RIGHT TO THE
AVERAGE WOULD BE AROUND FORTY
THOUSAND AND THEN IS IT ALSO
ACTED TO SAY THE AVERAGE.
SYSTEMWIDE NONRESIDENT TUITION
AND FEES A YEAR IS FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. FORTY THREE
HUNDRED. THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT AND WOULD BE ACTED TO
SAY DOESN'T COST. TO EDUCATE A
NON RESIDENT OUT OF STATE OR
INTERNATIONAL THREE TIMES AS
MUCH AS A RESIDENT CALIFORNIA
CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT WE
REQUEST- ABOUT ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ELEVEN THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
FOR MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION THAT'S THE STATE
SHARE ON TOP OF THE TUITION-
FOR WHAT. WHAT WE ESTIMATED
COST TO EDUCATE A STUDENT
RIGHT. AND COMING FROM A
STUDENT ADVOCATE REALM ONLY
FOUR YEARS AGO THE UC SYSTEM I
RARELY AGREE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT IS WOULD IT
BE ACCURATE TO SAY THE MISSION
OF YOU SEE WHAT WE ACCURATE TO
SAY THAN THAT. ETHNONYM COMING
IN DOES NOT TAKE A SEAT AWAY
FROM A RESIDENT STUDENT BUT
BRINGS INTO OTHER STATES. THAT
IS CORRECT OUR NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS HELP PAY FOR RESIDENT
INSTRUCTION. WE DO HAVE. MORE
RESIDENT INSTRUCTION CURRENTLY
AND THEN- WE THINK WOULD BE
COVERED NECESSARILY- EIGHT NON
RESIDENTS ARE PAYING ABOUT 15%
OF OUR CAMPUS BUDGETS WHICH
HELPS PAY FOR SERVICES TO OUR
RESIDENT POPULATION AS WELL
RIGHT AND WITH ACADEMIC
COUNSELING DOES THAT COME OUT
OF THE TUITION AND FEES
STUDENTS PAY ACADEMIC HOUSING
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY FOR HELPING. ME
COUNSELING CAN BE PAID FOR WITH
A MIX OF STATE GENERAL FUND AND
TUITION. BURKE SO I BRING UP I
HIGHLIGHT THAT FACT ONLY
BECAUSE COMING FROM THAT WORLD
I WAS IN ONLY A COUPLE YEARS
AGO IS THAT. SO I DEFINITELY
AGREE WE NEED TO BE STEPPING UP
AND PROVIDING MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY MAKING
SURE THEY'RE TRANSFERRING FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL.
BUT I'M DON'T DISAGREE ABOUT
GROWING NON NON STATE AND NON
RESIDENT. SAN ROMAN AS LONG AS
IT IS BALANCED IN THEIR
APPROACH AND MAKING SURE WE
HAVE ENOUGH SEATS FOR EVERYONE.
THE REAL PROBLEM THAT I'VE SEEN
ON CAMPUSES AS WE GROW TOO
QUICKLY AND THOSE WHERE LIMITED
RESOURCES ON THE CAMPUSES. AND
SAYS AND TO THE FACT THAT IT'S
A- BLACK AND BROWN STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING. SEVERAL PERCENTAGE
POINTS MUCH LOWER THAN OTHER
STUDENTS IS INDICATIVE OF A LOT
OF DIFFERENT REASONS AND
ESPECIALLY AS TO HOW YOU NOTICE
BEFORE THEY YOU KNOW TO BEFORE
IS LACK OF ADVISING ELECT OUR
LACK OF ADVISING AND THE
INCREASE IN BOTTLENECK OF
COURSES. THE REAL PROBLEM I'VE
SEEN BEFORE AND I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU FIX THAT IN THE FRANKLY THE
THREE YEARS I'VE HAD BEEN
THERE. BUT IT IS A PROBLEM OF
THEIR TOO MANY STUDENTS TRYING
TO GET IN THE SAME CLASSES TOO
MANY STUDENTS TRYING TO ACCESS
THE SAME THE SAME RESOURCES AND
YET THE UC HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
FUND THOSE RESOURCES ADEQUATELY
OUR FUNDERS CLASS OFFERINGS
ADEQUATELY. SO THAT YOU KNOW IF
YOU MISS ONE CRITICAL REQUIRED
CLASS YOU COULD BE SET BACK ONE
YEAR REPORT PLUS AND THAT DELAY
THE GRADUATION RATE AND OFTEN.
AND I HAD MANY FIGHTS WITH MY
LOCAL MEASURES ABOUT HOW THE
EVEN PRIORITIZE HOW YOU SELECT
CLASSES WHERE YOU ARE ON THE
WAIT LIST THAT REALLY SCREWS
YOU OVER. BECAUSE IF YOU MISS
ONE CLASS YOU COULD BE SET BACK
TWO YEARS PAYING YOU KNOW
SEVERAL THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE-
EVEN JUST THE REPORT COSTS- SO.
WELL I JUST. AT THE COVER.
ABOUT EQUITY IN ADDING TO ABOUT
THE ROLE PIECES BECAUSE- I. I'M
NOT OPPOSED TO HAVING MORE OUT
OF STATE STUDENTS AS LONG AS IT
IS OFF OF COURSE ACT WILL
BALLOTS WITH OUR- ON OUR
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIANS- I
THINK FRANKLY HAVING MORE SINCE
FROM AROUND THE WORLD IS.
CONTRIBUTED TO THEIR
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE AND YOU
SEE I KNOW WAS TO MINE. AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
BALANCE THAT. IT'S NOT GREAT
THAT AND I KNOW A LOT OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS
DEFINITELY FEEL AS THOUGH THEY
ARE THE CASH COWS OF. OF YOU
SEE THE UPDATE VERY MUCH KNOW
THAT THEY ARE PAYING THREE
TIMES AS MUCH BUT IT'S ALSO
SELECTED FOR THE KINDS OF
INTERNATIONAL SINCE WE CAN HAVE
AS WELL- ONE OF COURSE. WE ARE
EVERYTHING CALIFORNIA'S NOT
DRAFT SINCE TOLD TOTALLY I
THINK IT'S PARTY EQUATION- BUT
DEFINITELY. WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE UC IS COMMITTED TO
THESE THINGS AND LOOKING AT IT
VERY CLOSELY. SO IF YOU ARE
ABLE TO COME BACK TO US AS MR
GALLAGHER HAD COURSE OF ACTION
ITEMS. TALK ABOUT WHAT THE UC
IS GOING TO DO ABOUT. GETTING
MORE ACADEMIC COUNSELING AND
ACADEMIC ADVISING ESPECIALLY TO
LONG CONCERNS AND SENSE OF
COLOR. AND ALSO ABOUT HOW
YOU'RE ADDRESSING THE
BOTTLENECKS SHORTAGES CLASSES
BECAUSE THAT IS A PROBLEM. IN
THE U. SEASON OF COURSE
ALTERCATION. EDUCATION SECTORS.
WHERE TOO MANY STUDENTS ARE
TRYING TO GET TO THE ONE SAME
CLASS. SO I'D REALLY LIKE TO
SEE HOW YOU CAN COME BACK AND
TALK TO US ABOUT ADVISING AND
THE BOTTLENECK COURSES AS WELL.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU. AND
MOSTLY OUT I WILL KNOW THAT IT
THAT WE LIKE TO SAY IT'S MORE
OF A RATIO THAN A CAT. BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT. IF IT IF WE
HAVE A CAP. FIRST THEN THAT'S
THE FINITE NUMBER. BUT WE FOR
S. FOR EVERY. READ THE ENROLL
MUST ENROLL ROUGHLY. FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IT'S
DIFFERENT PER CAMPUS IN SELMA-
WE THINK THAT THAT WAS A FAIR
COMPROMISE. IS GOING FORWARD I
KNOW THAT. THAT THAT THAT I
KNOW THE SENATE- IS LOOKING TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER- IN THAT
RATIO TO MR TING A SOME
THOUGHTS IN A SECOND AS WELL
SO. BUT IT'S MORE OF A RATIO
THAT THAN A CAP JUST WANNA
CLARIFY THEIR SENSE OF TRYING
TO FIND READ THAT. IT'S ABOUT
BRING MORE SEATS IN TOGETHER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TAKE.
I THINK WITH CHAIR- I JUST
WANTED TO GO BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUE INCENTIVES. COMMENTED
I WILL BE. WANT TO MAKE A-
SLIGHT. ON THEN HE MADE A POINT
I THINK YOU AGREED. THAT FOR
EVERY OUT OF STATE STUDENT.
THAT IN ESSENCE THEY PAY FOR.
TO IN STATE STUDENTS IS THAT IS
IT WOULD YOU WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH THAT. YES THAT'S CORRECT
EACH NON RESIDENT STUDENT BASED
ON SALES AND ONE POINT SIX.
RESIDENTS STUDENTS SUBMARGINAL
COSTS OF INSTRUCTION I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WERE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY BETWEEN THE YEARS OF.
TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN. I WAS AT A CAMPUS
BUDGET OFFICE OF THAT TIME
PERFECT SO YOU'RE YOU'RE AWARE
OF WHAT WAS GOING ON DOWN. ON
THE DURING THAT TIME YOU KNOW I
DON'T HAVE THE DIRECT NUMBERS
RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME BUT I'M-
OUT OF STATE ENROLLMENT GREW
SIGNIFICANTLY I THINK THREE OR
FOUR. WE ARE FOR FULL DUTY
RECOLLECT HOW HOW MUCH IN STATE
ENROLLMENT GREW DURING THAT
TIME. LET'S SEE DURING- DURING
THE DURING THAT TIME- IN STATE
ENROLLMENT- WHAT'S LET'S SEE IT
WAS- IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
STATE OH SORRY I DON'T HAVE
THAT IN FRONT OF ME- BUT I DO
BELIEVE WE GREW IN STATE
ENROLLMENT AT THAT TIME. I YEAH
ARE YOU A LOT YEAH I THINK IF
YOU ARMED. BY LAW IF YOU MEAN
NOTHING AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
IT WAS- SO DID THE NUMBERS
ADOPTABLE REFLECT BECAUSE I
MEAN I WOULD I WAS ON THIS
COMMITTEE STARTING IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN SO I RECOLLECT ALL
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. ON AND-
USING YOUR LARGER OR LIKE IT'S
MY COLLEAGUES LOGIC THAT YOU'RE
FROM WE HAD A FIVE FOLD
INCREASE IN- HOW TO STAY IN. A
ROOM AND WE SHOULD HAVE A TENER.
YOU KNOW. TEN OR- OR FORTY IN
INSTEAD ENROLLMENT BUT YET WE
DIDN'T SEE THAT. IN FACT OWNED.
WE SAW IN STATE ENROLLMENT R.
AS MY MOST COMPETITIVE
CAMPUSES. UC BERKELEY UCLA AND
SAN DIEGO GO DOWN. I CAN'T CAN
YOU TELL ME WHAT THE PERCENT OF
ASK STUDENTS AT BERKELEY UCLA
AND SAN DIEGO ARE NOW. I ONLY
HAVE THE SYSTEM WHAT WELL- AT
AT BERKELEY SAN DIEGO AND AWAY
OUT OF STATE AND INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS ARE ALLOWED TO BE- AT
THE RATE AT THE PLACE WHERE
THEY WERE WHEN THE CAP WAS. NOT
IF I'M JUST ALSO THEY ARE I'M
JUST ASKING I KNOW WHAT THE
POLICY IS MANNED BY HELP WRITE
IT SO. YOU COULD JUST GIVE ME
THE NUMBER. I CAN GET THAT FOR
YOUR OFFICE I DON'T HAVE IT
HERE IN FRONT OF ME. I WILL SAY
THAT BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY. YOU SEE A ROLE-
ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATES THAT WE RECEIVED
MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION
FUNDING FOR. FROM THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE DO TRY TO
MAKE YOUR WISHES AND KEEP UP
WITH THAT ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN
BLACK MATTER THIS IS A JUST OUT
OF CURIOSITY BUT- BOTH RURAL
DIRECTLY PAID FOR OUT OF THE
STATE BUDGET IN THROUGH
NEGOTIATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. I'LL WHY DIDN'T
THE FORTY FOUR HUNDRED INCREASE
IN NONRESIDENT STUDENT- ALSO
INCREASE COMMENSURATELY. AN
INCREASE IN NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT. SO FROM THE MONEY
WE- ADDED TO THE BUDGET. WE
INSTITUTIONAL FUNDS FROM- NON
RESIDENTS THAT WE GET TO HELP
PAY FOR SERVICES FOR ALL
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS SO IT'S
INCREASING- VARIOUS TYPES OF
SERVICES AND INCREASING COURSES
FOR ALL STUDENTS- IS HOW THOSE
FUNDS ARE USED IF WE RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR NON
RESIDENTS DON'T USE THAT MUCH.
BUT AT WELL OTHER NON RESIDENTS
COUNCILLORS TO THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO LINK BETWEEN
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT IN IN.
STATE ENROLLMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. IS THERE. THE LINK
IS THAT- WE GET WE ARE ABLE TO
PAY FOR ADDITIONAL SERVICES ON
ALL OUR ALL OUR CAMPUSES
CURRENTLY ABOUT 15% OF NUMBERS
BUDGETS THE SYSTEM WIDE COME
FROM NON RESIDENT TUITION
THAT'S JUST THE EXTRA PAYMENT
THAT NONRESIDENT STUDENTS MAKE-
BECAUSE WE SPEND THAT ON ALL
KINDS OF SERVICES ON THE CAMPUS
ALL STUDENTS END UP BENEFITING
FROM WORK RIGHT NOW AND I DON'T
AGREE WITH THAT SO SILVA SO THE
BENEFIT COULD BE TO THE
STUDENTS QUALITY OF LIFE. BUT
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
INCREASED ACCESS. WE DON'T-
ADMIT NEW RESIDENTS STUDENTS-
WHEN WE ARE ADMITTING NON
RESIDENTS THE WE DO STATE OF
THE STATE OF THE CAP LEVELS BUT
WE DON'T- WE DON'T NECESSARILY
LANDED TWO ONE ROMANS TO GATHER
IF THAT MAKES SENSE YEAH
BUSINESS ARE LOOKING AT THE
LEVELS OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
THAT THEY THEY WANT TO HAVE AND
THEN- WE HAVE THE ADMISSIONS
DECISIONS FOR THE TWO
SEPARATELY SO IT'S NOT LIKE WE
ADMIT OUR RESIDENTS. AND THEN
GO ON RESIDENTS TO CORRESPOND
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
THERE TO SUPPORT FOR THREE IT'S
VERY CLEAR FROM THE NUMBERS
OKAY CAN YOU TELL US WHY IN
FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN- YOU
SEE EXCEEDED THE 18% GOAL WITH
THE TWENTY ONE PERCENT- IN
ROMAN OF NONRESIDENTS. WE HAVE
A HEARING LOSS YEAR SO THAT'S
WHEN WE CAN GET THAT BECAUSE-
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
STARK- ADMISSIONS DECISIONS ARE
VERY DIFFICULT AND THAT. WE
DON'T ALWAYS KNOW WHAT THE
YIELD WILL BE STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDED WITH OFFERS. AND WE
MAKE- PREDICTIONS ABOUT HOW
MANY WILL ACCEPT THOSE OFFERS.
BASED ON PRIOR YEAR AVERAGES.
AND THEN SOME YEARS CAMPUSES DO
OVERSHOOTS SLIGHTLY. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN YOU'RE CORRECT THERE
WERE. YOUR CAMPUSES THAT HAD- A
LITTLE BIT OF AN OVER
INVOLVEMENT IN THEIR NON
RESIDENTS- WE TOOK THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AWAY FROM
THEM. AND WE DISTRIBUTED IT
SYSTEM WIDE FOR STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS. OR OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. OKAY BUT LET'S LET'S
JUST TALK ABOUT WITH 3% OF THAT
NUMBER IS IT'S ALMOST SIXTY
SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS. SO
THAT'S NOT. WELL I'M JUST
TAKING 3% YOU YOU GIVE ME OF
KIND OF YOUR EYES POPPED. 3% OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND THE JUNE ROLLED IF WE
RE DID THE RATIO. THAT RESULTS
IN THE FIRST 3% MULTIPLIED BY
TWO TWENTY SIX OF SIXTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE. RIGHT SIR I THINK
THE OVER AND ROLAND WAS CLOSER
TO TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS OVERALL
SYSTEM WIDE. I I WILL GET THOSE
NUMBERS FOR YOUR OFFICE OKAY
ARE YOU. DISCUSSING WITH ABOUT
THE NUMBER. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
21% VERSUS 18% RIGHT. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE THEY'RE
ENTIRE CAMPUS AND WHAT THEY'RE
ALLOWED IS YEAH THERE ARE SOME
CAMPUSES BECAUSE THEY ARE THEIR
CAP IS HIGHER THAN 18% YES THEY
DO. IN ROLL UP MORE NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS AND CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE A CAP OF EIGHTEEN.
RIGHT RIGHT NO I UNDERSTAND BUT
THE WE'RE TRYING TO PUT THE
OVERALL THE OVERALL UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS SUPPOSED TO BE 18% WHEN
THE REGION'S ADOPTED THE GAP
THEY ALLOW CAMPUSES THAT WERE
ALREADY ABOVE THE 18% LEVEL TO.
CONTINUE TO ENROLL THE NUMBER
OF NON RESIDENTS THAT THEY WERE
ROLLING WHEN THE COP WAS
ADOPTED AND THAT'S WHY THERE
ARE SOME CAMPUSES THAT ARE
ABOVE THAT EIGHT. THAT WAS THE
AGREEMENT WE WITH- UNIVERSITY
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN OVERALL
NOT TO EXCEED 18% IT WASN'T SO
THAT. THREE THE THREE THAT WERE
HIGHER BERKELEY UCLA SAN DIEGO
WHICH WERE ABOUT EIGHTEEN
PERCENT. WERE ALLOWED TO REMAIN
HARD THAT IS CORRECT BUT THE
18% WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
OVERALL TARGET FOR THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM. KNOWING THAT SOME
CAMPUSES LIKE MERCED. ASIDE
WOULD NOT WOULD NOT REALLY GET
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO THAT EIGHTEEN
PERCENT- AND SO SEEING A 21%
NUMBER IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. CAN WE CAN WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT CORRECTIVE
ACTION WAS TAKEN BY THE
UNIVERSITY. THE UNIVERSITY HAS
CAP
CURRENTLY ARE ABOUT 80% YEAH I
THOUGHT I WOULD SAY THAT- THEN-
TARGET FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WAS A NON RESIDENT- TARGET FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WHAT'S
WHAT ARE YOUR WHAT ARE YOUR
MOMENT TARGETS FOR RESIDENTS
NON RESIDENTS IN TOTALS FOR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE PLAN THE
WHOLE- ENROLLMENT FLAT. OR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. ACADEMIC
YEAR. WHICH MEANS WE WOULD AND
MAKE ROUGHLY THE SAME- NUMBER
AND RATIO STUDENTS AS WE DID
FOR FALL ONE TWENTY. GUNS TO
SEE YOU SEE YOU YOU ANTICIPATED
ROLLING ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
AGAIN ROUGHLY. AND OBVIOUSLY WE
KNOW IT'S NOT A PERFECT SCIENCE.
YES AN UNDERGRADUATE YES
CORRECT. RIGHT SO OFTEN. WHAT
DO WE NEED TO DO AND BURKE
CAMPUSES ADDICTION TO NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS. SIR IF WE
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF NON
RESIDENTS WILL LOSE FUNDING FOR
THOSE CAMPUSES AND SO- WE WOULD
PREFER NOT TO HAVE TRUSTED
BUDGET CUTS TO OUR CAMPUSES-
WE- IF WE HAD. CUTS FOR
MULTIPLE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
CANVASES WOULD HAVE TO CUT
STUDENT SERVICES THEY WOULD
HAVE TO CUT THE NUMBER OF
COURSES AVAILABLE AND IT WOULD
MAKE THINGS WORSE FOR ALL
STUDENTS- WE DID SUBMIT A PLAN
TO YOU ARE YOU YEARS AGO I
BELIEVE IN TWENTY NINETEEN. OR
REDUCING NON RESIDENTS- AND AT
THAT TIME FOUND THAT IT COULD
BE TREMENDOUSLY EXPENSIVE-
DEPENDING ON THE AMOUNT OF THE
REDUCTION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
YEAH BETWEEN HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS TO BILLIONS. RIGHT BUT
THAT THAT WAS IF YOU IF YOU
TOOK IT DOWN ALL THE WAY I
THINK TO. FIVE OR 10% BUT
NOTHING THING GRADUALLY OVER
TIME. I'M I THINK I THINK THE
CHALLENGE IS YOU NOW HAVE- NINE
CHANCELLORS OR I GUESS I WOULD
SAY SEVEN CHANCELLORS. WHO-
THIS IS THE ONLY AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT THEY HAVE COMPLETE
DISCRETION OVER. SO THEY HAVE
EVERY INCENTIVE TO FOCUS AND
BRING IN NON RESIDENT ROMAN
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR ONLY
DISCRETIONARY POT OF MONEY I
MEAN YOU YOU MENTIONED YOU WERE
OUT YOU WERE AT A CAMPUS BUDGET
OFFICE WHICH CAMPUS WHERE YOU
WERE. I WAS AT UC DAVIS AND
THEN IF YOU SEE BERKELEY
WONDERFUL SO WHAT WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU SAY THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE ONLY POTS
OF MONEY THAT DAVIS OR
BERKELEY. HAD THAT WAS
COMPLETELY UP TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S DISCRETION-
THERE'S A STATE MONIES
APPROPRIATE BY FORMULA THE TO
THE FEE MONEY IS THE FEMALE
NAME. THIS IS ONE OF THE ONLY
WAYS THAT THEY COULD GET
ADDITIONAL REVENUE ON CAMPUS.
IN IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY. I
WOULD SAY THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT
CERTAIN THESE BONDS ARE WHAT WE
USED TO CALL FUNGIBLE THAT IS-
THE CAMPUS GOING TO SUSPEND
THEM ON ANY COURT CAMPUS
ACTIVITY. SO THE CHANCELLOR
HAVE. NO INCENTIVE EFFECTIVE
HUGE DISINCENTIVE TO REDUCE
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT. THE
CHANCELLOR'S WANT TO MAINTAIN
FISCAL HEALTH OF THEIR CAMPUSES
AND- WHEN THEY ARE UNABLE TO
INCREASE OTHER FUNDING SOURCES-
I THINK THEY WANT TO MAINTAIN
THE ONES THAT THEY HAVE YES SO
THIS IN IN THIS IS ONE OF THE
ONLY FUNDING SOURCES THEY COULD
GOING CHRIS. SOME OF OUR
CAMPUSES ARE THE 18% CAP SO-
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
INCREASES FUNDING SOURCE
TREMENDOUSLY BUT- YES THIS IS
ONE OF THE FUNDING SOURCES ARE
CAMPUSES SOURCE AVAILABLE FOR
INCREASED- BETWEEN SAY TWENTY
TEN. AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN YEAH SO SINCE THE
CHURCHILL MCCARTY MENTIONED-
THIS WILL BE AN ISSUE THAT WE
WITH REVISITING THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR NOT AN ABSOLUTE WILL BE-
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT OVER. THE
LONG RUN UC NEEDS TO REDUCE
THAT FIGURE DOWN TO TEN OR EVEN
BACK 25% IN TERMS OF. OUT OF
STATE ENROLLMENT. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT CAN BE DONE IS TO CONTINUE
TO EXPAND- THE DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES IN FIND DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND. ON
ENROLLMENT AT THE DIFFERENT AT
THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO.
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION I WANTED
TO GO BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS FROM SAN BERNARD DINO
INTER RIVERSIDE FOR THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. THAT THE
UNIVERSITY'S ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ACTIVE CLOSE THE
EQUITY GAP- WHAT IS THE- YOU
KNOW WHAT WOULD BE THE-
GRADUATION TARGETS. FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS THAT THIS.
THAT THAT IF WE YOU THE- SIXTY
MILLION WHAT WOULD BE CALLED
THE- GRADUATION GAP FOR LATINO
AFRICAN AMERICANS THAN TELEGRAM
RECIPIENTS. WHAT'S THE GOLDEN.
AND OVER WHAT TIME- THANK YOU
SIR THE- GOAL WOULD BE TO FULLY
CLOSE THE GRADUATION BY TWENTY
THIRTY SO WOULD BE TO BRING THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LAST NEXT-
REGULATION RATES THE SAME LEVEL
AS OF THE STUDENTS WHO
CURRENTLY DON'T RECEIVE PELL
GRANTS AND WHO ARE- CAUCASIAN.
SO FOR A PROGRAM RECIPIENT THE
GOAL WOULD BE TO GET TO THE 67%
ASSUMING THEY DIDN'T INCREASE
AND THEN FOR. FOR LATINO AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS THE GOAL
WOULD BE TO GET TO. SOMEWHERE
AROUND. SEVENTY THREE SEVENTY
SIX YOU KNOW SERVICE AND
PERCENT. FORM I'M LOOKING OUT
FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATES.
RIGHT FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATE
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS FOR
ALL- YOU SEE STUDENTS- SO THE
OUR GRADUATION RATE OR- THESE-
SECOND. OUR CUSTOM THINK I HAVE
I OF OUR YEAR OLD WHITE
CAUCASIAN 73% API'S SIX LATINOS
FIFTY EIGHT AFRICAN AMERICANS
FIFTY FOUR PROGRAMS TO BE
INSTRUCTED SEVEN A NON PROGRAM
RECIPIENTS SIXTY SEVEN. SO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING I JUST WANT TO
GET THIS ON THE RECORD AS YOU
WERE TRYING TO GET LATINO
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS TO
BETWEEN 73276% LET'S SAY
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND ROUGHLY 67% FOR PELL
GRANT. RECIPIENTS BY TWENTY
THREE. THAT IS CORRECT- AND WE
ARE WE WERE ESTIMATING THAT WE
WOULD NEED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN ORDER TO
FULFILL THAT GOAL. OUR REQUEST
THAT WAS THANK YOU. OKAY SO YOU
NEED THE MONEY ANNUALLY THAT'S
NOT A ONE TIME EXPENDITURE. YES
THAT THAT'S ALL I'M GOING
BINDING AND IT WOULD BE FOLDING
UP SIXTY MILLION THE FIRST YEAR
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THE NEXT
YEAR. AND HUNDRED EIGHTY YEAR
AFTER. DO YOU EVER BREAK UP I
CAMPUS OF HOW THE MONEY GETS
SPENT. I DO HAVE- YES WE HAVE
CAMPUS PLANS. FOR HOW THE
FUNDING WOULD BE SPENT- I DON'T
HAVE THAT RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME
AT THE MOMENT BUT I CAN GET
THAT. FOR YOU. IT DOES THAT
DOES THAT BREAK OUT IN SPENDING
ACTUALLY REFLECT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF LATINO AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
BECAUSE- BECAUSE LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE
MENTIONED. DISTRIBUTION IS AN
EQUAL KNOCKS THE NINE CAMPUSES.
WE CAN DEFINITELY. YOU ARE
CLOSING EQUITY GAPS BASED ON DU
CAMPUSES IN A MOMENT WHERE THE
EQUITY GAPS ACTUALLY EXISTS. NO
NO NO WE DON'T YOU CAN DO THIS
QUESTIONS WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE
YOU GONNA DO AND HOW YOU DO IT.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A THERE'S
NEVER BEEN A PROBLEM WITH YOU
CAN DO THINGS THAT THE
CHALLENGE HAS BEEN GETTING YOU
TO DO THINGS. WE WILL
DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS BASED ON
WHERE THE EQUITY GAPS ARE. IF
YOU PROVIDE US WITH THE CLOSING
OF EQUITY GAPS FUNDING THAT WE
REQUESTED. GREAT THANK YOU SO
OFTEN. JUST SO YOU'RE PREPARED
I THINK YOU SHOULD- START
THINKING ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW
REDUCTION IN NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT WOULD LOOK LIKE-
WHAT THE IMPACT WOULD BE AND
THEN YOU I THINK YOU I WOULD
ADVISE YOU TO START THINKING
ABOUT- NUMBERS ABOUT HOW HOW
YOU WOULD. ABSORB THAT ARE OR
WHAT WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO
ASSIST YOU WITH THAT THE END
AGAIN THAT PERCENTAGE CAN GO
DOWN IF YOU INCREASED THE
CALIFORNIA STATE IN ROME
DOESN'T HAVE TO MEAN THAT YOU
DECREASE NONRESIDENT ROMAN JUST
MEET YOU COULD CONTINUE TO
INCREASE INSTEAD A ROLL. SO
THAT THAT THAT WILL DEFINITELY
BE PART OF OUR DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE FIFTEENTH
SEVEN THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
WE WANT TO TRY TO MOVE ON THE
AGENDA BUT GO BACK TO MR MEDINA
SAID DO YOU HAVE THE NUMBERS
THERE I KNOW THE NOT THE MOST
RECENT NUMBERS FOR NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT FOR THE NINE CAMPUS
WE KNOW THAT LA BERKELEY. AND
SAN DIEGO ARE BETWEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY FOUR AS YOU SAID
AND- THE IRVINE INSTANT DAVIS
THAT IS CAN GO UP TO EIGHTEEN
WHICH WAS OUR POLICY AND THAT
THE NUMBER THAT CAMPUS IS AT
THE BOTTOM AND- THEN RIVERSIDE.
MERCED. AND SANTA CRUZ WHAT
WERE THEIR NUMBERS. I DON'T
HAVE THE BY CAMPUS NON RESIDENT
INVOLVEMENT IN FRONT OF ME I DO
BELIEVE IT'S WRONG FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF BALD WHEN PLANNING
WITHOUT. YEAH MS. BUT BUT- I'M
A CONTRACTOR AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT IT'S MINIMAL THE NUMBER.
OF OUT OF STATE AND
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS S. N. UC
RIVERSIDE I THINK FOR JOBS
INTERNATIONAL. IS PRETTY
MINIMAL IN COMPARISON TO THE
OTHER CAMPUSES. YES SIR I
BELIEVE THAT- MERCED THERE ARE
ALMOST NO INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS THERE'S VERY FEW
MERCED AND IT RIVERSIDE THE
NUMBER IS VERY LOW COMPARED TO
OTHER CAMPUSES. YEAH YES SIR WE
HAVE HERE- MR DENTAL AND OUR
GENDER FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
SINCE TWO YEARS AGO AND I THINK
IT'S THE SAME SOBRE OF BERKELEY
WAS ABOUT TWENTY FIVE UCLA WAS
TWENTY FOUR- SAN DIEGO WAS
TWENTY THREE- THAT THE THREE IN
THE MID MIDDLE THE POLICY WAS
THEY CAN GO 218% SO THAT WAS
IRVINE. AS AT NINETEEN DAVIS AT
EIGHTEEN- AND IN SANTA BARBARA
AT SIXTEEN THAT THREE AT THE
BOTTOM. WE'RE AND WE'RE
RIVERSIDE AT 4%MERCED IS AT 0%
IN SANTA CRUZ AT 11% SO WELL
UNDER TEN AYE MAYBE THEY'VE GOT
A LITTLE BIT BUT AND WELL UNDER
TEN AND VERY LOW JUST JUST TO
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S-
NECESSARY TO KEEP IT IN
PERSPECTIVE. THAT THAT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE. ARE MINIMAL AT
THAT THE OTHER CAMPUSES. ON ON
THE POINT OF EQUITY IT IS ALSO-
THERE'S SOME IRONY THAT THE
CAMPUSES LIKE RIVERSIDE THAT
ARE UNDERFUNDED ARE DOING
BETTER WITH EQUITY- WHERE THE
GRADUATION RATE FOR LATINO ARE
PROBABLY BETTER HIGHER. AT UC
RIVERSIDE EVEN THOUGH IT'S
UNDER FUNDED THAN AT OTHER
CAMPUSES. OKAY THANK YOU SO
LET'S. LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO- THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN OF COURSE
AND EXPECT ACTION FROM THE TO
THE ASSEMBLY ON THESE TWO
ISSUES- IN A FEW MONTHS I
SHOULD NEVER TO STUDENTS
SUPPORTING BASIC NEEDS PROPOSAL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS TO BE
PROPOSALS FOR STUDENTS SUPPORT
THE FIRST IS. FIFTEEN MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. OUR BASIC
NEEDS FOCUSED ON TECHNOLOGY
ACCESS AND MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES STUDENTS THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THE EXISTING
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING THAT
YOU SEE CURRENTLY RECEIVES FOR
FOOD AND HOUSING BASIC NEEDS.
THE OTHER PROPOSAL AND STUDENT
SUPPORT IS FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME EMERGENCY STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID. WE ARE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU L. L.
FROM OUR MESSAGE HERE IS
SOMETHING YOU'LL HEAR A LOT
FROM US DURING TODAY'S HEARING
WHICH IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS IDENTIFIED
OBJECTIVES AND GOALS THAT ARE
REASONABLE AND TIMELY BUT WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS I JUST IF IN
CASE IT'S HELPFUL TO FOLLOW
ALONG PAGE ELEVEN OF YOUR
AGENDA. HAS TWO BULLETS THAT
SITE THE TWO PROPOSALS IN THIS
ISSUE. I'M GOING TO REACH BALL
AT OUR CONCERNS WITH- THE HOUSE
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND. IS THAT IT COMBINES TWO
DIFFERENT. ISSUES STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND STERN
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS. WITHOUT
HAVING TO NECESSARILY CLEAR
NEXUS WITH THESE TWO
OBJECTIVES. JUST FOR EXAMPLE
STOOD MENTAL HEALTH IS
SOMETHING THAT THE UNIVERSITY
IN RECENT YEARS HAS PROVIDED
FUNDING PORTAGE RAMPED UP
FUNDING FOR OVERTIME SO THIS IS
EFFECTIVELY AN EXISTING
PROGRAM. BUT THEY UNIVERSITY
THE STATE HAS NOT FUNDED A
SYSTEM WIDE STUDENT TECHNOLOGY-
INITIATIVE BEFORE SO THIS WOULD
BE A NEW ISSUE. SO IN THIS CASE
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND POTENTIALLY TACKLE
EACH ISSUE SEPARATELY. ON THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND. I'M HERE THE
ISSUE WAS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS LITTLE INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW THESE FUNDS WOULD INTERACT
WITH THE MUCH LARGER AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDING FOR
STUDENT EMERGENCY AID ALL THE
SEGMENTS HAVE RECEIVED
EMERGENCY EMERGENCY FINANCE
FUNDS FOR EMERGENCY STUDENT AID
AND TWO SEPARATE ROUNDS. AND
ARE POTENTIALLY SLATED TO
RECEIVE EVEN MORE SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING UNDER THIRD
ROUND. WE RECOMMEND YOU
EVALUATE THE PROPOSED A TWO
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND IN
LIGHT OF THIS FEDERALLY FUNDING.
SOME INFORMATION YOU COULD
GATHER IN THE COMING MONTHS
WOULD BE TO HAVE THE
UNIVERSITIES PROVIDE MORE. DATA
AND INFORMATION ARMED STUDENT
FINANCIAL NEED OF REMAINING
NEED AFTER FACTORING YOU DISH
THE- FEDERAL RESPONDS. AND THEN
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE RESTORE
MEANING FINANCIAL NEEDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD GET
INFORMATION FROM YOU SEE ANY
OTHER SEGMENTS AS TO HOW IT
INTENDS TO SPEND THESE FEDERAL
DOLLARS TO ENSURE THAT ANY
STATE FUNDING IS COORDINATED.
AND A COVERING- I THINK FILLING
ANY GAPS THAT REMAIN.
APPARENTLY FINALLY OUR ANALYSIS
ON STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
IDENTIFIED SOME OVERARCHING
CONCERNS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
STATE'S EXISTING APPROACH ON
THE STATE HAS IDENTIFIED BASIC
NEEDS AS A BUDGET PRIORITY IN
RECENT YEARS BUT HASN'T-
DEVELOPED A LONG TERM STRATEGY
AND MANY OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE BEEN FUNDED IN PREVIOUS
YEARS HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT
PIECEMEAL AND NOT WALK
COORDINATED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE SOME
STEPS THIS YEAR TO ESTABLISH A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE. STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS.
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME I'D BE I'D
BE HAPPY TO ELABORATE MORE ON
THAT IN JUNE IF THAT'S OF
INTEREST TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELCOME
BACK TO YOU EARLY ON A SECOND.
YOU SEE. SAY OVER TEN PER
UNIVERSITY UP. WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIFTEEN
MILLION AN ONGOING BASIC NEEDS
SUPPORT FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
TECHNOLOGY ACCESS AS WELL AS
THE FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR EMERGENCY STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID WE REQUEST FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THESE FUNDS. I
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR PER FUNDING
RECEIVED IN PRIOR YEARS. ALLOW
THE UNIVERSITY TO ESTABLISH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROCESSES
USED WITH WHICH TO SERVE
STUDENTS. ONGOING FUNDING
ALLOWS UNIVERSITY THE PLAN FOR
HOW TO COVER STUDENT NEEDS
ALLOWS TO DO MORE TO ADDRESS
STUDENTS AND CRISES THE
PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED THE UC
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS EXTEND
BEYOND HOUSING AND FOOD
SECURITY NEEDS LIKE TECHNOLOGY
AND MENTAL HEALTH. WE WOULD USE
THAT THEIR BASIC NEEDS FUNDING
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS FOR OUR CAMPUSES
PROVIDE TARGETED MENTAL HEALTH
RESPONSES SUCH AS SCREENING
TOOLS PROACTIVE CYCLE
EDUCATIONAL WORKSHOPS AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS DONE IN
COLLABORATION WITH CULTURAL
AFFINITY GROUPS. AND OTHER
STUDENTS SERVICE PROGRAMS ON
OUR CAMPUSES IN ADDITION THE
STUDENT TECHNOLOGY FUNDS COULD
BE USED FOR ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH
TECHNOLOGY LIKE LAPTOPS AND
HOTSPOT BY. GRANTS FOR HIGH
SPEED INTERNET ACCESS AS WELL
AS THE PURCHASE A LEARNING
ACCESSIBILITY SOFTWARE TO SERVE
OUR DISABLED STUDENTS. I WANT
TO EXTEND OUR THANKS THE
LEGISLATURE FORTY EARLY ACTION
BILL AB EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
APPROVED SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE CURRENT YEAR
INCREASE STUDENT ENROLLMENT IN
CALFRESH THESE FUNDS WILL OUR
CAMPUSES TO HIRE STUDENT
WORKERS. PURCHASE EQUIPMENT AND
SOFTWARE UNDERTAKE OTHER
ACTIONS TO HELP STUDENTS WITH
THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
BECAUSE WE'RE A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION THAT STRIVES TO
SERVE STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS WE ARE LIKELY TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE BASIC NEEDS
ISSUES. PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH
BASIC NEEDS SAFETY THAT ALLOWS
UNIVERSITIES AND SHORT THAT
CAME IN COLLEGE. EDUCATION
POSSIBLE FOR STUDENTS FOR OUR
LIST OF THEIR LIVES. THANK YOU
FOR THE TO SPEAK TODAY. OKAY
THE YOU CAN I GO BACK TO THE L.
A. L. THAT JASON WHO WHAT WE
WERE YOU FOR THE THESE BASS I'M
OBVIOUSLY THIS CAN MAKE- AND
THEY SIMPLY THAT WE WITH THE IN
THE INCLUDE OF A BASIC NEED
LINE ITEMS FOR. A MENTAL HEALTH
FOOD HOUSING THESE ARE ALL
PRIORITIES THAT THAT HAVE ONLY
BECOME EXASPERATED DURING COVER
NINETEEN ARE YOU SAYING THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE LESS- LESS
FLEXIBILITY AND HAVE THESE LINE
ITEMS OR HAVE MORE FOR MORE
FLEXIBILITY HAVE LIKE A BLOCK
GRANT PER PER CAMPUS BASED UPON
THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS. BOTH BOTH
APPROACHES ARE OUR OPTIONS TO
CONSIDER. THE MAIN REASON TO DO
THE BLOCK GRANT APPROACH- COULD
BE IF CAMPUSES FACE CERTAIN-
DIFFERENT BASIC NEEDS ISSUES
MAYBE MENTAL HEALTH IS MORE
PREVALENT OF ONE CAMPUS. MAYBE
IT'S- ARE MAYBE ANOTHER ISSUES
OR PROBLEMS ON ANOTHER CAMPUS
ON THE OTHER HAND HAVING MORE
LINE ITEMS WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRACK SOME OF
THESE INITIATIVES WILL MORE
CAREFULLY. AND SOME OF THESE
INITIATIVES ARE ARE A BIT
DIFFERENT- FOR STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH FOR EXAMPLE WELL THE
UNIVERSITY IS SPECIFICALLY
HIRING MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AT EACH CAMPUS.
HAS SPECIFIC GOALS IN PLACE TO
REACH CERTAIN STAFFING LEVELS
REDUCE WAIT TIMES THE
LEGISLATURE COULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REVIEW LEVEL MORE
CAREFULLY DAHLE IMPLICA
FOLLOWING PUBLICATION OVER
TRYING TO GET MORE GET MORE
DATA AND INFORMATION. LIKEWISE
ADDRESSING THINGS LIKE STUDENT
SECURITY OR WHICHEVER ARE GOING
TO BE A SEPARATE SET OF
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WOULD BE.
THE ADVANTAGE OF- SEPARATELY I
THINK OUR MESSAGE THE ON THE-
NON- ON GO FUNDING JUST BECAUSE-
THESE ISSUES ARE SOMEWHAT THERE.
FOR EXAMPLE TECHNOLOGY NEEDS
COULD POTENTIALLY BE MORE OF A
ONE TIME ISSUE THERE COULD BE
SOME ONGOING ISSUES TOO BUT
THOSE THOSE WOULD BE UP. EARLY
DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES AND-
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR EXAMPLE THAT COULDBE
SOMETHING A LEGISLATURE OF
WANTED TACKLE SEPARATELY. YEAH
I CONCUR WITH THAT FIRST OF ALL
I THINK THAT IT'S ODD TO LUMP
IN MENTAL HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT. HI I'M
SURE THAT STUDENTS AND HAVE
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS AS- AS WELL AS
ONGOING MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS WE
SEE THAT OVER AND OVER. I THINK
HAVING ONGOING SUPPORT
SOMETHING THAT WE WE'VEWE'VE
TRIED TO DO WHICH WE TOOK A
LACK AT TOOK A LOOK AT PROP
SIXTY THREE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WHICH REMAIN TO DO
AGAIN TO TRY TO GET MORE. MONEY
FOR HIGHER ED MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT. BUT YOU BRING UP A
GOOD POINT WITH TECHNOLOGY YOU
KNOW THIS YEAR WE THINK WE'RE
GOING TO BE FLUSH WITH. WITH
THAT ONE TIME MONEY. BASED UPON
YOU KNOW THE CASH RECEIPTS
COMING IN AND WITH AND WITH THE
BUDGET- PLUS WE HAVE THIS NEW
ONE TIME MONEY THAT JUST IS
ABOUT TO BE APPROVED THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO. YOU KNOW
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD. PLOW MORE THIS DIRECTLY
TO MENTAL HEALTH AND USE ONE
TIME FOR TECHNOLOGY NEEDS- I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD
RECOMMENDATION- QUESTIONS ON
THIS IS ON THIS ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY THAT S.
SO UC REGENTS APPROVED A PLAN
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
SIXTEEN THAT PROPOSED AN
INCREASE STUDENT SERVICE FEE S.
S. S. BY 5% ANNUALLY FOR FIVE
YEARS WITH HALF OF THE INCREASEINTENDED TO SUPPORT STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. AFTER
TWO YEARS OF THE FSF FEE
INCREASES IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN YOU
SEE REQUESTED STATE FUNDING FOR
THE REMAINDER OF THE PLAN I'M
GOING STATE FUNDING HAS BEEN
LIMITED TO THREE TO FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY
PROVIDED IN. TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH ROUGHLY
EQUATES TO WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN. THE THREE IN THE THIRD
YEAR FUNDING UNDER THE ACCESS
FEE INCREASE PLAN SO WHY DIDN'T
YOU SEE CONTINUE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE REGION'S PLAN TO
INCREASE STUDENT FEES AS A
SOURCE OF ONGOING SUPPORT FOR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SELECTED NOT TO INCREASE
STUDENT FEES- BECAUSE OF. A
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR STUDENTS
THAT THEY FOUND. INCREASE FEES
TO BE A BURDEN- AND ALSO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR OF
WHERE WE WERE TOLD THAT THERE
WAS A PROBLEMS TO NOT SEE
MANDATORY FEES INCREASE FOR
STUDENTS. AND TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- ARE YOU OPEN TO
CONSIDERING THE USE OF PROP
SIXTY THREE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR YOU
SEE STUDENTS. YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET COMMITS ALL AVAILABLE
PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDS TO OTHER
PRIORITIES. AND I WOULD NOTE
THAT ALTHOUGH PROP SIXTY THREE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN USED IN THE
PAST FOR ONE TIME SUPPORT FOR
YOU SEE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS-
HOW WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AS
YOU MENTIONED INCLUDES FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION NGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR THIS PURPOSE.
AND THAT ARE OR PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION A NEW ONGOING GENERAL
FUND WOULD PROVIDE YOU SEE A
LOT OF FLEXIBILITY OF THE
FIFTEEN MILLION WE'RE PROPOSING
UC HAS INDICATED THEY WILL. PUT
ELEVEN MILLION TOWARDS STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND LEAVE THE OF
FOREST REMAINING MILLION
TOWARDS THE TECHNOLOGY. HE SAID
WE THINK THAT STATE PARK.
THAT'S IN LINE WITH THE
PROPOSAL AND THAT WOULD.
SUBSTANTIALLY ADDRESS STREET
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OFF IN ISSUE NUMBER THREE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU AND I
WILL INTRODUCE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE COMPONENT AND THEN
I WILL HAND IT OFF TO MY
COLLEAGUE RANDY CATS FOR THE
CAT OUTLAY SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS.
THERE'S ALSO A PIECE FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY IN WHICH ALL NOW
SWITCH MY COLLEAGUE RANDY CAPPS.
HELLO A RANDY KATZ WITH THE OF
FINANCE. THE- THERE YOU SEE A
SUBMITTED TWO REQUESTS FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY- ONE AN
INFORMATIONAL PROPOSAL
EXPLAINING THE ARE YOU SEE- YOU
0% MEDICAL. EDUCATION PROJECT
THAT WAS APPROVED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND THEN
ANOTHER ONE FOR SEISMIC
IMPROVEMENTS AT UC BERKELEY-
WE'VE BEEN HAVING- ALSO AS
NOTED IN THE AGE GENDER THERE'S
BEEN SOME ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS WITH S. B. H.
FUNNY AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH YOU SEE WE EXPECT
TO HAVE THE PRELIMINARY
APPROVAL. LETTER OUT SHORTLY
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT.
I'M WE WILL GO NEXT- SO THIS
ISSUE HAS TWO DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS AS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND THEN IT AS
CAPITAL OUTLAY SO I'LL TOUCH ON
EACH ISSUE FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- YOUR FIRST
TESTIFYING ON ISSUES LIKE THIS
PREVIOUSLY AS WE NOTED THAT WE
THINK DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS A
GOOD USE OF ONE TIME FUNDING WE
THINK THE PROPOSED AMOUNT IS
JUSTIFIED GIVEN THE SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF- BACKLOG PROJECTS
THAT YOU SEE HAS THIS ISN'T. AN
AREA YOU COULD CONSIDER
REDIRECTING AN ADDITIONAL ONE
TIME FUNDING TOWARD DEPENDING
ON YOUR OTHER BUDGET PRIORITIES
YOU GET TO THE INVENTION. WE
DIRECT ONE MODIFICATION TO THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECT
APPROVAL PROCESS THE THING
THOSE THIS YEAR. THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BUDGET BILL WHICH WOULD
SPECIFY THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE.
ALL THE PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE
SUPPORTED WITH THE FUNDS AFTER
THE FUNDS ARE RELEASED WE'RE
RECOMMENDING MODIFICATIONS SO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE GETS
NOTIFICATION OF THESE PROJECTS
BEFORE THE FUNDS ARE RELEASED
THAT WOULD GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THEIR
PROPOSALS TO PROJECTS IT'S ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR PROCESS
TO BUILD STATE TOOK A PREVIOUS
YEARS FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
HI CAPITAL OUTLAY- AS THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTED THERE ARE
TWO ISSUES THERE'S TWO
PROPOSALS HERE ONE IS AFTER
BERKELEY AND THE OTHER IS
FORMER SAID. AND AT THE MERCED
PROJECT. HAD BEEN- THEY USUALLY
HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED TO PURSUE
THE MERCED PROJECT IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT-
BUDGET. BUT IT ONLY RECENTLY
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
UPDATED INFORMATION REGARDING
ITS SCOPE AND COST. WE DO NOT
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BERKELEY
PROJECT WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE MERCED PROJECT
PARTICULARLY AROUND ITS SCOPE
COST AND FUNDING PLAN. I'D BE
HAPPY TO OPERATE MORE ON THAT
DURING THE Q. NAY. THE SECOND
TIME. FINALLY OUR ANALYSIS ON
CAPITAL OUTLAY ISSUES
IDENTIFIED SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
WE HAVE ON THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECT APPROVAL PROCESS AT THE
STATE USES FOR UC AND CSU OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE INTENDED TO
ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY AND ALSO
ENHANCE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AND HERE AGAIN AND I'M HAPPY TO
ELABORATE ON ANY OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS DURING THE CUNY
THAT'S OF INTEREST TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOU SEE. SO CALIBER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
OF A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION BURKE MAINTENANCE AND
ENERGY PROJECTS WILL ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY. PRESS CRITICAL
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ISSUES AND
INCREASED LOCAL EMPLOYMENT.
EVERY UC CAMPUS WILL RECEIVE A
PORTION OF THESE FUNDS. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
IDENTIFIED PROJECTS THROUGH OUR
INTEGRATED CAPITAL ASSET
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM OR I. THEIR
HIGH PRIORITY TO CAMPUSES OR
THE PROVIDES ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
WE ESTIMATE THAT THESE PROJECTS
CAN BE INITIATED WITHIN SIX
MONTHS AND THUS PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED LOCAL EMPLOYMENT THERE
ARE CAMPUSES. WHERE REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE CAN
CONCUR THERE'S A GREAT NEED
FOR. A DEFERRED MAINTENANCE-
ARE YOU SEE CAMPUS ARE AGING
PLUS WE HAVE A VERY OLD
CAMPUSES LIKE UC BERKELEY WHERE
THE SEISMIC NEEDS ARE JUST.
TREMENDOUS IN THE IN THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS VERY
STAGGERING SO. YOU KNOW WE
COULD USE. THE ENTIRE STATE
SURPLUS THIS YEAR AND. AND- AND
TACKLE THIS- THE UC. DIFFER
MAINTENANCE BACK SO THIS IS
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF WE WILL
YOU KNOW TAKE A LOOK AT
POTENTIALLY OTHER RESOURCES
WHEN WE GET THEM THE FINAL
BUDGET AND AS WELL AS FEDERAL
MONEY- SO. SINGLE COMMENT WILL
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN- ISSUE FOR
OTHER PROPOSALS AS KIND OF A
CATCH ALL OF THEM.
MISCELLANEOUS PROPOSALS FOR THE
UC FROM THE GOVERNOR'S. TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU CHAIR SO THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHER PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WERE
CHEN DICED UNDER THIS ISSUE.
THESE INCLUDE TWELVE POINT FIVE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
FOR YOU SEE CRIME. ONE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR A
LEARNING LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM ALIGNMENT FOR THE UC TO
ALIGN WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. TWENTY MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
SCIENCE AND INNOVATION. FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ARE
FOCUSED ON ONLINE EDUCATION.
AND THEN LASTLY ONE POINT THREE
MILLION ONE TIME JUST OR TO
HEALTH MODELING CONSORTIUM
BETWEEN THE UC IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU AND WERE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. OKAY. THAT THANK
YOU L. A. L. SO IT MIGHT BE
HANDY TO TURN TO PAGE SEVENTEEN
OF YOUR AGENDA IT SUMMARIZES
WHAT IT IS USED IN THE BULLETS.
OF THE FIVE ISSUES WE AT WILL
RAISE CONCERNS OF THREE ON I'LL
GO THROUGH EACH- PROPOSAL WE
HAVE CONCERTS. THE FIRST IS ON
THAT TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PRIME- THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS IDENTIFIED A
COMMENDABLE- ISSUE FOR
CONSIDERATION THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WHICH IS ADDRESSING LONG
STANDING OUTSIDE EQUITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WE HAVE SOME.
CONCERNS WITH THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL. OUR FIRST CONCERN IS
AROUND THE FACT THAT THE
PROPOSAL LACKS A FEW WANT
ESSENTIAL LONG TERM PLANS THAT
WE THINK ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE INTENDED GOALS OF THAT
PROPOSAL. FOR EXAMPLE- THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
UNIVERSITY HAVE NOT- DEVELOP A
LONG TERM PLAN TO ADDRESS
HEALTH EQUITY ISSUES ACROSS THE
STATE WITHOUT THIS LONG TERM
PLAN IT'S DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
WHERE THE REMAINING GAPS ARE
WHICH TYPES OF THE GAPS ARE NOT
COVERED BY PRINT PROGRAMS. IN
WHICH WOULD REMAIN UNADDRESSED
UNDER THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL.
TWO SECONDS- THE PROPOSED
BUDGET APPROACH TO SUPPORT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN THAT
PROPOSAL. HAS INTERVIEW SEVERAL
WEAKNESSES JUST A SITE ONE
NOTABLE EXAMPLE- THE
UNIVERSITY'S ASKING FOR FUNDING
UP FRONT FOR GROWTH THAT WILL
NOT BE MATERIALIZED FOR.
SEVERAL YEARS WE THINK THIS IS
NOT ONLY INEFFICIENT BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES FUNDING IN YEARS WHERE
THE COST HAVEN'T NECESSARILY
OCCURRED IT ALSO WEAKENS
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT GROWTH.
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE WE HAVE.
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
BUDGET APPROACH WE HAVE
PERSON FUNDING RATE. THE
PROPOSAL DOESN'T HAVE AN
ENROLLMENT TARGET SO THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE ABLE TO
HOLD YOU SEE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THIS GROSS. AND THEN THERE'S A
THE PROPOSAL ALSO WOULDN'T HAVE
ANY REPORTING ON OUTCOMES THE
PROGRAMS A LEGISLATURE REVENUE
CONSISTENT WAY TO EVALUATE ON
PROGRAMS IN FUTURE YEARS. AND
THEN ARE THIRD CONCERNED WITH
THE UC PRIME PROPOSAL IS THAT A
SIZABLE PORTION OF THE FUNDS-
ARE NOT FOR A MOMENT GROWTH BUT
ARE INTENDED TO BOLSTER.
SUPPORT FOR EXISTING ENROLLMENT
AT EXISTING PROGRAMS. I'M THIS
COULD POTENTIALLY BE JUSTIFIED
FOR EXAMPLE PORTION OF THE
FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT FINANCIAL
AID- BUT IN OUR VIEW YOU SEE
HAS NOT JUSTIFIED THE BULK OF
THIS ENHANCEMENT FUNDING. AND
EVEN FOR FINANCIAL AID WORK AT
THE EVENTUALLY BE WARRANTED.
YOU SEE HAS NOT PROVIDED ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO ESTIMATE
STUDENTS FINANCIAL NEED TO
REALLY ASSESS WHETHER. I WAS
FUNDING JUSTIFIED. SO IS THE
CASE WE THINK THE LARGEST COULD
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
UNIVERSITY TO COME BACK WITH A
STRONGER PROPOSAL THAT
ADDRESSES EACH ONE OF OUR
CONCERNS. SECOND PROPOSAL I'D
LIKE TO. DISCUSS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TWO FOR SCIENCE
AND INNOVATION. MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
HERE. OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE
PROPOSAL APPEARS TO HAVE A VERY
NARROW OR IT WOULD HAVE A VERY
NARROW IMPACT IT WOULD SUPPORT
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY INDIVIDUALS
ANNUALLY OR ABOUT. TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD IN A NARROW SET OF
INDUSTRIES. THE PROPOSAL
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE CONNECTED TO
A STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT OF
WORKFORCE NEEDS AND SO IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE PROPOSED
ACTIVITIES AND INDUSTRIES UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL. ALL REFLECT THE
STATE'S HIGHEST WORKFORCE NEEDS.
HERE AGAIN IS A SITUATION WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DEVELOP A BETTER PROPOSAL THAT
REFLECTS OUR CONCERNS. WERE
ALTERNATIVELY IT COULD REJECTED
THIS PROPOSAL REDIRECT THE
FUNDING FOR OTHER- HIGH
PRIORITIES THINGS LIKE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR EXAMPLE. IN THE
FINAL OF. PROPOSAL I WANT TO
DISCUSS IS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. SO HERE AGAIN OF
THE RESTORATION HAS IDENTIFIED
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF THE FIELD WHICH IS THAT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT HAS.
BEEN A HIGH PRIORITY
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF KOBE
IN THE MOVE TO REMOTE
INSTRUCTION. THE ISSUE HERE IS
THAT THE UNIVERSITY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE NOT
PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT OF FACULTY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND SO
THE NUMBER OF FACULTY IN NEED
OF DEVELOPMENT THE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NEEDED. AND
THE TYPES OF- FUNDING AVAILABLE
TO THE UNIVERSITY FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT KNOWN TO THE
LEGISLATURE. IN ADDITION THE
UNIVERSITY IS RECEIVING A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF FEDERALLY
FUNDS AND THIS IS EXACTLY THE
KIND OF ACTIVITY. THAT FEDERAL
FUNDS COULD BE USED TO SUPPORT.
SO HERE WE ARE OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECTED
THIS PROPOSAL NOW YOU MIGHT
RECALL THAT IN ISSUE ONE WE
RECOMMENDED- REPORT ON UC'S
EXPERIENCE OF ONLINE EDUCATION.
AND OUR PORT WE ENVISIONED TO
INCLUDE- INFORMATION ON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INSERTED THE NEED FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. IT
WOULD GIVE THE LEGISLATURE MORE
DATA SO THAT I CAN MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS IN THIS AREA
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET. I WITHOUT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANYTHING IN
TUNING. THANK YOU UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. SAVER CAN IMPROVE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO INVEST IN YOU
SEE STUDENTS AND RESEARCH WE
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THESE
ITEMS WITH THE EXCEPTION THAT
WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM PROPOSAL
TODAY I WILL MAKE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PROGRAMS AND MEDICAL
EDUCATION ALSO KNOWN AS PRIME.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION IN
NEW INVESTMENTS IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION BACK WILL HELP OUR
STUDENTS AND THE STATE. CRIME
TRAINS MEDICAL STUDENTS TO
PRACTICE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THE FOCUS ON
HEALTH EQUITY AT THE CENTRAL
ELEMENT IN ALL CRIME PROGRAMS.
THE SPECIAL TRAINING THESE
GRADUATES RECEIVE PREPARES THEM
FOR LEADERSHIP ROLES AS
COMMUTING HUGE CLINICIANS
EDUCATORS RESEARCHERS AND
SOCIAL POLICY ADVOCATES FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THE
MAJORITY OF HOMES ARE. FROM
GROUPS UNDERREPRESENTED IN
MEDICINE INCLUDING AFRICAN
AMERICAN BLACK NEXT AN AMERICAN
INDIAN POPULATIONS. THE
AVAILABILITY OF MEDICAL CARE
FOR CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITIES IS
LIKELY TO BECOME MORE CHALLENGE
IN THE FUTURE. BECAUSE ONE
THIRD OF THE STATE'S POSITIONS
ARE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY.
THESE DOCTORS ARE ABOUT TO
START RETIRING AND THEY NEED TO
BE REPLACED. FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY PRIME STUDENTS HAVE
GRADUATED MEDICAL SCHOOL SINCE
PRIME STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR. THE FUNDING PROVIDED BY
THE GOVERNOR WOULD ALLOW YOU
SEE TOOK SPENT TIME WITH YOUR
NEW PROGRAMS. WANT TO SERVE
AMERICAN INDIAN AND NATIVE
ALASKAN COMMUNITIES AND THE
OTHER TO SERVE BLACK
COMMUNITIES. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT EXISTING
PROGRAMS WOULD ENABLE YOU SEE
MEDICAL SCHOOLS TO ASSURE
STABLE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
PRIME. IN ADDITION TO FUNDING A
PORTION OF THE COST OF
INSTRUCTION THE PROPOSED NEW
FUNDING WILL ENABLE YOU SEE
MEDICAL SCHOOLS TO MEET 1100%
OF THE DEMONSTRATE FINANCIAL
NEED FOR EACH TIME STUDENT.
ORIGINALLY PLANNED ENROLLMENT
LEVELS REDIRECT RESOURCES TO
EXPAND PIPELINE PROGRAMS TO
STRENGTHEN OUTREACH AND
RECRUITMENT OCTOBER STUDENTS.
SECURE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
SITES AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT NEEDED FOR LEARNING
RESOURCES EMERGENCY FINANCIAL
AID. AND IMPROVE DATA
COLLECTION TRACKING AND
ANALYSIS. ONE THIRD OF THE
FUNDING PROPOSED WOULD. GO ONE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID KERN
PLACE 4% OF STILL TAKE A
STUDENT DEBT WHILE IT BROUGHT
ANY USE MEDICAL SCHOOL. THE
AVERAGE DEBT FIRST UPON. FROM
MATTER SCHOOL IS A HUNDRED AND
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH NOT
INCLUDE POSSIBLE BACK FROM
UNDERGRADUATE STUDIES. THIS
LEVEL OF DEPTH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR STUDENTS TO WORK
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ON
GRADUATION. THE PROPOSED
FUNDING WOULD HELP
TREMENDOUSLY. I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT SOON WE WILL PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO CLARIFY
THE PROCESS OF MEDICAL ONE
MOMENT IN PROGRAMMING.
SPECIFICALLY IN RESPONSE TO
SOME OF THE STATEMENTS MADE BY
THE L. A. L. WITH MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND RESIDENCY TAKES A
MINIMUM OF SEVEN YEARS TO TRAIN
NEW DOCTORS READY TO PRACTICE
WITHOUT SUPERVISION.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES CANNOT
WAIT ANY LONGER FOR ACTION I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT PRIME. FOR
THE REMAINING PROPOSALS I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS OR GO
THROUGH THEM ONE AT A TIME THAT
WOULD BE PREFERABLE. I THINK
WE'RE OKAY- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MR MEDINA. THANK YOU I
WANT TO THANK YOU SEE FOUR-
COMMENTS ON PRIME. I REPRESENT
AN AREA OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS
CERTAINLY UNDERSERVED- IN THE
NUMBER OF DOCTORS AND I THINK
THIS PANDEMIC. HAS ONLY
HIGHLIGHTED THE INEQUALITIES
AND IN THE MEDICAL CARE THAT
EXIST WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE THE RATIO AND I
WISH I REMEMBERED WHAT THAT
RATIO AS THE RATIO OF. OF THE
POPULATION TO THE NUMBER OF
DOCTORS IN MY AREA LIKE IN MUCH
OF A INLAND CALIFORNIA. IS SO
MUCH LOWER THAN THE COASTAL
AREAS- SO THEREFORE. THE NEED
FOR- DOCTORS IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS AND I KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE- PRIMES THAT IS A SET TO BE
EXPANDED PROGRAMS THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WHICH I THINK IS
A PROGRAM BETWEEN. UC MERCED-
AND FRESNO STATE IS THAT IS
THAT. ARE YOU SEE MERCED UC SAN
FRANCISCO. YOU SEE MERCED AND-
UCSF FRESNO BRANCH CAMPUS RIGHT.
NO THEY THEY SHARE WITH MYERS
OF THIS- YOU KNOW I'M NEED FOR-
MORE DOCTORS AND THEN AS THE
UCR'S SCHOOL OF MEDICINE WAS
ESTABLISHED TO SPECIALLY SERVE-
THE UNDER REPRESENTED. A
POPULATION UNDERSERVED EVEN
MORE BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENGES
OF- OF CULTURE AND LANGUAGE I
KNOW THAT IT'S PROBABLY NOT ON
HERE BUT THE UC IRVINE HAS A
SPECIAL PRIME PROGRAM TO TRAIN
A DOCTORS WHO ARE FLUENT IN
SPANISH. SO I HAD A CHANCE TO
MEET WITH SOME OF THE PRIME
STUDENTS FROM UC SAN FRANCISCO.
AND JUST AS I AM SO IMPRESSED
WITH THE UC- OUR STUDENTS ARE
ENTERING THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND AS THEY GRADUATE AND THE
DIVERSITY. OF THE UCR SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE STUDENTS GRADUATE I
WAS JUST AS IMPRESSED WITH THE
STUDENTS THAT I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH- THIS
WEEK FROM THE UC SAN FRANCISCO
PRIME PROGRAM. AND THE
DIVERSITY THAT THAT THE
STUDENTS REFLECT MUCH NEEDED IN
IN THE- AND THE KINDS OF
DOCTORS THAT WE PRODUCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE KINDS
OF DOCTORS. THAT ARE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
A DIVERSE POPULATION SO I
CANNOT SAY ENOUGH GOOD THINGS
ABOUT PRIME. I THINK THE TWELVE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IS
CERTAINLY- MONEY WELL SPENT- TO
THE CONCERNS OF THE L. A. O. I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THERE WOULD
PROBABLY BE MECHANISMS THAT WE
COULD GET MORE INFORMATION. ON
HOW THE PROGRAM WORKS HOW
EFFECTIVE IT IS AND GET THAT
KIND OF REPORTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITHOUT MUCH
DIFFICULTY. I THINK THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE EASY TO DO. AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD ME THIS MORNING.
TALK A LOT ABOUT UC RIVERSIDE.
MAYBE ONE QUESTION. HOW CAN YOU
SEE RIVERSIDE GET AT A PRIME
PROGRAM. YEAH AND- AND I DO NOT
ASK THAT- SARCASTICALLY OR- I'M
SERIOUS IN THE- WHAT WHAT. WHAT
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO
MEDICAL SCHOOL ENROLLMENT IS-
HIGHLY CONTROLLED BY D.
ACCREDITING ENTITY AND THUS
ARENA- UC RIVERSIDE DOES HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO GROW AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT- A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN ALL THE MEDICAL SCHOOL
DEANS THE C. WHERE TO TWO NEW
PROGRAMS WOULD BE PLACED- THE
DECISION HASN'T YET BEEN MADE
ITS- WAY DEPENDENT ON RESOURCES
AND GETTING THAT APPROVAL FROM
THE ACCREDITING ENTITY- BUT TO
ANSWER YOUR FIRST POINT
REGARDING REPORTS WERE VERY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. ON A REPORT ON
FRIDAY OUTCOMES THAT WOULD-
SHOW YOU HOW EFFECTIVE THESE
PROGRAMS ARE. AND THE PRIME
STUDENTS DO NOT ACTUALLY IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS RIGHT OR- IT ISN'T-
NAY A SUBSET OF THE- NUMBER.
STUDENTS ALREADY ENROLLED IN
PROGRAMS. HEARD SHOTS OF
FRIENDS. YEAH UC RIVERSIDE HAS
BIRDS IS GOING TO APPROACH A
HUNDRED STUDENTS- WITH ONE OF
OUR PRIME PROGRAM SAY AT THAT
PLACE THANK YOU SEE ARE MEAN
ADDITIONAL MEDICAL STUDENTS ARE
GOING TO BE A SUBSET OF SAY THE
ONE HUNDRED MEDICAL STUDENTS
THAT ARE ALREADY THERE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION IT COULD
BE EITHER SO WE COULD TAKE A
SUBSET OF THE EXISTING-
ENROLLMENT AND MAKE THEM PRIME
PROGRAM STUDENTS. WHERE THEY
WOULD HAVE THAT ADDITIONAL
TRAINING TO WORK WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OR WE
COULD INCREASE THE TOTAL SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT TO INCORPORATE TIME.
IN THE PAST I'M PROGRAMS HAVE
INCREASED INVOLVEMENT IN
MEDICAL SCHOOL SO WE USE THAT
AS A WAY TO. INCREASE
ENROLLMENT WHAT WE COULD DO
EITHER. AND DID YOU MENTION WE
WERE GOING TO HEAR FROM SOME OF
THE PRIME STUDENTS- TODAY. I'M
NOT. YOU YOU MIGHT DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE ANY- WITH ME THAT WE
WALKED UP THE SOCIAL SPEAKERS
THANK YOU. YES SEE YOUR STRONG
ADVOCACY THERE FOR YOUR- PRIME
ALLOCATE I WOULD NOTE WE HAVE A
BUDGET PROCESS YOU CAN ALWAYS
IN YOUR BUDGET LETTER THAT
CHAIRED. SUBMIT THIS AS YOUR
MEMBER REQUEST AND FIND YOUR
OWN PRIME PROGRAM THERE YES YOU
ARE MAYBE GET- THIS REYES SAID
MISTER ROTH TO HELP YOU OUT TOO
SO. GIVE ME SOME TIPS THERE MR
MEDINA- I WILL NOTE THAT THIS
THE PRIME- PROGRAM AND THESE
EFFORTS IS EXTREMELY POPULAR
WITH. A LEGISLATORS ESPECIALLY
FROM RURAL AREAS- DOCTOR WOULD
DOCTOR RAMBLE- AND YOU MISTER
MEDINA AMONG OTHERS THAT HAVE
CONTINUALLY MENTIONED. THIS
MISTER SALAS AND IN BAKERSFIELD
AS WELL SO- IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WELL VERSED ON AND- YOU
KNOW THE THINGS THAT THE IT WAS
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO INCREASE
SUPPORT FOR PRIVATE PROGRAMS
AND SAYS THAT THAT REALLY AT
THAT THE HEALTH ISSUE FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT YOU SEE AS OUR-
TEACHING HOSPITAL IN THE IN
THE- UNIVERSITY BUDGETS AS PART
OF OUR- WORK FOR THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE- SO MY MEMBER BY A
DENTIST. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
SO HOW DID THE ADMINISTRATION
DETERMINE THE NEED FOR TWO NEW
PRIME PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE
PROPOSED FOCUS ON AMERICAN
INDIAN NATIVE ALASKAN AND BLACK
AFRICAN AMERICAN POPULATIONS-
EIGHT I'M JUST INTERESTING WHAT
I'M INTERESTED TO KNOWING WILL-
HOW THAT IS EVALUATED AND
DETERMINED. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO THIS WAS THIS THIS
PROPOSAL IS. HAS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTEREST VERY
INTERTWINED WITH THE UC'S
ENTRANTS THE HISTORY OF THIS
PROPOSALS THAT FIRST IT WAS A
REGENT REQUEST SO THE REGENTS
WERE COMING FORWARD WITH A
TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND REQUEST.
FOR PRIVATE INVESTMENT. THE
ADMINISTRATION THEN IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SPECIFICALLY
PROPOSED A NEW NATIVE AMERICAN
FOCUSED PRIME. PROGRAM WITH
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE ALSO. UP
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED UC TO
OUR A SECOND NEW PRIME PROGRAM
BUT DID NOT SPECIFY WHAT THAT
SECOND NEW PROGRAM WOULD FOCUS
ON. SENSE GOVERNOR'S BUDGETS
RELEASED UC'S INDICATED NOW
THAT THEIR THEIR DECISION WOULD
BE TO USE THAT TO FOCUS ON
AFRICAN AMERICAN. POPULATIONS
SO THAT'S HOW WE GET TO NOW
THIS TWELVE POINT NINE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH A TO DO
PROGRAMS ONE FOR NATIVE
AMERICAN WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME FORWARD
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND
TOO IN LINE WITH OUR
EXPECTATIONS THE UC HAS A
PROPOSED THIS SECOND AFRICAN
AMERICAN. FOCUSED PROPOSAL. AND
WHEN DO YOU THINK IT MISTER
WILL ANTICIPATE IDENTIFYING
WHICH YOU SEE MEDICAL SCHOOLS
WILL OPERATE THE PROPOSED PRIME
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU FOR THE
FOLLOW UP IS THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE WE PROPOSE DOESN'T
SPECIFICALLY CITE ANY METHOD
FOR DEFINING THAT WE'RE LEAVING
OUT FLEXIBLE FOR YOU SEEK TO
DECIDE- OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS- AND
HAVE NOT COME TO A CONCLUSION
IN TERMS OF. WHERE THE REGIONAL
BASIS FOR THE CAMPUS WOULD BE-
WOODLAND- WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THE REASON FOR THE FLEXIBILITY
IS THAT YOU SEE AS THE- THE
ORIGINATORS OF THE MINISTRY
THERE'S ON THESE PROGRAMS-
THEY'RE THEY'RE BETTER
POSITIONED TO KNOW WHAT'S
POSSIBLE AND WHAT'S GOING TO BE
THE BEST LINKAGE WITH THE
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY. AND YOU SEE
DO YOU HAVE ANY INDICATION OF
WHEN- AND HOW YOU'LL MAKE THE
SELECTION OF WHICH- WHICH
MEDICAL SCHOOLS- LAUNCH THESE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- IN TERMS OF HOW WE
WILL MAKE THE DECISION OF THE
DIFFERENT MEDICAL SCHOOL DEANS
WILL DISCUSS THE AVAILABILITY
OF RESOURCES THERE NEEDS TO BE
ENOUGH FACULTY- ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THE STUDENTS AND
FACULTY WHO- HAVE. PRACTICED IN
IN SERVING THOSE COMMUNITIES
PREVIOUSLY AND HAVE THE LINKS
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
ARE PROPOSING TO HAVE THE PRIME
PROGRAMS WITH- THERE NEEDS TO
BE ENOUGH AVAILABILITY OF
CLINICAL ROTATIONS NEAR THE
SCHOOLS. AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE AVAILABILITY OF ALL THOSE
FACTORS IN DETERMINING THE MOST
OPTIMAL SITES AND WILL PROBABLY
HAVE THAT DECISION- BY THE END
OF JUNE. THANK YOU IF YOU COULD
FOLLOW UP AND GIVE US MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS AS IT COMES
THROUGH I'D APPRECIATE THAT-
ALSO FOR YOU SEE A PRIME
PROGRAMS- YOUR PRIME PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY ACCOUNT FOR ONLY
ABOUT 10% OF YOU SEE MEDICAL
STUDENT ENROLLMENT- AND YOU
ALSO ALLOCATE FIVE TIME THE
STATE GENERAL FUND FOR MEDICAL
SCHOOL STUDENTS- COMPARED TO
HOW MUCH ALLOCATE FOR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. COULD
OR- DOES DOES. WHY DOES USED
WHAT HEY WHY DOESN'T YOU SEE
HAVE MORE THAN 10% OF THEIR
MEDICAL SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
PRIME AND IS THERE PLANS TO
INCREASE THAT. ARE MEDICAL
SCHOOL DEANS WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO INCREASE OUR PROGRAMS
NOT JUST LIMITED TO THE TWO NEW
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
NOW BUT THERE ARE OTHER-
PROGRAMS AS WELL THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO. INCREASE AND
INCREASE THE SIZE OF THE CRIME
PROGRAMS FUNDING HAS BEEN A
LIMITATION AS HAS BEEN- THE
ABILITY TO. PROVE ENOUGH BASE
FUNDING FOR DISCREDITING.
AGENCY THAT ACCREDITS MEDICAL
SCHOOLS WHAT TO LIMITS THE
AMOUNT OF GROWTH ALSO GROWTH IS
SOMEWHAT LIMITED BY THE NUMBER
OF CLINICS. AND ABILITY TO DO
CLINICAL ROTATIONS NEAR MEDICAL
SCHOOL. BECAUSE OF THOSE
FACTORS- WE HAVEN'T GROWN FIND
AS MUCH AS WE WOULD LIKE TO
WERE VERY OPEN TO A DISCUSSION
ON HOW TO INCREASE THE- NUMBER
OF. CRIMES STUDENTS AND PRIME
TRAINING WITHIN OUR MEDICAL
SCHOOLS ARE TO EITHER ADD
ADDITIONAL COURSES FOR EXISTING
MEDICAL STUDENTS OR TO INCREASE
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF SEATS IN
OUR MEDICAL SCHOOLS. FOR CRIME
PROGRAMS. AND THE ANNUAL
FUNDING OF ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN THE SAN
JOAQUIN PRIME PROGRAM HAS YET
TO ACHIEVE THE FUNDED ON THE
TARGET. OF FORTY EIGHT STUDENTS
WITH ONLY THIRTY SIX STUDENTS
ENROLLED AS OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ACADEMIC YEAR. RATHER
THAN PROVIDING THE FULL AMOUNT
OF ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING UP
FRONT WOULD IT BE REASONABLE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR ONLY FOR
ANY NEW PROGRAMS OVER OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS TO ACCOMMODATE A
MORE REALISTIC. AND GROW
ENROLLMENT GROWTH TIME FRAME.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
BECAUSE MEDICAL SCHOOL SCHOOL
CLASSES INTERACT WITH ONE
ANOTHER WHERE THE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN IN THE PROGRAM
LONGER. WORK AS HELPERS ARE.
ART EDUCATORS FOR THE OF NEW
INCOMING COURSE CLASSES YOU'RE
CREDITING. OUR AGENCY DOES
REQUIRE THE MEDICAL SCHOOL'S
PROOF. THAT THEY HAVE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING BEFORE
ADMITTING ANY STUDENTS OR FOR
ALL. INCOMING COHORTS- THAT
MEANS THAT WE CAN'T RATE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO EACH
INCOMING. COHORT LIKE WE DO
WITH UNDERGRADUATE FRESHMEN FOR
EXAMPLE BUT RATHER WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE YEARS ONE THROUGH OR
FULLY FUNDED BEFORE WE CAN AND
MAKE BUCK FORCE FIRST CLASS-
AND THAT DOES COMPLICATE THE
AMOUNT. OF AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR- CRIME PROGRAMS AND MEDICAL
SCHOOLS WHERE IT'S VERY.
RESOURCE INTENSIVE. THANK YOU
YES. THREE IF YOU COULD. OUR
EXPAND A LITTLE BIT FOR US HOW
THE PRIME PROGRAM DIFFERS FROM
THE REGULAR- MEDICAL SCHOOL
CURRICULUM IF THAT IS THE RIGHT
WORD AND THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THAT PRIME STUDENTS- TAKE THAT
HAVE- ACCESSIBILITY TO AND THE
DIFFERENT PRIME PROGRAMS
THROUGH OUT THE UC SYSTEM AND
THE DIFFERENT AGREES THAT SOME
OF THE PRIME STUDENTS CAN
ATTAIN IN THE PROGRAM. BESIDES
THE MEDICAL DEGREE IF YOU. HAVE
THOSE DETAILS. I THINK I THINK
THEY WERE IN A- GOOD FOR- THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
ARE I HAVE SOME OF THOSE
DETAILS- SURPRISED STUDENTS CAN
FREQUENTLY TAKE A- MASTER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ALONG WITH THEIR
MEDICAL STUDIES- THEY ALSO HAVE
CLINICAL ROTATIONS IN THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY'RE STUDYING TO PRACTICE
WITH- SO THAT THEY GET HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE WITH WORKING WITH
THE POPULATION PROVIDING CARE
IN TERMS OF THE PRIME PROGRAMS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE. WE HAVE
A RURAL CRIME WORKS WITH WORLD
POPULATIONS WE HAVE A LOT TO
KNOW COMMUNITY PRIME WE HAVE
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY FOCUSED
RIDE THE TRAINS DOCTOR
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY- WE HAVEN'T FOR
URBAN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY
WHERE STUDENTS LEARN HOW TO
WORK WITH URBAN A LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS INCLUDING THE
HOMELESS POPULATIONS THAT HAVE
EXTREMELY LIMITED ACCESS. THE
AMERICAN INDIAN THE NATIVE
ALASKAN PRIME AND THE- BLACK
AFRICAN AMERICANS. AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO COMMEND THE
COUNTER FOR THE- PROPOSING THE
TWO NEW PROGRAMS FOR NATIVE
AMERICANS- CARE AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN AMERICANS I THINK BOTH
ARE MUCH NEEDED. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE ALL THIS
UP IN OUR NEXT ISSUE IS NOT A
BUDGET ITEM PER SE IN THE
BUDGET BUT- THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
IS WELL MISTER MEDINA I HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON FINANCIALLY
REFORM. IN THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WE WANT TO GIVE YOU
SEE A CHANCE TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK ON THESE CAL GRANT
REFORM PROPOSALS- ESPECIALLY
RELATED TO INSTITUTIONAL AID.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE I THINK
SEAN BRICK WITH THE UC OPS THE
PRESIDENT. THE CORRECT. YES
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
HI MY NAME IS SEAN BURKE AND I
AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
STUDENT FINANCIAL SUPPORT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA-
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS I'VE
SERVED ON STATEWIDE WORK GROUPS
THAT HAVE. CONTRIBUTED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
NAY COMMISSION'S.
RECOMMENDATIONS ON CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION. I WANT TO START
BY SAYING THAT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR GARCIA AND HER STAFF
HAVE BEEN VERY TRANSPARENT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. OF
DEVELOPING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I WANTED TO
THANK HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP.
THE PROPOSED STRUCTURE IN THE
SEE SACRAMENTO'S ALL VASTLY
SIMPLIFIES THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS. MAKING IT SIMPLE FOR
STUDENTS AND PARENTS TO
UNDERSTAND. YOU'RE GONNA CAL
GRANT TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
CAL GRANT FOUR FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION. EVERY YEAR THE
AWARD IS THE SAME MAN LIKE THE
CURRENT CAL GRANT BE PROGRAM.
ANY ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM
TRACKS WITH THE BIGGEST EDERAL
FINANCIALLY PROGRAM THE PROGRAM.
AT THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL THE CAL
GRANT FOR WOULD SEND A VERY
POWERFUL MESSAGE. FROM THE
STATE TO CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND THEIR PARENTS. IF YOU
QUALIFY FOR POKER FOR A CAL
GRANT. YOU WON'T NEED TO PAY
TUITION AT UC. WE ARE VERY WELL
THE TUITION IS JUST PART OF THE
AFFORDABILITY PICTURE BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS
WORRY FIRST ABOUT TUITION. AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OUR OWN INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL
AID STRATEGY EXPLICITLY TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT ALL THE OTHER
COSTS THAT STUDENTS FACE. SUCH
AS BASIC NEEDS LIKE HOUSING AND
FOOD AS WELL AS BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES TRANSPORTATION AND
HEALTH CARE. OUR GOAL IS TO
TAKE COST OFF THE TABLE FOR
STUDENTS AS THEY MAKE THEIR
COLLEGE CHOICE AND THEN SUPPORT
THEM UNTIL THEY GRADUATE. IF WE
TRY TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
FINANCIALLY IT'S THE ONLY NEED
TO WORK PART TIME CONTRASTING
THEM TO ATTEND SCHOOL FULL
TIME. AND TAKE OUT A MODEST
AMOUNT OF STUDENT LOANS IN
ORDER TO COVER ALL OF THOSE
OCCASIONAL COSTS. WE USE OUR
INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIALLY
PROGRAM TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BY
FILLING IN GAPS. LEFT AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR STATE AND
FEDERAL PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE PARENTS
WHO ARE ABLE TO AFFORD TO PAY.
WE USE OUR INSTITUTIONAL
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM TO COVER
TUITION. FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO DO NOT
GET A RECEIVER CAL GRANT
CURRENTLY. SO FOR EXAMPLE THOSE
WHO EXCEED THE CURRENT AGE
THRESHOLD. CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
OR MAYBE REQUIRE FIFTH YEAR TO
GRADUATE. IN TOTAL BETWEEN THE
COVERAGE PROVIDED BY CAL GRANTS
IN YOU SEE GRASS ABOUT 56% OF
OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. NO
TUITION. IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
STRENGTH OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAMMING COVERING TUITION
AND FEES- MANY UC STUDENTS THAT
MOST OF OUR OWN FINANCIAL AID
GOES TO COVER BASIC NEEDS
ANOTHER EDUCATIONAL COSTS.
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF UC'S NEED
BASED GRANTS AND ABOUT THREE
QUARTERS OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE. GOING TO
PAY FOR THESE COSTS BEYOND
TUITION. THE CALDERON
MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL PUT
FORTH BY SEATAC STRAIGHTEN THIS
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE.
AND THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
IMPROVE THE AFFORDABILITY OF
YOU SEE DEGREE IN OUR STUDENTS
AS A WHOLE. WE THINK THAT UNDER
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL YOU SEE
STUDENTS WOULD BE EFFECTIVE IN
THE FOLLOWING WAYS. SOME YOU
SEE STUDENTS WITH MORE OF A
MIDDLE INCOME BACKGROUNDS WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE CURRENTLY
QUALIFY WOULD NOT QUALIFY IN
THE FUTURE. BUT SLIGHTLY MORE
UC STUDENTS WITH A MORE LOW
INCOME BACKGROUND OR CURRENTLY
SHUT OUT OF THE PROGRAM DUE TO
AGE OR LENGTH OF TIME OF SCHOOL
WHAT QUALIFY. THEREFORE BECAUSE
YOU SEE BACK FILLS WITH ITS OWN
YOU SEE NEED BASED GRANT. THOSE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS WHO DON'T
CURRENTLY GET A CAL GRANT.
COUNTERPROPOSAL WOULD FREE UP
SOME OF THAT YOU SEE NEED BASED
GRANT THAT COULD THAT INSTEAD
GO TOWARDS THE BASIC NEEDS OF
OUR NEEDIEST STUDENTS. IN OTHER
WORDS YOU SEE STUDENTS AS A
WHOLE WOULD BE SO MUCH BETTER
OFF AS A RESULT OF CAL GRANT
PRIORITIZATION. ON THE MARGINS
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS-
DEPENDING ON WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM THOSE MORE MIDDLE
INCOME STUDENTS THAT I
MENTIONED. WHO WOULD NO LONGER
QUALIFY UNDER THE REFORM
PROPOSAL MAY FACE CHALLENGES.
AS IT IS CURRENTLY STRUCTURED
YOU SEEN. IS UNABLE TO HELP
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
RECIPIENTS. YANG WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING FROM THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. THEIR OWN
YOU SEE GRANT DOLLARS. BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THE BILL CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP IS A LAST DOLLAR
PROGRAM AND SO EVERY DOLLAR. IN
INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL AID WE
PROVIDE TO MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP RECIPIENTS REDUCES
A DOLLAR OF THEIR MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP. VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM BUT WE THINK THAT SOME
REFORMS AND HOW. AND THEN
FINALLY LINKING THE STATE'S
FINANCIALLY PROGRAM TO A
FEDERAL PROGRAM TO THE FEDERAL
PELL GRANT DOES MEAN BACKED
POLICY CALLS WILL NEED TO BE
MADE WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CHANGES THEIR
PROGRAM. I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CSX STAFF ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING TO ASSESS WITH
THE CHANGES THAT HAPPENED. IN
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM. OVER THE
HOLIDAYS. ALL IN ALL THOUGH AS
HE SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF MY
REMARKS WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE
THAT OUR CORE PRIORITIES.
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY FIRST
UC STUDENTS AND SIMPLE AND THE
PROGRAMS. ARE PART OF THE
REFORM PROPOSAL. AND AGAIN I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I
THANK YOU MR BREAK AT I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU- SO I OUR
GOAL IS TO ONE SIMPLIFY IT. AND
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY FOR PEOPLE
WHO JUST JUST MISSED OUT THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP THAT'S
A- THAT'S SOMETHING HASN'T BEEN
DETERMINED YET. THAT'S A VERY
POPULAR PROGRAM WITH THE
LEGISLATURE SOME STRONG
OPINIONS ON THAT WE HEARD A FEW
WEEKS AGO. IN OUR COMMITTEE ON
THE CALGARY FORM IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE THERE'S SO FEW IN OUR
STATE BUDGET TO HELP MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES AND RIGHTFULLY
SO OUR BUDGET PROGRAMS HELP.
THAT YOU KNOW THOSE THAT WITH
EXTREME NEED. IT AS LIVING IN
POVERTY- IT BUT YOU KNOW MIDDLE
CLASS MATES AND GET LEFT BEHIND
SO WE HAVE DECIDED WE'RE GONNA
DEAL WITH THAT- POTENTIALLY-
YOU KNOW TAPER DOWN FOR THE
HIGHEST EARNERS IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. BUT STILL
HAVE SOME OF THAT- A THIRD
ROUGHLY THE THIRD TUITION PAID.
I WANTED TO GO BACK TO YOU TO
THE INSTITUTIONAL AID AND- SO
HOW. IS THEIR CONCERN FROM THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HOW WOULD
THAT PLAY. WITH THE- THE READ
THE IS WHAT'S CALLED THE BLUE
AND GOLD RIGHT. HOW DO YOU ARE
THERE IN SAY WHEN. YOU'RE BLUE
AND GOLD PROGRAM AND YOUR THE
THIRD OF THE TUITION GOES BACK
TO FINANCIAL AID. SURE WE DON'T
HAVE- CONCERNS WITH HOW IT
WOULD INTERACT WITH THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL A PROGRAM WHICH
IS ALREADY. FLEXIBLE ENOUGH
THAT IF DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
STUDENTS- QUALIFY FOR CAL GRANT.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO MOVE OUR
INSTITUTIONAL AID MONEY TO HELP
THOSE LOW INCOME STUDENTS WITH
THE NONTRADITIONAL COSTS AND
THEN ALSO- POTENTIALLY COVER
TUITION FOR OTHER STUDENTS SO
IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT RIGHT
NOW WE KIND OF HAVE IT DE FACTO
SYSTEM IN PLACE WITH. USE WITH
UC COVERING. NON TUITION COSTS
FOR YOUR CAL GRANT SLASH PELL
STUDENTS WITH THE BLUE AND GOLD.
YES WE ARE OUR OWN
INSTITUTIONAL A PROGRAM WE'RE
PROVIDING BETWEEN IT DEPENDS ON
THE INDIVIDUAL STUDENT BY ART
TWENTY SIX AND SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS- FOR SOME OF THOSE
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS TO
OFFSET THOSE. NON TUITION COSTS.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE. OKAY DESPITE US NOT
SAYING THAT OKAY THANK YOU THIS
IS AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM AND
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN- CONVERSING
WITH THE UNIVERSITY AS WELL AS
ALL SEGMENTS ON THIS ANYWAY SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. OKAY THANK YOU
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO PLOW
THROUGH NOW. THE- C. S. U. SOME
CSU BUDGET. ISSUES ISSUE NUMBER
ISSUE NUMBER SIX ISSUE NUMBER
ONE FOR CSU IS THE SAME WE HAD
WITH THE UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA
BASED FUNDING SLASH IN A MOMENT
WE HAVE A JENNIFER LOUIS- AT
LEAST IF MILIOANE RYAN FROM CSU.
BERMAN FINANCE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBER AT JENNIFER
LOUIS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IS A STUDENT FOCUSED BUDGET
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON ACCESS
EQUITY AND BUDGETARY
RESILIENCY- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND AND WITHIN THIS
AMOUNT- WE'RE PROVIDING CSE
WITH ONE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT- NO MY AT CSU
STANISLAUS STOCKTON CENTER AT
ONE TIME AUGMENTATIONS WERE C.
S. U. AT TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION- THIS ISN'T THIS.
AUGMENTATION INCLUDES A 3% BASE
INCREASE TOTALING A HUNDRED
ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND WHAT THE
FOLLOWING EXPECTATIONS ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS THAT THE
CSU WILL OF ONE MAINTAIN
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
UNDERGRADUATE TUITION AND FEES
AT THE CURRENT LEVEL FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
TWO ACADEMIC YEAR- PREPARE A
REPORT IDENTIFYING ACTIONABLE
WAYS A SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING
EQUITY GAPS WITH THE GOAL OF
FULLY CLOSING EQUITY GAPS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. ADULT
POLICIES SO THAT CAMPUS IS A
STAIN THEIR ONLINE LEARNING
PROGRAMS THAT TEMPER SET UP
ABOVE PRE CODED LEVELS ARE
BETTER ALIGNED STUDENT LEARNING
OBJECTIVES WITH STUDENTS WITH
WORKFORCE NEEDS AND FINALLY
ESTABLISH A NEW STANDALONE TOOL
MISSION PATHWAY TO CSU UPON
COMPLETION A LOWER DIVISION
RECORD CHOIR MATES AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO GO INTO FURTHER
DETAIL AS REQUESTED OR ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU LMAO.
CHIANG AND- THINKING WENT PANEL
NOT. THIS MORNING MY CAN
CONCENTRATE ON AND THE ECB
FUNDING ITEM COMES LARGELY BY
AS WELL AND SO IN THE INTEREST
OF I'LL BE BRIEF BUT THE
FEBRUARY PAYMENT PLACE THEN
MEAN QUESTION LET RIGHT NOW TO
CA BASED. IS WANTED TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL. SUCH AS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PERCENT OUR
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS QUESTION
IS. TO REVISIT THE MAYOR.
SONOMA COMMISSION AVAILABLE TO
LECTURE. BOTH IN THE STATE OUT
BUT YOU CAN. AND ON THE IMPACT
OF THE COULD THERE FEDERAL
POLICE ARE PENDING. REGARDING
THE COMPANY'S EXPECTATIONS TO
POST 3% BASED ON. WE HAVE THE
SAME CAN HERE AS WE RAISED THE
SIMILAR YOU SEE I. SPECIFICALLY
A LONG EDUCATE. AND THE DEAL.
FINALLY ON THE TOP OF MOMENT.
THE GOVERNOR BUDGET IS KNOW
DOES NOT SEND AN MOMENT. YES
YOU. ALL IT DOES IS THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTED. BY
CONTRACT WILL FOR THE STATUS
STATE OCT CAMP CENTER STOP. TO
REITERATE BELIEVE THAT SAID
ANIMAL AXACT FOR THE- SYSTEM.
IN THE QUEUE RESPONSIBLE IN
THIS. LEGISLATORS ALSO
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING
TARGETED AND WILL FUNDING THE
STATE CAN ARE. THE FIRST WORK
WITH THE IN. YES YOU TIED SET
OF FACTS TO USE IN PRIORITIZING
CAMPUS CENTRIST THIS. WE THINK
IT DOES HELP SURE THAT ABOUT
WHICH CAMPUS ACTRESSES IF I
COULDN'T MOVE OKAY OUR
SYSTEMATIC. THANK YOU I'D BE
HAPPY TO IT. THANK YOU SEE IF
YOU. WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ON BEHALF OF THIS YEAR ISSUE
FOR DELVING INTO EACH OF THE
ISSUES ON OUR AGENDA TODAY.
YOUR MCCARTY HI MY NAME IS RYAN
STORM I AM THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR BUDGET FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR.
SEVERAL OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
JOINING TODAY DOCTOR LOW ON THE
ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
STUDENT AFFAIRS AND ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT. MISS BY SAN JUAN
SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
CAPITAL PLANNING DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION. AND MR NATHAN
EVANS CHIEF OF STAFF AND SENIOR
ADVISER FOR ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS. THE FOUR OF US
WILL PROVIDE YOU THE DETAILS
WORK FROM SPECIES PERSPECTIVES
AND ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS. NOW
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS A FEW NEW
MEMBERS AND TO GET TO KNOW THE
FUTURE WILL BE BETTER. I'D LIKE
TO SHARE SOME VERY HIGH LEVEL
INFORMATION ABOUT SEATS YOU. SO
THE NATION'S LARGEST FOUR YEAR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY TO SEE ISSUE
PROVIDES EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES 284-008-6000
STUDENTS. ON TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES. NOW STRETCHING FROM
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY IN
THE NORTH TO SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY IN SOUTH CSU
ANNUALLY ANNUALLY CAN FOR SOME
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DEGREES. AND BOASTS
NEARLY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION LIVING ALUMNI. NEARLY
HALF OF ALL A BACHELOR'S
DEGREES WERE THE CITY IN
CALIFORNIA R. C. ISSUE DEGREES.
AND ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIA
WORKERS IS A CSU GRADUATE AND
IN FACT ONE IN TWENTY AMERICANS
HOLDING A COLLEGE DEGREE IS A
GRADUATE OF THE SEATS YOU. NOW
TO MY OVERALL COMMENTS ABOUT
THE BUDGET. GOVERNOR NUISANCE
FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR THE CSU
RECOGNIZES THE POWERFUL ROLE
OUR CAMPUS IS PLAYED IN THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY. THIS
ISSUE STANDS READY TO DO EVEN
MORE AND REQUEST THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING THAT
WHICH RESTORE PRIOR CUTS CREATE
JOBS THROUGH INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AND ENSURE WE
CONTINUE TO REDUCE EQUITY GAPS
AND PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE WORKFORCE.
THIS YEAR SHE WAS EXPERIENCE A
BUDGET IS EXPERIENCING BUDGET
CHALLENGES BECAUSE OF A TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NINE BILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING STATE FUNDING
REDUCTION. WE ARE ONE OF THE
VERY VERY FEW STATE PROGRAMS
THAT RECEIVED AN ONGOING
CONFLICT THAT'S- THAT'S NOT
ALL. OUR SO FUNDED STUDENT
ENTERPRISE PROGRAMS NOT CELERY
SUCH AS STUDENT HOUSING PARKING
AND DINING AT REVENUE LOSSES
AND COSTS THAT EXCEED SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SINCE
THE START OF A PANDEMIC. WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S RECESSED SINCE
WITH SOME OF THOSE LOSSES AND
COSTS. AS A BEACON OF SOCIAL
MOBILITY AND JOB CREATORS THERE
ARE THREE AREAS WHERE WE ARE
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS. FIRST RESTORATION
OF THOSE CUTS TO MAINTAIN JOBS.
THIS ISSUE HAS LARGELY BEEN
ABLE TO AVOID SYSTEM WIDE
LAYOFFS AND FURLOUGHS OF ITS
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND FACULTY
STAFF. PRUDENT FISCAL
MANAGEMENT AND USE OF RESERVES
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO THIS
LONGSTRETH OUT THAT RESTORATION
IN THE STATE BUDGET THE SUMMER.
SECOND I GRADUATION SHIP TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE OR EVEN MORE
DIVERSE WORKFORCE. ISSUE HAS
IMPROVED ITS FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE BY 63% SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
THAT'S A NIGHT I REQUEST THIRTY
POINT 19% GROWING 231% THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENT IN
AN UNPARALLELED RETURN ON YOUR
INVESTMENT OUR WORK IS
UNFINISHED AS WE MUST ELIMINATE
THE GAPS. IN THIRD ECONOMIC
FACILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CREATE JOBS NOW SEE SHE HASN'T
IDENTIFIED SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS KNACK AND
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. INCLUDING FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION AND APPROVED
PROJECTS THAT CAN IMMEDIATELY
PROCEED TO DESIGN ERROR
CONSTRUCTION TO HELP STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY. WE KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED ALREADY
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION IN ONE SENTENCE FOR
THIS. SO NOW IN CONCLUSION
HERE'S THE SUMMARY ISSUES USE
POSITION ON THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROPOSALS SO
ON THE BUDGET RESTORATION LAST
MONTH THE SPEAKER OF THE PRO
TEM. THE GOVERNOR COMMITTED TO
FULLY RESTORE THAT. IN THE C.
SHE WAS VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THAT COMMITMENT AND CLEARLY
SUPPORTS IT. AT RESTORATION HAS
NOT YET BEEN CODIFIED AND WE
ENCOURAGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH. AND INCLUDE
THAT FULL RESTORATION IN THE
FINAL BUDGET ACT THIS SUMMER.
ON THE ADMINISTRATION'S BASED
PROPOSAL SEIZE YOUR SUPPORTS
THE ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION OF ONGOING DOLLARS
PROPERTY COST INCREASES AS- AS
MENTIONED EARLIER BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN ALL THE CSU
UP OR TRUSTEES REMAINING
REQUEST I HAVE TWO NUMBERS FOR
YOU TO REMEMBER SIXTY SIX
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDS AND
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDING. THIS ISSUE
SIX ADDITIONAL SIXTY SIX
MILLION OF ONGOING FUNDING
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
PROPOSAL. IF YOU WERE. TO GRANT
OUR REQUEST IT WOULD FULLY
COVER COSTS WE CANNOT AVOID
SUCH AS RISING HEALTH CARE
PREMIUM INCREASES. WHAT ALSO
FULLY FIVE GRADUATION SHIP
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THAT
REQUEST WHICH WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO THE RESILIENCY OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND STUDENTS
FUTURES. FURTHER THIS ISSUE SIX
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION AND ONE TIME
DOLLARS TO FUND ACADEMIC
FACILITIES AND RURAL NEEDS THAT
TOO IS ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY PROPOSAL. SO THOSE ARE
THE C. ISSUES OVERALL COMMENTS
ON THE BUDGET MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER NATHAN EVANS HAS
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO SHARE.
THANK YOU MISTER STORM AND
THANK YOU- CHARM MCCARTY I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF- ONCE AGAIN
NATHAN EVANS CHIEF OF STAFF AND
SENIOR ADVISER. FOR ACADEMIC
AND STUDENT AFFAIRS IN THE CSU
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR- I
THINK I WOULD JUST ADD TO WHAT
RYAN SHARE THAT- IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT DESPITE THE
PANDEMIC- LAST MAY UP NEARLY A
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND A
RECORD NUMBER. CSU STUDENTS
EARNED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND
JOINED THE RANKS OF OUR MORE
THAN THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
ALUMNI. AND WHILE COLLECTIVELY
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE NATION-
SOL UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT
DROPPED. BY APPROXIMATELY 4% TO
SEE ISSUES ENROLLMENT ACTUALLY
GREW TO A RECORD HIGH. OF OVER
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS. AND PERHAPS
MOST NOTABLY CONTRIBUTING TO
THAT WAS OUR HIGHEST RETENTION
RATE EVER. FOR FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS HAVE 85% FOR THEIR
FIRST TO SECOND YEAR OUR
RETENTION. AND WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S A TESTAMENT
NOT ONLY TO OUR STUDENTS
RESOLVE BUT ALSO TO THEIR TRUST
IN THE CSU ON DAY AND THEIR
FAMILIES. TO ENSURE THEIR
PROGRESS TOWARD- HIGH QUALITY
DEGREE. AND I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT THIS IS OCCURRING BECAUSE
OF OUR AT THE C. ISSUES ON
WAVERING COMMITMENT TO OUR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THAT MR STORM SPOKE
ABOUT. REALLY FOCUSED ON THREE
KEY OBJECTIVES IMPROVING
GRADUATES HAVE GRADUATION RATES
FOR ALL STUDENTS ELIMINATING
EQUITY AND OPPORTUNITY KICK
GAPS IN DEGREE COMPLETION. AND
METER MEETING CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE WORKFORCE NEEDS- BUT AS
YOU'VE HEARD OUR WORK ISN'T
FINISHED EVEN WITH ALL THIS
PROGRESS- IN DOING OUR PARK FOR
A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WE MUST
ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS IN THOSE
OUTCOMES BY RACE BY INCOME. AND
BY FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE. AND WITH THE SOCIAL
UNREST IN OUR ECONOMIC UPHEAVAL
UPHEAVAL THAT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES HAVING CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
MORE IMPORTANT RETURN ON
INVESTMENT SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MY
COLLEAGUES AND I- AND MR TRUMP
WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE- OVERVIEW- PHILLIMORE
VITAS DID YOU DO IT YEP YOU
HAVE A CSU IN YOUR DISTRICT IN.
RIGHT OUTSIDE WHICH WHICH ONE
CAN'T. CASTING NORTHRIDGE OKAY
SELF- DO YOU LIKE TO START HERE
GO AHEAD I JUST HAVE A SIMILAR
QUESTION IS WHAT I ASKED THAT
THE UC SEGMENT- AROUND THE
SPECIFICS FOR EQUITY GOALS WHAT
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION- X.
BACK WHAT WHAT ARE THEY
EXPECTING THE PLANS TO REFLECT
AN ACHIEVED. BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. I THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- SO WE HAVE BEEN AS WE
WERE DESCRIBING WE ARE MIDWAY
THROUGH OUR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE-
PROCESS AND AT THE BEGINNING OF
THAT. EACH CAMPUS AND OUR
SYSTEM THAT- STRETCH GOALS FOR
THEIR OVERALL GRADUATION RATES
FOR FIRST YEAR STUDENTS AT IT
FOUR YEAR AND SIX YEAR MARKING
FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS AT A TWO
YEAR AND FOUR YEAR MARK AND
EMBEDDED IN THOSE GOALS WAS THE
ABSOLUTE ELIMINATION. OF EQUITY
GAPS BY RACE ETHNICITY BY
HEALTH STATUS AND BY FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE ATTENDANCE
STATUS. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CAMPUSES THAT ARE ALREADY
ZEROED OUT THOSE GOALS THAT YOU
MARK MAY HAVE HEARD FROM
CHANCER CASTRO WHEN HE SPOKE TO
THIS COMMITTEE- BUT WE HAVE
OTHER CAMPUSES THAT STILL HAVE
WORK TO DO AND SO. FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF INFORMATION SHARING ACROSS
OUR CAMPUSES I'VE HEARD CHANCER
CASTRO NOTE THAT FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE THREE C. ISSUES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- ONE OF THOSE
CAMPUSES ARE STANISLAUS HAS
EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATED THEIR
EQUITY GAP FOR PELL STUDENTS.
SO AGAIN SHARING THOSE
EXPERIENCES AND THOSE
STRATEGIES THAT HAVE BEEN USED
ACROSS OUR CAMPUSES SO THAT'S
ONE ELEMENT IS REALLY
BENEFITING FROM THE LEARNED AND
LIVED EXPERIENCES. OF OUR CSU
CAMPUSES AND THEIR LEADERS AND
STUDENTS TODAY THE SECOND
ACTUALLY JUST ABOUT THREE WEEKS
AGO WE DELIVERED TO EVERY CSU
PRESIDENT- THROUGH AN EQUITY
REPORT- LOOKING AT THEIR
TRAJECTORY TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE GOAL OF ELIMINATING EQUITY
GAPS. AND AROUND THAT WERE
THREE SORT OF STRATEGIC AREAS
OF FOCUS THAT WE ENCOURAGE EACH
CAMPUS TO REALLY BUILD AND MORE
DETAILED PLAN AROUND- FIRST WAS
ON STUDENTS THAT HAD ALREADY
LEFT THE CSU AND HOW TO RE
ENGAGE THOSE STUDENTS- IF THEY
BEGAN AND LET'S SAY PAUL
NINETEEN OR FULL TWENTY. THAT
PERHAPSOF ALREADY LEFT
UNIVERSITY STRATEGIES TO RE
ENGAGE THOSE STUDENTS THE
SECOND WORST DIDN'T THAT MAY.
BE AT RISK OF LEAVING THE
UNIVERSITY YES BASED THEIR YEAR
PER- OR THE- OF COURSES THEY'VE
TAKEN. AND THEN THERE WAS A
THIRD STRATEGY LOOKING AT
SPECIFICALLY- AREAS AND MAJORS
AND DISCIPLINES IN WHICH THEY
ARE MAYBE HIGHER NON PASS RATES
WITH SOME STRATEGIES AROUND
THAT SO FROM THAT OUR WORK IS
REALLY DATA INFORMED AND THAT'S
BEEN THE FODDER FOR THEIR
CONVERSATIONS THAT EACH CAMPUS
WILL BE- GOING BACK TO THOSE
ORIGINAL PLANS THAT THEY
DEVELOPED. BUILDING ON THEM
BASED ON THE PROGRESS THEY'VE
MADE ALREADY. GREAT THANK YOU.
NO FOR THE CURRENT QUESTIONS
CHECK OKAY. THANK YOU- I WANTED
TO ENGAGE ON THE ENROLLMENT
ISSUES AND THAT THE REDIRECTION.
SO OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
INTERESTING TIMES THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC- I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
CAN PROPERLY ESTIMATE WHERE
WE'RE AT AS FAR AS DEMAND
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH COVER NINETEEN
BUT WE DID SEE WITH OUR LAST
PANEL HUGE INCREASE OF PERSEUS
FOR YOU SEE AN APPLICATIONS.
ARE ARE WE SEEING ROUGHLY THE
SAME INCREASE FOR THE CSU FOR
APPLICATIONS. THEY HAD ABOUT A
16% INCREASE. ALL HELLO HI I'M
LAW HARNESSES ARE VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR STUDENT AFFAIRS
AND ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT SO
I'LL I'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
THAT QUESTION SO WE CONTINUE TO
TRACK OUR- APPLICATIONS VERY
CAREFULLY AS YOU WELL KNOW WE
DID HAVE ANOTHER RECORD SETTING
SEMESTER THIS PAST FALL IN
TERMS OF OVERALL ENROLLMENT.
BASED ON THE LATEST SNAPSHOT
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN AND WE JUST
HAD OUR LAST CAMPUS CLOSE ARE
OUT THE OFFICIAL APPLICATION
ARE DEADLINE- AT THE END OF
FEBRUARY AND SO IN LOOKING AT
THAT WE ARE NOW ROUGHLY AT
ABOUT THREE PERCENT. BOB LAST
FEWER APPLICATIONS THAN
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR AND WHAT
YOU'RE A SO THIS YEAH WHAT DO
YOU WHAT WHAT I'M SORRY
INTERRUPT YOU- YOU ARE DONE YET
BUT THAT WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE
THAT TO EAT EAT EAT YOU SEE FOR
FIRST TIME FRESHMEN THE SAME
ROUGHLY POOL OF. HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES YOU NOT QUITE BUT
COLLEGE READY- PERFORMED WELL
ACADEMICALLY IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
YOU SEE OR GETTING A 16%
INCREASE IN CSU. ADDRESS IS IT
THE- THE FINANCIAL MEANS FOR
THE STUDENTS BACK HOME IN THEIR
FAMILIES MANY THE SAME
DEMOGRAPHICS FOR THE ARE FOR
THE UC SELL IT CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH. HOW DO YOU TO BE THE
DIFFERENCE. YEAH AND I THINK
THERE MULTIPLE RE I THINK THE
AN X. QUESTION. I WOULD
ACTUALLY OFF FRIENDLY SUGGESTS
THAT IN MANY WAYS OUR CSU
STUDENTS ARE MUCH MORE SIMILAR
TO OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ENROLLMENTS IN TERMS OF OUR
FINANCIAL STATUS AND FAMILY
SITUATIONS SO THERE ARE
MULTIPLE FACTORS WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT THE IMPACT ON
COLLEGE. ACCESS AN ASPIRATION
IN MANY WAYS HAS MIRRORED THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY RIGHT IT'S A
K. AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THAT FAMILIES THAT HAVE MORE
ECONOMIC MEANS. WE'RE SEEING
LESS VARIANCE IN THEIR DESIRE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND THEN FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE MORE
FINANCIALLY CHALLENGED OUR
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC THAT'S
CARRYING OUT- DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND WE IMAGINE POST
PANDEMIC. WILL HAVE A DECREASED
DEMAND BECAUSE THEY ARE NEEDING
TO MEET OTHER LIFE LIFE
PRIORITIES AT THIS TIME SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S ONE FACTOR
THAT'S CONTRIBUTING TO THE
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT WE ARE STILL
QUITE PLEASED THAT WE HAD
EXPECTED THAT THE DROP IN
APPLICATIONS WILL BE HIGHER-
TRACKING WITH. OTHER NATIONAL-
UP FOR OUR PROJECTIONS AND-
TRENDS THAT WE'RE SEEING
NATIONWIDE FOR OUR
INSTITUTIONAL TYPES SO OUR
FOCUS IS THAT WE STILL ARE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING ACCESS.
APPLICATIONS ARE ONLY ONE
NUMBER AND SO IT'S STILL
IMPORTANT THAT WE ADMIT OUR
STUDENTS ARE EVERY SINGLE ONE
THAT IS A QUALIFIED AND
ELIGIBLE FOR CSU ADMISSION. AND
HELP GET THEM ENROLLED AND COME
TO COLLEGE SO THAT OUR COLLEGE
ATTAINMENT WILL BE A PART OF
THEIR ECONOMIC RECOVERY AS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. THE
LAST FACTOR I WOULD ADDRESSES
THAT ON SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD WE HAVE AN IMPENDING
ENROLLMENT CLASS. THAT IS
COMING SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
APPLICATION NUMBERS THEY
ACTUALLY VARY FROM CAMPUS TO
CAMPUS SO SOME CAMPUSES STILL%
SAW AN INCREASE SO OFTEN THAT
IS IN A DROP. YOU'RE. GONNA SEE
IT WE'RE GONNA SEE A DROP YES I
AM ONLY CLIPPER FOR TO THE
PRINT. DRAW OVERALL IN THE NO
OF NEW. HIGH SCHOOL GRAD- THAT
WILL BE COMING OUT CALIFORNIA
ALONE BY TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
WHICH IS WHEN THE PROJECTIONS
GO OUT TO- IS PROJECTED TO
EXPERIENCE A 16% DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF NEW. HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES SO FOR SOME PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE ALREADY
STARTING TO SEE THE IMPACT OF
THAT- AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY HAVE ALREADY STARTED
THEIR DECLINE AS WELL SO I
THINK THAT IS ANOTHER
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR. WE CERTAINLY HAVE MANY
OTHER STUDENTS AND ADULTS THAT
WE CONSERVE BUT THAT IS ONE
PIECE TO LOOK AT. I'M ON THAT
ISSUE- IT AT THAT IN IT WHAT
THE ONE THING I'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT IS. WAIT WE
HAVE MORE STUDENTS WHO ARE. ALL
IS READY AND MORE STUDENTS WHO
I THINK ARE REALIZING THAT THE
TICKET TO A GOOD PAYING JOB IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY IS MORE
THAN HIGH SCHOOL SEE EVEN NOW
WE WE'RE GONNA HAVE FEWER. THE
NUMBER OF PERTH IF YOU WERE AT
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT MORE OF
THOSE EXISTING GRADUATES. CSU
ELIGIBLE IN REDDING AND SO THE
IT WOULDN'T HAVE AS MUCH OF AN
IMPACT ON THE DROP IN.
APPLICATIONS ARE YOU STILL
ANTICIPATE. THE DROP. SO THAT'S
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION AND THIS
REFLECTS THE VERY COMPLICATED
NATURE RIGHT OF PROJECTING
IMPACTS ON APPLICATIONS I THINK
ALL HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES THERE
IS INDICATION THAT A GREATER
PROPORTION OF THEM ARE MORE
COLLEGE READY BUT THEN HOW THAT
INTERFACES WITH THE TOTAL
NUMBER AND I WHAT'S IMPORTANT
TO KEEP IN MIND IS THAT
COMPETITION THEN FOR ALL
STUDENTS RIGHT GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS GOING TO INCREASE IN
INTENSITY SO OTHER STATES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ARE GOING TO
EXPERIENCE A DEEPER DROP MAYBE
LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA
CRITICALLY THOSE CAMPUSES ARE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE LOOKING
TO INCREASE THEIR ETHNIC OR
RACIAL DIVERSITY WILL OFTEN
COME TO CALIFORNIA. RIGHT TO
INCREASE- AND ADDRESS THOSE
GOALS SO I HAVE TO SAY THAT
WITHOUT OUR ACTUAL DATA GOING
FORWARD GOING TO HAVE TO
MONITOR THIS I WOULD BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT PROJECTING WHAT
WILL BE THE NET IMPACT BUT WE
ARE CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE TO
ONE THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE
STUDENTS WE SERVE OUR FOR
EXAMPLE WE ARE TRYING TO RAISE
ATTENTION ABOUT THIS STUDENTS
WHO HAVE ARE OLDER ADULTS AND
WHO HAVE SOME COLLEGE BUT HAVE
NOT COMPLETED THEIR FOUR YEAR
DEGREE SO WE WANT TO
INTENTIONALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE
SERVE A GREATER PROPORTION OF
THOSE STUDENTS AS AN EXAMPLE SO
ACTIONS LIKE THAT COULD HELP
OFFSET. WHATEVER IN RALEIGH
CLIP FOR EXPERIENCING FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. OKAY. AND THEN-
MAYBE RYAN CAN YOU- OR OR OR OR
YOU AS WELL HERE I'M SORRY FOR
CATCHING THE AND GET YOUR NAME
AGAIN. LATELY THE ONE COULD GET
SOMEBODY FROM THE C. S. YOU
TALK ABOUT THE REDIRECTION
POLICY. AND HOW THAT'S GOING SO
FAR AND- IF WE NEEDED DURING
THE TO DOING TO ADD TO ADJUSTED
OCCUR KEEP THAT GUN. I CAN
CERTAINLY ADDRESS THAT MONEY IS
LOW LOW LOW. OKAY EVERYONE FINE
ON THE SCREEN RIGHT NOW SO- WE
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE- NOW ABOUT
TWO YEARS UNDER OUR BELT AND I
BELIEVE THERE IS A SUMMARY OF
THE REDIRECTION DATA SO WE THIS
IS BEEN A WONDERFUL LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR US SO WITH TWO
YEARS UNDER OUR BELTS- I THINK
YOU WILL SEE IN THE AGENDA THAT
UNFORTUNATELY HAVEN'T HAD
NECESSARILY- THE YIELD RATE
THAT WE WOULD LIKE BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTICE
WE HAVE SEVERAL HUNDRED
STUDENTS WHO THEN WERE OFFERED
ADMISSION TO A CSU THAT MIGHT
NOT HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN OFFER
THAT SO IT WAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. R. FOR ACCEPTING
THEY ARE A NOTABLE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS I THINK WHAT WE
LEARNED IN THIS IS THAT BOB
THERE ARE A SMALL NUMBER OF
CAMPUSES THAT PROVIDE THE
SIGNIFICANT AN ALMOST
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO END UP
BEING PRETTY DIRECT IT AND THE
REALITY OF IT IS THAT
ULTIMATELY STUDENTS ARE
APPLYING TO A CAMPUS RIGHT THE
CAMPUS HAS THE BRAND THE CAMPUS
HAS THE IDENTITY THAT THE
CAMPUS HAS THE DISTINCTIVE
PERSONALITY ARE ATTRIBUTES ARE
CLIMATE THAT THE STUDENT IS
SEEKING AND THAT IS WHERE THEY
ASPIRE TO GO AND STILL OFFERING
REDIRECTION FOR SOME STUDENTS
IF THAT WAS NOT AS SIGNIFICANT
AN ASPECT OF THEIR COLLEGE
CHOICE- THEY'RE MORE INTERESTED
IN BEING ABLE TO JUST GET THE
COLLEGE DEGREE. BUT WE'RE
SEEING THAT FOR A LARGE NUMBER
OF OUR STUDENTS TO REDIRECT THE
pSIMPLY BEING REFUSE BECAUSE
THAT DOESN'T THEM MATCH WHAT
THEIR COLLEGE ASPIRATIONS LIES
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON COMMUNICATION
TECHNIQUES WE DO BELIEVE THAT
IN THE FORTHCOMING YEARS WHERE
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS WILL BE
CHALLENGING FOR MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES AS THEY FACE RECOVERY
IN THE POST PANDEMIC ERA THAT
THERE WILL BE SOME PRESSURE- TO
GO TO CAMPUSES THAT ARE CLOSER
TO THEM SO WE'RE GOING. TO
WATCH AND CERTAINLY EVALUATE I
NEXT YEAR THE NEXT ROUND OR- TO
THE THERE WERE AN IN. YES THANK
YOU SEMIRAMIDE AT US SO DOES
THE CSU HAVE A TO HAVE DATA ON
WHETHER RE DIRECTED STUDENTS
WHO DO NOT ENROLL IN THE CSU
CAMPUS CHOOSE TO ENROLL IN
ANOTHER COLLEGE UNIVERSITY AND
WHAT AND WHAT A HEARING IN IN
IN YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
GONNA EVALUATE. OVER THE NEXT
YEAR ARE YOU COLLECTING DATA ON
THIS. WE DO HAVE SOME DATA SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN LOOKING AT ALL
STUDENTS WHO ARE STILL WHICH
CSU ELIGIBLE AND WHO DON'T END
UP. ARE COMING TO ENROLLING AT
A CSU PER SE WELL WE KNOW THAT
MANY OF THEM DO END UP GOING TO
EITHER- I COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
YOU SEE SO THE OTHER SEGMENTS
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IRONICALLY- OUR SOME OF OUR OUR
MOST SIGNIFICANT. COMPETITORS
WERE ALSO MONITORING TO SEE HOW
MANY STUDENTS ARE ARE GOING OUT
OF STATE- BUT RIGHT NOW THE
LARGEST PERCENTAGES IN THOSE
AREAS WHAT IS INTERESTING. IS
THAT THERE THERE WAS A GROUP OF
STUDENTS THAT IT DID NOT APPEAR
HAD NECESSARILY GONE TO ANOTHER
INSTITUTION. THAT WE COULD SEE
WITHIN THAT THAT IMMEDIATE YEAR
NOT A LARGE NUMBER- BUT THAT
IT'S JUST SOMETHING OF INTEREST
TO NOTE BUT FOR SURE OVER 60%
WE WOULD SAY ARE GOING TO
EITHER C. C. OR TO A UC CAMPUS.
THANK YOU. WELL I THINK THIS IS
A- AND THE IDEA THAT THAT- HAS
BEEN EMBRACE IT IS WORKING AND
I'LL GIVE CREDIT TO OUR BUDGET
CHAIR TANKER REALLY PUSHED US
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS- A FEW
YEARS AGO AND- I THINK IT'S
WORKING SO BUT UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS NOT THAT THE OVERALL
BUDGET ISSUE WAS TALKING ABOUT
BASE FUNDING ARRANGEMENT AND-
AS WE KNOW IT AS AS NOTED BY A
RAINSTORM- YOU KNOW CSU
APPRECIATES THE RESTORATION OF
LAST YEAR'S CATS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT THE
LARGER PICTURE AND LOOKING AT
WHAT'S COMING IN THE MAIL
REVISED AS WELL AS- A ONE TIME
MONEY. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO- THANK YOU KNOW I
WAS GONNA ASK YOU SEE THIS
QUESTION AND I FORGOT SALAS YOU
BRIAN- ANSWER THIS FROM THE
BUDGET PERSPECTIVE WHAT WHAT'S
YOUR BASICALLY HOT TAKE ON THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS BROWN THREE-
IT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S GOING TO
BE I THINK FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR HIGHER ED. FOR- CAN. SEVEN
THAT GOES DIRECTLY FOR STUDENTS
OF COURSE FINANCIAL AID IS
IMPORTANT BUT- SUFFER COMMITTEE
CALLS BUT LOOKS LIKE ABOUT A
BILLION. I BELIEVE KLIENT
ROUGHLY FOR UCCS HIMSELF MISTER
STORM YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON
WHAT THE CSU WILL DO WHAT YOUR
SHARE ASSUMING THAT THE HOUSE
PASSES IT AND GET SIGNED BY THE
PRESIDENT BUT THAT LOOKS TO BE.
THE CASE TODAY. YEAH THE OTHER
SIDE THERE SEEMS TO MAJOR
PIECES OF THE- THE NEW S.
RABBITS. LEGISLATION FIRST.
THERE IS AID TO STUDENTS WHICH
IS ABOUT 50% OF THAT. AND THEN
THERE IS- INSTITUTIONAL SYSTEMS
WERE INSTITUTIONALLY. THAT'S
THE OTHER PORTION OF THAT-
GRAND TOTAL FROM AN
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT
PERSPECTIVE- WE ANTICIPATE- WE
ANTICIPATE. GO AHEAD RANK. OKAY
I'M SORRY I LOOK AT MY SCREEN
WAS NOT WORKING WELL SO I
PAUSED AND HEARD SOME SOME
NOISE IN THE BACKGROUND BUT
ANYWAY I THE GRAND TOTAL THAT
WE ANTICIPATE RESPONSE
PRELIMINARY INFORMATION OUT OF
SOME OF OUR PARTNERS IN THE
FEDERAL ATTACK I READ THAT WE
ANTICIPATE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
COULD BE USED IN INSTITUTIONAL
AID. TO SUPPORT OUR CAMPUS IS
NOW THERE'S A BIG CARRY OUT
WITH THAT THIS IS NOT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT YOU CAN ONE SPEND ON
ANYTHING YET GENERALLY AREN'T
ARE INTELLIGENT SAYS THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO USE THIS
FUNDING A LOT LIKE THAT FIRST
TWO ROUNDS OF THE FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE WHICH WAS TO
REIMBURSE REVENUE LOSSES AND
CAN COVER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT WHAT THE CAN DOWN NEXT. SO
THAT THAT WILL HAVE A CERTAIN
LIMITATION THE OTHER MAJOR
LIMITATION OF COURSE IS THAT.
IT'S ONE TIME FUNDING. THAT'S
THE MAG. THAT WE BEGINNING ALL
IN INTO OF. SYSTEM TO THE
UNIVERSE. FROM ALL THREE ROUNDS
OF FUNDING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. I'M SORRY NO
ONE POINT SIX MILLION ONE POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS. I HAD I
HAD A COUPLE OF A SUB SUB
TOTALS. ONE POINT SIX BILLION
TO ASSIST WITH A NUMBER OF. I
CHALLENGES THAT ALL OF OUR ALL
OF OUR ELEMENTS WERE
UNIVERSALLY OR FACE YES SO IN
PLAIN ENGLISH THAT ONE TIME
MONEY WHAT WOULD WHAT WOULD YOU
DO IT WELL WHAT CAMPUS IS DOING
THAT. WELL CERTAINLY ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR US HAS BEEN A
LOSS OF PARKING REVENUE. AND
HOUSING HOUSING IS STILL VERY
LIMITED ON OUR CAMPUSES. AND SO
THAT WOULD REIMBURSE THE IT WAS
PROGRAMS STUMBLE ACROSS THIS
BELT CAN. SIMPLY BACK FILL FOR
COVERED LOSSES RIGHT. RIGHT THE
OTHER THING TOO IS THAT WE HAVE
LOTS OF COSTS RELATED TO- WE
ANNUALLY LIKE EVERY OTHER STATE
AGENCY BE TO ROUTE REQUIRE OUR
COST IMPLICATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ON A
PERIODIC BASIS WERE WELL OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION THERE- I AM
TELLING AND WE ALSO ARE
FORECASTING IN THE FUTURE THAT
WILL HAVE A NUMBER OF. POSSIBLE
LOSSES AS WE CONTINUE THROUGH
THIS- THIS SPRING TERM RIGHT.
WE HAVE I HAVE SOME DATA THAT
IS ONLY UP AND GET THROUGH. D.
JANUARY TIME FRAME SO WE HAVE.
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND LOSSES
THAT WILL BE EXPERIENCING. A
THROUGH THE SPRING TERM. YEAH
OKAY. THANK YOU. WE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN AND I WILL NOTE
THAT WE ARE NOW IN ISSUE SEVEN
SECOND CSU ISSUE BUT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE OUR RECESS AS WAS
DONE EARLIER DURING THE
HEARING. WE HAVE- I RESPECTED
CAUCUSES AND SO. WE HOPE TO BE
BACK IN ABOUT AN HOUR BUT STAY
TUNED. THANK YOU.
BY ABOUT ONE
MINUTE.
THE.
OKAY WILL BEGIN AS
THE- SUB COMMITTEE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LIKE SAY. BUT
WE'RE HERE HERE HERE THE SHOW
GOES ON SO LET'S PROCEED NOW
WITH ISSUE SEVEN STUDENTS
SUPPORT BASIC NEEDS PROPOSALS
FROM THE CSU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR- GENERALLY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS FOUR
HUNDRED BUDGET WITH AN EMPHASIS
ON ACCESS EQUITY AND BUDGET
RESILIENCY AS IT HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED IN LIGHT OF THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC STUDENTS
SUPPORT- AND BASIC NEEDS ARE
CRUCIAL TO ACADEMIC SUCCESS TO
PROVIDE FURTHER SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES. FIFTEEN MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS INVESTMENTS
FOCUSING ON STUDENT TECHNOLOGY
AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING TURNER
FINE FOR BASIC NEEDS COMPONENT
IN THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR EMERGENCY FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND FINALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SHIFTS THE
SUSPENSION DATE FOR SUCH
SUSPENSION DATE FOR SUMMER TERM
FINANCIAL IF THEY'RE DRIVING
MAINTAINING THE PROGRAM AT SIX
MILLION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
L. L. EVERYTHING ABOUT A. L. A.
COUNTY. MENTIONED EARLIER WE AT
THAT PROPOSAL RIGHT SCHEMES
AFTER AND- ANTI ISSUE. THAT HAS
HAS THINK ANY. WE HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S LOCAL BASICALLY. AND
HEALTH. THAT. FIRST FINANCES
NOTED THERE ARE TWO ON GOING
NEEDS FOR SEE. THIS RAISES THE
QUESTION BY HOW BEST TO WEAR
THIS PROPOSAL AND MINOR JACK.
THIS MORNING DISCUSSED THAT
WITH YOUR TO THE HEALTH AND
TECHNOLOGY ONE OF ALLEGE COULD
AS DE **** THOSE ADDRESS IN
FACT. ANOTHER QUESTION IS HOW
THE MIDDLE AND- RELATES TO
THEIR PROPERTY BASICALLY. ALL
ALSO INJURED IF YOU YOU BUDGET
FOR THE PAST ACT. ONE TIME WHEN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED STATE
EMERGENCY A. MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO EVALUATE THEM IN LINE
AS FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS BUT
PURPOSE. AS RELATED THAT LIKELY
THIRD ROUND OF FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDS BACK TO. EIGHT SEEMS
IMPORTANT TO THE- TO HAVE TO
MAKE FROM THE SAN AND HOW THEY
INTEND TO USE SO FEDERAL FUND.
SO THAT THE LARGEST CAN ANY
STATE FUNDS FOR THAT PURPOSE.
TOWARD ANY GAPS IN YOUR NAME.
THING WE HAVE TO TAKE CLASS. TO
OKAY THANK YOU SEE A FUTURE
OFFICE. HELLO OF STILL LOCAL.
SO AS WE THIS MAR THE ONE YEAR
AND OF THE WE DO SO DEEP
APPRECIATE FOR THE STATE AND
FEDERAL AID THAT HAS HELPED TO
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS BUT
IN PARTICULAR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. THE ONSET OF COVERED
NINETEEN AND THE ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL DISTRESS THAT FOLLOW
CREATED UNPRECEDENTED DEMAND
FOR STUDENT BASIC NEEDS SUPPORT
ON ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES. AND
JUST AS INSTRUCTION PIVOTED TO
BE PRIMARILY ONLINE OR VIRTUAL
SO TO DO OUR STUDENTS SERVICES
WHETHER FROM EMISSIONS TO
FINANCIAL AID REVISING TWO CREW
SERVICES AND FROM STUDENT
ACTIVITIES TO STUDENTS SUPPORT.
GIVEN THE RACIALLY ETHNICALLY
AND FINANCIALLY DIVERSE
STUDENTS WE SERVE WE KNEW THAT
SUSTAINING CONNECTION AND
COMMUNITY WERE OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE TO ROUTE THIS TIME.
DURING THE PANDEMIC CHANCELLOR
EMERITUS WHITE AND NOW
CHANCELLOR CASTRO HAVE KEPT THE
UNIVERSITY SITES ON TO NORTH
STARS ONE SAFEGUARDING THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF THE
ENTIRE CSU COMMUNITY. AND TO
ENSURING THAT AS MANY STUDENTS
AS POSSIBLE STAY ON TRACK TO
EARNING THE PROVEN LIFELONG
BENEFITS OF A CSU DEGREE. TODAY
I'M PLEASED TO SHARE HIGHLIGHTS
OF HOUSE USE YOUR MINISTRY-
FACULTY STAFF COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND OUR STUDENTS
MARSHALED RESOURCES TO HELP
SAFEGUARD THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR COMMUNITIES STATE
WIDE. STUDENT BASIC NEEDS IN
THE CSU FALLS ACROSS THE BROAD
SPECTRUM FROM FOOD INSECURITY
AND HUNGER. HOUSING INSECURITY
AND HOMELESSNESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES AND FINANCIAL
DISTRESS. IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC THE CSU HAS NOW ADDED
DIGITAL LEARNING NEEDS TO THAT
DEFINITION IN RECOGNITION OF
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED. WITHIN THESE AREAS
CAN BE FOUND IN EVEN MORE
DIVERSE CONTINUUM OF NEEDS SO
FOR EXAMPLE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES CAN RANGE FROM HOME
SICKNESS AND TEST TAKING
ANXIETY. TO SEVERE MENTAL
HEALTH ILLNESS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN RESPONSE CAN RANGE
FROM PREVENTATIVE AND SELF CARE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH TO
COUNSELING FOR TRAUMA AND
DEPRESSION. OR PSYCHIATRIC
MANAGEMENT OF THE DSM FIVE
DIAGNOSIS THE MOST OF YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH AND ILLNESS IT'S-
PRIOR TO THE ONSET OF THE
ANDEMIC THE CSU HAD IN PLACE A
COMPREHENSIVE BASIC NEEDS
INITIATIVE WHICH TAKES A
HOLISTIC APPROACH. TO STUDENTS
WELL BEING BOTH INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM. AT ANY
OF OUR TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
STUDENTS WOULD FIND A FOOD
PANTRY A FOOD DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM EMERGENCY CAMPUS
HOUSING OR VOUCHERS FOR OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING. CALFRESH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE ACCESS
TO EMERGENCY GRANT FUNDS AND
DEDICATED STAFF TO CONNECT
STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITY RESOURCES. WHEN
SOCIAL DISTANCING BECAME A
DAILY FACT OF LIFE THE CAMPUS
IS RELIED ON CREATIVE
INNOVATIVE THINKING TO MEET
STUDENT NEEDS ARE JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES. FOR FOOD INSECURITY
DURING THE PANDEMIC CAMPUSES
CONTINUE TO MEET STUDENTS NEEDS
BY PROVIDING ACCESS TO PHYSICAL
FOOD PANTRIES OFFERING CURBSIDE
FOOD PICK UP OFFERING GROCERY
STORE GIFT CARDS AND IN SOME
CASES EVEN DELIVERING FOOD
BOXES TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
UNABLE TO TRAVEL TO CAMPUS. TO
SUPPORT CSU STUDENTS WHO ARE
LIVING AWAY FROM THEIR HOME
CAMPUS WE ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
COULD SEEK SUPPORT FROM THE CSU
CAMPUS THAT WAS LOCATED CLOSEST
TO THEM WHILE THEY STUDIED AND
LEARNED FROM HOME. AS OF THE
END OF LAST MONTH ONE THIRD OF
CAMPUSES HAVE SUPPORTED
STUDENTS FROM ANOTHER CSU
CAMPUS AND ALL CAMPUSES
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CALFRESH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE CSU
HOSTS TO CALFRESH OUTREACH WEEK
THE LAST WEEK OF FEBRUARY TO
ENCOURAGE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS TO APPLY FOR
THE PROGRAM. IN TERMS OF
HOUSING AND SECURITY THIS IS
ALWAYS BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE DEPENDENT ON THE VEIL
ABILITY OF SPACE AND OUR NEED
TO ADHERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
GUIDELINES. THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT A STUDENT TO LIVE
ON CAMPUS EMERGENCY HOUSING
VARIES FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS
FROM TEN DAYS TO THREE MONTHS.
MORE THAN HALF OF THE CAMPUSES
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE OFF
CAMPUS EMERGENCY HOUSING
THEREBY INCREASING THE CAPACITY
TO SERVE MORE STUDENTS. OF THE
SEVEN CAMPUSES ARE CURRENTLY
PILOTING COLLEGE FOCUSED RAPID
RE HOUSING THIS IS WITH THE
SUPPORT OF LEGISLATIVE FUNDING.
THESE CAMPUSES ARE WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNITY AGENCY WITH A
HISTORY OF PROVIDING WRAPAROUND
SUPPORT TO HOMELESS AND HOUSING
INSECURE STUDENTS. ALL CAMPUSES
ALSO PROVIDE EMERGENCY GRANTS
TO STUDENTS AND THESE FUNDS CAN
BE USED TO HELP PAY FOR RENT
AND OTHER HOUSING RELATED
EXPENSES. WITH REGARD TO MENTAL
HEALTH WHEN THE PANDEMIC BEGAN
CAMPUSES QUICKLY TRANSITIONED
TO OFFERING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES VIA HIP A COMPLIANT
VIDEO CALLS. THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT CAMPUSES HAVE
CONTINUED TO PROVIDE THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC INCLUDE ONE ON
ONE THERAPY SUPPORT GROUPS
WORKSHOPS ON SELF CARE
REFERRALS TO COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AND CASE MANAGEMENT
TO ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
HOLISTIC NEEDS ARE MET.
CLINICAL STAFF ARE ALSO
PROVIDED ADVANCED TRAINING AND
WORKING WITH STUDENTS OF COLOR
INTENDING TO RACIAL TRAUMA.
SOCIAL MEDIA AND ONLINE
RESOURCES HAVE ALSO BEEN
LEVERAGE TO PROMOTE PUBLIC
HEALTH AWARENESS ONE INNOVATIVE
EXAMPLE HAS BEEN THE LAUNCH OF
AN ONLINE STUDENT WELL BEING
PLATFORM ACROSS MORE THAN A
DOZEN CSU CAMPUSES. CALLED YOU
AT COLLEGE THIS TELEHEALTH
SOLUTION FOCUS ON STUDENTS
HOLISTIC WELLBEING ACROSS THREE
DOMAINS ACADEMIC SUCCESS CAREER
PREPAREDNESS SOCIAL COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS AND PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH. THIS RESOURCE
EXTENDS THE REACH OF CSU BEYOND
CAMPUS SPACE RESOURCES AND EVEN
FEATURES A UNIQUE WELLNESS PEER
EDUCATOR COMPONENTS TO BUILD A
GREATER SENSE F BELONGING
AMONG STUDENTS AND THEIR PEERS.
LASTLY IN TERMS OF BRIDGING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THE TRANSITION
LAST SPRING TO VIRTUAL LEARNING
MEANT THAT CAMPUSES WOULD NEED
TO MEET INCREASED DEMAND FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. BRIDGING
THIS DIGITAL EQUITY DIVIDE
RESULTED IN CAMPUSES
DISTRIBUTING AND THIS IS JUST
WHAT WE COULD TRACK SO WE
BELIEVE THE TOTAL IS ACTUALLY
MORE MORE THAN TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND LAPTOPS AND TABLETS
AND TEN THOUSAND MOBILE WIFI
AND WIFI HOT SPOTS. THE
INVESTMENT IN YOU QUIT IT ALONE
TOTALED MORE THAN EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES MANY
CAMPUSES CONVERTED THEIR
PARKING LOTS INTO SAFE SPACES
STUDENTS GET ACCESS WIFI FOR
FREE. IN ADDITION TO THE
SERVICES AGAIN CAMPUS EMERGENCY
GRANT AID COULD BE APPLIED FOR
AND RECEIVED BY STUDENTS TO
HELP COVER SOME OF THESE COSTS
OF BIRD MEANING- LEARNING AN
ACTIVE ENGAGE STUDENTS SOME
CLEANING TO HELP COVER SOME OF
THEIR COSTS OF HIGH SPEED
INTERNET. I DO JUST WANT TO
DRESS UP THE ROLE OF EMERGENCY
GRANT AID. LAST SUMMER WELL
SPRING AND SUMMER AND THEN A
BIT INTO THE FALL TWENTY TWENTY
TERM. THIS CSU IMPLEMENTED
SUCCESSFULLY THE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WERE AWARDED AS PART OF
THE KERRS ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY.
THIS RESULTED ARE BEING ABLE TO
ASSIST OVER THREE HUNDRED
ELEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AVERAGE AWARDS WERE
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS.
THIS AID WAS AUGMENTED BY OTHER
SOURCES OF OUR INSTITUTIONAL
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS WHO COULD
NOT QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL STUDENT
AID STORM RESPONSE TO ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT RYAN
ADDRESSED EARLIER. THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO BE AWARE OF IS THAT
THE FEDERAL FINANCIAL. AND
GRANT AID- STILL LEAVES OUT
SOME STUDENTS IN TERMS OF
ELIGIBILITY. AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF PROVIDING BASIC NEEDS
SUPPORT TO OUR STUDENTS.
PROBABLY IN THE AREAS OF FOOD
ASSISTANCE EMERGENCY HOUSING
AND MORE RECENTLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND RESOURCES TO CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. WHILE WE
BEGIN TO LOOK TOWARDS A FUTURE
WHERE WE CAN ONCE AGAIN RETURN
TO OUR CAMPUSES AND RECOVER
WITH EQUITY WE DO SO KNOWING
THAT THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A-
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT. ON OUR
COLLECTIVE MENTAL HEALTH IT
WILL BE OUR STUDENTS HOLISTIC
WELL BEING THAT MAY BECOME THE
NEXT FRONTLINE. EDUCATION FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU. SPEAKING OF A
FRONTLINE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
NOT NECESSARILY FRONT LINE BUT
I THINK I TOLD THE CSU THAT
THIS PAST MONTH THE PBS
NEWSHOUR DONE INCREDIBLE SERIES
ON THE IMPACT OF. COLLEGE
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH AND THEY
HIGHLIGHTED SOME STUDENTS AT
CSU NORTHRIDGE. AND YOU KNOW
WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN THAT COLLEGE
IS A STRESSFUL LOT OF THINGS IT
AND CERTAINLY COST SENSE
BECAUSE STUDENTS HAVE
EXPERIENCED DEPRESSION BUT THIS
PANDEMIC IS REALLY. EXASPERATED
ENDS RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THREE
IN FOUR COLLEGE STUDENTS. HAVE
SHOWN- THE POOR MENTAL HEALTH-
TITUS PANDEMIC SO IT IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN ISSUE WE NEED TO
STEP IT UP EVEN MORE- THIS IS A
PRIORITY THAT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE IN IN IN THE BUDGET.
AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO
EXPAND RESOURCES FROM PROP
SIXTY THREE. THE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT IN THE
MILLIONAIRE'S TAXES REVENUES
ARE INCREASING CALIFORNIA'S THE
DEDICATING MORE THAT TO. CALL
STUDENTS I THINK IS KEEN NOT TO
SEE ISSUE BUT COMMITTEE CALLS
AND YOU SEE. ONE THING HERE I
THINK I'D MENTIONED THAT. WHICH
I TALKED ABOUT THIS DURING THE
UC COMMENT SECTION. IS- YOU
KNOW THAT'S KIND OF ODD LINKING
MENTAL HEALTH TECHNOLOGY
THEY'RE BOTH- COMPORT NEEDS
WHETHER VERY SEPARATE- AND
TECHNOLOGY AS YOU MENTION
LAPTOP PURCHASE AND SO FORTH
THOSE ARE. A LOT OF TIMES ONE
TIME IN MENTAL HEALTH- HIRING
PROFESSIONALS TO STAFF TO
STAFF- APPOINTMENTS AND SO
FORTH WITH STUDENTS YOU KNOW WE
NEED PERSONNEL STAFF FOR THAT
SO YOU POTENTIALLY WE SHOULD
BREAK THOSE TWO UP AND YOU KNOW
I THINK WE'LL BE GOOD IDEAS
LOOKING AT A ONE TIME MONEY TO
DO. A ONE TIME ALLOCATION FACT
FOR TECHNOLOGY MAYBE WE CAN BE
AGGRESSIVE IN THE AMOUNTS AND
SPENT OVER THREE BUDGET YEARS
AS WELL- BUT HAVING AN ON.
DEDICATING MORE ON GOING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH I THINK- IS A
PRIORITY. AS FAR AS THE- THE
BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVE. IN
ONGOING SUPPORT SO THIS WILL GO
OUT TO CAMPUS IS ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS BASED UPON
THEIR POPULATION AND THEN THEY
WILL FOCUS ON WHAT THEIR WHAT
THEIR PRIORITIES ARE WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE IF IT'S FOOD OR RAPID
RE HOUSING OR SO FORTH IS THAT
HOW THAT WORKS. SO WE HAVE AS
OF YET- NOT QUITE DETERMINED
THE ACTUAL DISTRIBUTION
METHODOLOGY BUT WE ANTICIPATE
IT WILL MIRROR OUR PAST
APPROACH. SO WE ADOPTED- A SORT
OF MINI GRANT PROCESS AN
INTERNAL TO THE CSU I REQUEST
FOR PROPOSALS WE DEVELOPED IN
HIGHLIGHTED IN CONSULTATION
WITH OUR STUDENTS AND OUR AND
OUR ON CAMPUS PERSONNEL WHAT WE
THOUGHT WOULD BE SOME OF THE
PRIORITIES TO ADDRESS AND THEN
CAMPUS IS ACCORDINGLY SUBMITTED
PROPOSALS. FOR WHAT THEY'RE
INTENDED INTERVENTIONS AND
STRATEGIES WOULD BE HOW THEY
WOULD EVALUATE OUTCOMES AND HOW
THEY WOULD BE EXPENDING THE
FUNDS AND SO THOSE WERE
REVIEWED I THINK WE ERRED ON
THE SIDE OF BEING INCLUSIVE.
AND GENEROUS RIGHT IN TERMS OF
WANTING TO GIVE THE MONEY OUT
TWO CAMPUSES I I'VE DISSIPATE
THAT WE WILL. PURSUE A SIMILAR
APPROACH TO SHARING THE DOLLARS
TO THE CAMPUSES OKAY THANK YOU-
WELL THIS ISSUE OPEN A FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON ISSUE NUMBER
NUMBER SEVEN AS YOU NUMBER
EIGHT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
CAPITAL OUTLAY. GENERALLY WHERE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES A
ONE TIME DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING. TO ENABLE THE CSU TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS AS YOU MAY
ALREADY BE AWARE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS AT THE CSU
ARE SIGNIFICANT AND THESE
RESOURCES WILL HELP PROLONG THE
LIFESPAN OF THE SYSTEMS CAMPUS
BUILDINGS AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE AND ALSO INTRODUCE
MY COLLEAGUES READY CATS RUB
REGARDING CAPITAL OUTLAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALAIA. HELLO THIS
IS AND IT'S NOT. I WILL YES WE
CAN GO ON TO L. A. L. THANK YOU.
ALL THAT. IS THE KING OF THE L.
A. M. AS A FAITHFUL TIMES HE'D
LEAVE THAT DISTRICT MAINTENANCE
IS A PRETTY USEFUL ON AND I
WANT REGARDING THAT LITTLE
STREET THIS YEAR IS TO MODIFY
THE BUDGET LIKELY SAID THAT THE-
IS AS TEN DIFFERENT PROJECTS
BEFORE RATHER THAN AFTER THE
FUNDS ARE DISPENSED. MANY
REGARDING CAPITAL THANK BUT
CHEN ECONOMIC INDICATOR THAT. I
KNOW COVERAGE ON YOUR- APPLE
OUT PROPOSALS IN CHEN LISTED ON
PAGE THIRTY AND. THIRTY IN
GENERAL HE AT SHOULD HAVE MADE
CONCERNS THAT THE COP ATHLETE.
THAT WE CAN HAVE ONE REGARDING
THE- SURE AND. AND THIS
PROPOSAL AUTHORIZES YES YOU
SPEND I FINING UP TO HUNDRED.
IN PROJECTS THROUGH UNIVERSITY
FONG. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE MASTER
AND- PROJECTS TO SEE A WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC LIST OF THE
PROJECT THEY WOULD FIND WHAT
BACHELOR MILLION AND-
RECOMMENDS LET. ACROSS APPLE'S
OF CONTACTS IN ADVANCE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS MORNING WE DID ALSO
RECENTLY SUPPOSED PROVIDER.
REALLY TO. CAPITAL OUTLAY
REVIEW ESPECIALLY RELATING TO
TRANSPARENCY IN THAT ABOUT
SCIENCE TODAY SPENT ABOUT SEVEN
TO THE STUFF AND BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE WANTED UNTIL HE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU SEE IF YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS FIVE SEVEN
ONE THE SYSTEM BY CHANCE FOR
CAP PLANNING CONSTRUCTION THE
C. S. OFF OF THE CHANCE. WE ARE
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT IN
TWENTY TO EXPAND THIS ISSUES
THAT'S ALREADY TO FINANCE AND
FUND CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS AND
RENEW OUR PAPER TO RENEW OUR
BUILDINGS AND UTILITY SYSTEMS
ALSO PREACHED TO SHAPE THE
SUPPORT OF THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE ON OUR PROPOSED
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROGRAM. TO FUND CHECK A
FEW CALL REPLACEMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
PROPOSED FOR CSU FINANCING
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET TO THE
LEGISLATURE LIST OF THE
PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND PROJECTS AS THE L.
A. O. IS MENTIONED A ONCE IT'S
MORE CLOSELY DETERMINED ON THE
FUNDING FOR IT SUITS YOU
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. WHAT WITH
THE AUTHORITY GRANTED TO THIS
ISSUE THIS ISSUE IS PRIORITIZE
REPLACEMENT AND IMPROVEMENTS TO
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SEISMIC
STRENGTHENING ADDRESSING OUR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
WITH LIMITED EW FACILITIES TO
REPLACE OBSOLETE SCIENCE
BUILDINGS AND SERVE JUST ONE
MOMENT THAT ARE RELATIVELY
NEWER CAMPUS SITES SUCH AS
CHANNEL ISLANDS MONTEREY BAY.
IN OUR MULTI YOUR PLAN CAMPUSES
IDENTIFIED DISABILITIES NEEDS
OF OVER SIXTEEN BILLION AND THE
PROS PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE CAMPUS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PRIORITIES AND THE
BACKLOG. THE CSU HAS IDENTIFIED
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
FOR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THAT COULD BE ADDED
TO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET TO TOTAL OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION THIS
INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED PROJECTS THAT COULD
IMMEDIATELY PROCEED TO DESIGN.
AND OUR CONSTRUCTION TO HELP
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY THE
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE MILLION WILL HELP
THE CSU INSURED OUR CAMPUSES
CONTINUE TO OPERATE DURING
EXPECTED AND UNEXPECTED POWER
SHUTDOWNS AND YOUR AGING
FACILITIES TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS AND CAMPUS COMMUNITY.
MANY OF THE VENTILATION
LIGHTING REPLACEMENTS WILL
REDUCE. ENERGY CONSUMPTION AND
MAKE FOR THE- ON STATE SINCE
YOU SEE WHAT TRUSTEES CARBON.
GOALS WE HAD FOR FLEXIBLE IN
THE USE OF THE FUN. TO ADDRESS
NOT ONLY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BUT ALSO INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ENERGY IMPROVEMENTS. THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
ENABLE US TO INSTALL FIRE
SPRINKLERS IN BUILDINGS THAT DO
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE FIRE
SPRINKLERS WELL WE REPLACE
OBSOLETE FIRE ALARM PANELS FOR
EXAMPLE. IT'S ARE NEEDED AT
CAMPUSES SUCH AS CHICO CINEMA
AND SAN BERNARDINO. THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE CSU TO INTEGRATE
SOLAR POWER POWER AND BATTERY
STORAGE INTO OUR ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE EVENT
THAT FIRE WARNINGS AND HIGH
SPEED WINDS. BONTA SHUT DOWN OF
OUR ELECTRICAL UTILITY SERVICE
TO THE CAMPUS SO WE PUSH IT UP
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE USE OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS TO
ADDRESS SUCH NEEDS. IT WOULD
ADOPT THE CAMPUS TO CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SECURE
AVAILABLE UTILITYINCENTIVE
FUNDS. WITH REGARD TO
TRANSPARENCY THE CSU INCLUDES
THAT OUR ANNUAL CAPITAL OUTLAY
PLAN A FIVE YEAR HISTORY OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE FUNDED BY THE
STATE. SO EVEN THOUGH WE MAY
PROVIDE TO US FORWARD LOOKING
LIST OF HOW WE WOULD USE THE
FUNDS WE ALSO REPORTED.
ANNUALLY- THROUGH OUR WEBSITE.
THE IT IT INCLUDES ALL FUND
SOURCE. IN ADDITION TO THE
REPORTING THE SYSTEM OFFICE
HELPS CAMPUSES BY SETTING UP
MASTER CONTRACTSAND AGREEMENTS
TO STREAMLINED CAPS
CONTRACTING. IN ORDER TO GET
PROJECTS GOING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF ONE TIME FUNDS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BY FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THE NUMBER
OF JOBS. ARCHITECTS AND PROJECT
MANAGERS IS ESTIMATED TO
INCREASE OVER EIGHTY SEVEN
HUNDRED JOBS. BASED ON THE
CONTRACTS TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROJECTS SO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
AS AS I MENTIONED DURING THE UC
SEGMENT THIS IS THAT HIGH
PRIORITY FOR. OUR OUR STATE
CERTAINLY PUTS PEOPLE TO WORK
TO WITH THE GOOD CONSTRUCTION
JOBS AND- AND THAT'S A GOOD USE
A ONE TIME MONEY SO THE CSU
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
ISN'T AS LARGE AS THE UC EVEN.
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE TWICE AS
MANY CAMPUSES SO THAT RAISES A-
GREAT NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
GRANTED. SOME OF THE UC CAMPUS
ARE MUCH OLDER. THIS ISSUE
BUILDING ARE ARE- ARE
RELATIVELY NEWER ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- BUT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WILL CERTAINLY TAKE
A LOOK AT POTENTIALLY PUTTING
MORE MONEY IN THERE DEPENDING
ON HOW MUCH WE HAVE. FROM THAT
ONE TIME REVENUE FOR THE NAY
REVISE WALLS FEDERAL MONEY- I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS- ABOUT
THIS. SINGLE QUESTIONS. I WOULD
I WOULD I WOULD KNOW THAT-
SOMEONE MEMBER TEAM JOIN THIS
YEAR AND IF YOU DON'T WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
NUMBER EIGHT- AND- RAIN STORM
ARE YOU THERE. YES I AM YES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM WE WILL
WANT TO GO BACK TO- ENROLLMENT
IN THE REDIRECTION POLICY SO-
SOMEONE EVER TAKE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SO- I'M JUST GOING
THROUGH OUR PACKET IN THE LOOK
AT THE REDIRECTION I. KNEW THAT
THE MINGUS HILLS WAS RECEIVING
A NUMBER OF READ DIRECTIONS I
DIDN'T REALIZE THE SAN
FRANCISCO STATE I GOT UP THERE
SO. WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY MY
DISTRICTS ARE REALLY HAPPY TO
SEE. THAT- ALL. OF TO BOTH
THOSE CAMPUSES ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE IN AND ROLLING- RE
DIRECTED STUDENTS I JUST WANT
TO GET A SENSE ON HOW THAT. HOW
THAT POLICIES GOING I SEE THAT
THERE WAS QUITE A DROP IN TERMS
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE OFFERED RE
DIRECTION BUT- THE ENVIRONMENT
WAS- FAIRLY STEADY BETWEEN.
NINETEEN AND TWENTY BUCKS
CURIOUS HOW THAT HOW THAT'S
GOING. YES SIR THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION. SO MAYBE IN
TERMS OF IDENTIFYING. NOT ALL
CAMPUSES RECEIVED REDIRECTED
RIGHTS OUR FOCUS REALLY WAS ON
CSU CAMPUSES THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY IMPACTED THE IDEA
BEING THAT THERE IS AVAILABLE
CAPACITY SO OKAY SO I WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT. IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBERS I CAN SEE WHY THERE IS
A QUESTION ABOUT THAT. SO FROM
FALL TWENTY NINETEEN TO FALL
TWENTY TWENTY OCT IT MORE
STUDENTS WERE ALSO BEING
ADMITTED RIGHT TO THE ORIGINAL
CSU THAT THEY APPLY TO. SO THEN
THAT RESULTED IN A SMALLER POOL
OF THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE SEARS
YOU ELIGIBLE AND THEREFORE.
AVAILABLE FOR REDIRECTION SO
THAT THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
LIGHT THAT THE NUMBERS APPEAR
TO NOT A LINE. IT'S A GREAT
DEAL DO YOU FEEL LIKE- YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO GET ABOUT SAY SEVEN
TO EIGHT HUNDRED I MEAN
APPROXIMATELY. STUDENTS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO RURAL IN.
IN- IT IS THROUGH THE ROOF
THROUGH BETWEEN DIRECTION. IS
THAT WE WOULD ANTICIPATE FOR
THIS COMING YEAR. I WILL BE
HONEST AND SAY THAT I AM
RELUCTANT TO MAKE A PREDICTION
BECAUSE THERE ARE JUST SO MANY
THINGS IN PLAY RIGHT NOW THAT
ARE UNUSUAL FOR US AS
UNIVERSITY SO I WOULD I WOULD
OBSERVE THAT WE INSTITUTED THIS
SHORTLY BEFORE WE WERE
PICKETING RIGHTS OF WE REALLY
ONLY HAVE THE FALL TWENTY
NINETEEN- AND THEN FALL TWENTY
TWENTY WAS IN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE IN. SO
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO UNPACK
WHAT WERE THE IMPACTS HOW BIG
WERE THOSE IMPACTS WHAT WAS
THERE A FACT BUT WE WERE
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED RIGHT THAT
WE SERVED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY IN THIS CASE CLOSE TO
NINE HUNDRED STUDENTS AND NOT
FIRST ROUND- AND THEN AGAIN
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SO WE
HOPE THAT. IT'LL STAY THERE BUT
IDEALLY WE'RE HOPING THAT IT
COULD BE MORE OVERTIME SO WE'RE
TRYING TO STUDY WHAT WOULD HELP
FACILITATE STUDENTS ACCEPTING
OUR OFFER OF ADMISSION THROUGH
REDIRECTION. AND WE AND WE WERE
VERY PLEASANTLY I'M ALL I'M
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED JUST
LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS AS WELL
BECAUSE THIS IS A POLICY THAT
WE WORKED OUT WITH- YOU KNOW
CHANCE RIGHT AT THAT TIME. ALL
RIGHT DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
WHY- I MEAN THERE ARE NOT
ANOTHER NUMBER CAMPUSES ARE
UNDER AND ROLL BUT DO YOU KNOW
WHY SAN FRANCISCO STATE IN THE
MINGUS HILLS HAVE KIND OF SEEN
THE. MOST INTEREST IN TERMS OF
REDIRECTION. SO I THINK IT'S A-
TO. THAT- THE REDIRECTION DATA
WAS IN BALANCE SO YOU HAD A
SMALL NUMBER OF CSU CAMPUSES
THAT WERE THE PRIMARY CENTERS.
OF STUDENTS FOR REDIRECTION
RIGHT AND THEN THERE ON
IMPACTED CAMPUSES WHO WERE
RECEIVERS. AND WE LEARNED AN
IMPORTANT LESSON IN THIS AND I
THINK I SHARED EARLIER THIS
MORNING. IS THAT IN THE END
STUDENTS ARE STILL APPLYING TO
A PARTICULAR CAMPUS FOR ITS
BRAND FOR ITS DISTINCTIVENESS
FOR ITS NICHE. FOR THE
PARTICULAR CLIMATE OR
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR AND OFTENTIMES LOCATION IS
GOING TO BE A KEY. AND I WILL
JUST FRIENDLY OBSERVE THAT THE
LARGER SENDING CAMPUSES ARE IN
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION
RIGHT STEP. BACK FOR SOME
STUDENTS CONSIDERING AN OFFER
TO ATTEND A SCHOOL THAT IS IN
ANOTHER REGION WAS A BIT
PROHIBITIVE. SO I DO THINK WE
ATTRIBUTE THAT BOTH SAN
FRANCISCO AND DOMINGUEZ HILLS
HAD HIGHER NUMBERS. IN PART
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
METROPOLITANAREAS SO ACCESS
WAS. A FACTOR. AND THEN THOSE
ARE THE TWO CAMPUSES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE TO MAKE IT TELLS IS
THE ONLY ONE RIGHT NOW WHO'S
NOT IMPACTED IN THE SO CAL
REGION. GOT IT SO THAT MAKES
SENSE TO BASICALLY YEAH YOU
KNOW IF YOU APPLY TO FULLER
TENDED YOU PLAN TO LONG BEACH
STATE AND COULDN'T GET INTO
THOSE PLACES BUT- EXACTLY YOU
KNOW YOU CAN TAKE A DIFFERENT
FREEWAY GO TO DOMINGUEZ HILLS.
SO THAT'S RIGHT NOT THAT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE NO WRITTEN. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE I THINK THE-
THE SYSTEM JUST. TO WORK WITH
US AND WE WANT. THE POLICY THEN-
WE THOUGHT WE WERE JUST VERY
PLEASED ABOUT THE SMOOTH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE POLICY SO
I JUST WANTED TO JUST. IN
PARTICULAR JUST CAN THANK
FORMER CHANCELLOR WHITE AND
OBVIOUSLY A CHANCE ACOSTA BUT
ALL BUT ALL THE ALL THE TEAM
DOWN IN LONG BEACH FOR REALLY
MAKING THAT HAPPEN. I'M IN
TERMS OF ENROLLMENT I KNOW THAT
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT TROUBLING
TO SEE. A DIP IN APPLICATIONS
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE ENROLLMENT AT
LEAST SLIGHTLY INCREASED IN
TWENTY TWENTY DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THAT A WOMAN WILL KEEP KEEP
GOING UP ARE YOU CONCERNED
BECAUSE OF THE- THE DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS ATTACK COULD
RESULT IN LOWER ENROLLMENT.
OKAY SO I CAN'T THIS A PLACE
WHERE YOU KNOW THE ARE AND
SCIENCE OF ENROLLMENT
PROJECTIONS IS ALWAYS BASED ON
PAST PATTERNS OF STUDENT
BEHAVIOR. AND GIVEN THAT ALL OF
THOSE PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN
DISRUPTED. OUR ABILITY OUR
EIGHT BALL IS BROKEN. TO LOOK
AT IT SO WE WERE CERTAINLY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT OUR ROMANCE
UNLIKE OTHER SIMILAR
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE U. S.
DID NOT TAKE A DIP THIS PAST
FALL. AND I THINK AN EARLIER
REPORTED AND RIGHT NOW AS OF
EARLY MARCH OUR APPLICATIONS
FOR FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE
ONLY 3% BELOW THE PRIOR YEAR.
SO I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT
APPLICATIONS ARE NOT ENROLLMENT
APPLICATION IS JUST WHAT WE
CALL THE BEGINNING OF THE TOTAL
ENROLLMENT FINAL IT'S THE START
OF A STUDENT'S JOURNEY TO
POSSIBLY ENROLL WITH THE CSU SO
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE CAN ADMIT ALL OF
OUR ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. AND
HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE THEM TO
ENROLL SO THAT WE CAN EMPHASIZE
HOW MORE THAN EVER NOW IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET A HIGHER
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL SO THAT
YOU CAN BUY FOR YOURSELVES
AGAINST THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
THIS FINANCIAL TURMOIL. SO
WE'LL SEE WE CERTAINLY HOPE WE
CAN SUSTAIN AND MAINTAIN AND
IMPROVE WHAT WE HOPE WE HOPE SO
AS WELL. RIGHT AND THEN GOING
TO THE MY LAST POINT WHICH I
THINK IS OBVIOUSLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WHICH IS.
REALLY AROUND GRADUATION RATES-
YOU I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT THERE
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S BEEN
DEFINITELY SOME PROGRESS ON THE
SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE- SOME
NOT AS MUCH PROGRESS ON THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE I
KNOW THAT THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
IS ASKING FOR. I BELIEVE- SIXTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR ON
GOING. TO SUPPORT THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE CAN YOU
JUST GIVE ME GIVE US A SENSE OF
HOW THE GRADUATION ISSUES GOING
AND SORT OF WHAT WE COULD KIND
OF HOPE. FOR THE NEXT YEAR OR
SO. WHAT BUT THIS IS FOR STORE
WITH ISSUE IN THEN I'LL ASK ME
TO EVANS TO TALK ABOUT THE
PERSON. AND MOST OF THINGS
GREATNESS. SO- SOME TEAM- WE-
FOR AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY SIX
MILLION IS ON TOP OF THE ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED. IN JANUARY SO WHAT
THAT WILL DO IS THAT SIXTY SIX
MILLION ABOVE THAT AMOUNT.
WOULD THEN ALLOW US TO FULLY
FUND OUR GRADUATION ACTIONS ARE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS
CLEAR IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS
AND THEN I'LL I'LL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER EVANS. THANK
YOU MISTER STORM AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG I'VE NAY
CAN HAPPENS- FROM ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION- THE
FOCUS ON THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE IS CERTAINLY BEEN.
THE HALLMARK EFFORT OF THE CSU-
CERTAINLY UNDER CHANCELLOR
EMERITUS WHITE AND THEN
CHANCELLOR CASTRO HAS IN MANY
WAYS DOUBLE DOWN ON THAT AND
FOCUSED. ON THE REMAINING
EQUITY GAPS THAT EXIST ON TO
YOUR POINT WE HAVE MADE. STRONG
STEADY PROGRESS AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE TRAJECTORIES ALTHOUGH WE
ALWAYS KNOW THERE CAN BE
FLUCTUATION FROM YEAR TO YEAR
ALL OF OUR OVERALL PROJECTIONS
DEMONSTRATE THAT WE ARE ON
TRACK TO MEET BOTH THE- THE-
FIRST YEAR STUDENT GOALS AND
THE TRANSFER STUDENT GOALS- IN
FACT. FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS
WERE ALREADY WITHIN JUST ONE
PERCENTAGE POINT OF OUR- SECURE
PURSUED ME FOR YOUR METRIC
ALREADY- BUT HIS CHANCER
CASTRO'S EXPRESSED OUR ABSOLUTE
FOCUS IN THE BALANCE OF TIME
LEFT IN THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. IS ON ELIMINATING
EQUITY GAPS AND I KNOW THAT
WHEN HE WAS BEFORE THIS GROUP
HE SHARED THE BENEFIT OF.
LEARNING AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
A NUMBER OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
ALREADY ELIMINATED THOSE EQUITY
GAPS AND HE SHARED EVEN WITHIN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I
MENTIONED THIS THIS MORNING.
WITH THREE CAMPUSES THERE WERE
SIMILAR STUDENT POPULATIONS WE
HAVE SOME CAMPUSES FOR EXAMPLE
STANISLAUS THAT IS. EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATED THE EQUITY GAP FOR
PELL RECIPIENTS AND SO ENSURING
THAT WE ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE. IN
SIMILAR REGIONS ARE BENEFITING
UNDERSTANDING SO- WE'VE- JUST
DELIVERED SOME NEW DATA AND
REPORTS TO ALL TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES WITH SOME STRATEGIES
AROUND THAT. THAT ARE SQUARELY
FOCUSED ON THE EQUITAS
ELIMINATING EQUITY GAPS AND
IT'S REALLY NOT BETWEEN NOW AND
THE REMAINING FIVE YEARS AND
PUTTING. OF FOR THE PLAN AND
LEARNING FROM EACH OTHER ABOUT
HOW THEY GOT SOME. OF OUR
SISTER CAMPUSES I'VE ALREADY
DONE THAT. GREAT MAN OF FAITH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO YOU. YOU
ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO. HIT
YOUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TARGETS
BASED ON EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON. RIGHT NOW- AS I SAID
SORT OF THE TRAJECTORY IT
ALLOWS US TO DO THAT BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE I WILL SHARE TO
MISTER STORMS POINT THAT ARE
ARE PLANNING HAS BEEN
PREDICATED ON SUSTAINED
INVESTMENT AND AGAIN WE'VE BEEN
VERY APPRECIATIVE. OF THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE BUT WITH
THOSE ASSUMPTIONS YES WE ARE ON
TARGET FOR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
GOALS GREAT I MEAN THAT THE TO
JUST REITERATE IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE I KNOW
THAT- WHEN THE- CHANCELLOR
WHITE FIRST STARTED WORKING ON
IT IS. VERY VERY IMPORTANT I
THINK IT'S KEY THAT WE NOT ONLY
OFFER- STUDENTS ADMISSIONS BUT
ALL OFF OBVIOUSLY OFFER THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY GET THEIR
DEGREE SO. THAT'S WHY WE DO
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU WITH THAT
LET'S GO NOW TO ISSUE NINE
THESE ARE RELATED TO THREE- A
MISCELLANEOUS PROPOSALS FOR CSU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO
JENNIFER LOUIS WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AS I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES A HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION ONGOING
JOURNAL FINE. AND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATIONS THIS
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSALS TWO MILLION ONGOING
JOURNAL FIND TO SUPPORT THE
ADOPTION OF A COMMON NORTH OF
MENTAL LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE COMPUTING TALENT INITIATIVE
AND MINISTER TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY MONTEREY BAY
AND FINALLY TEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
FACULTY. THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR CSU AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY.
YOUR WHOLE APARTMENT FINANCES
JUST INTRODUCED HIM COMMON. HE.
WHAT RIGHT WE FOCUS ON
INCREASING DIVERSITY I PLAN YOU
THINK IT COULDN'T LINE WAY THE
STATE'S SIXTY AS WELL AS. FOR
MEETING IT IS LIKELY IMPACT
AROUND SMALL OF STUDENTS LIVING
ONE FIELD AND- LEGISLATURE HE
BACKGROUND. GRANT PROGRAMS TO
STAND ACTIVITIES BEYOND THE-
FINALLY REGARDING PROPERTY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND HE
HAD FAILURE THIS MORNING. THE
MISSION AND- WE GOT ABOUT HERE
HOW LET COULD POSSIBLY SECOND
YES YOU US AND ON THE NEED OF
THESE. THANK YOU. FURTHER PART
OF THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED
REALLY TO EXPANSION. SOME
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SEE YOU. I
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ONCE A
NATHAN FROM CSU OFF THE- AS WE
NOTED EARLIER TODAY AS THIS
ISSUE TO MAKE GOOD PROGRESS
TOWARD GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THE LEGISLATURE'S INTEREST
IN IDENTIFYING WAYS TO SUPPORT
OUR COLLECTIVE GOALS- LET ME
MET NOW BRIEFLY SPEAK ON THE
THREE OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FIRST A LEARNING
MANAGEMENT PROPOSAL- I WOULD
BEGIN BY SHARING FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS THE CSU HAS MAINTAINED
CENTRAL NEGOTIATED CONTRACTS.
FOR LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
THAT ARE LEVERAGING THE SIZE
AND SCOPE OF OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM FOR VERY FAVORABLE
PRICING- AND IS NOTED IN
TODAY'S AGENDA FOURTEEN CSU
CAMPUSES HAVE GRAVITATED TOWARD
ONE SYSTEM WITH THE REMAINING
NINE CAMPUSES ON OTHER
PLATFORMS I SEVERAL OF THOSE
REMAINING NINE HAVE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN MOVING TO A MORE
UBIQUITOUS PLATFORM IN THE
RESOURCES COULD CERTAINLY HELP
FACILITATE. BUT THEY MAY NOT BE
SUFFICIENT TO COVER ALL
ASSOCIATED COSTS WE WOULD ADD A
COUPLE CAUTIONS- THAT WE HAVE
NOTED IN OTHER CONVERSATIONS
THAT SUCH AN ACTION COULD
HINDER THE COMPETITIVE BIDDING
PROCESS FOR TECHNOLOGY AND ALSO
GIVEN RAPID CHANGES IN
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS WE WOULD
ALSO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
POTENTIALLY CODIFYING A
PARTICULAR PRODUCT OR VENDOR-
IN ANYACTION- NEXT ON THE
COMPUTING TALENT INITIATIVE-
WE'VE CONTINUOUSLY LOOK TO
IMPROVE. OUR GRADUATION RATE
FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS WHO
ENTERED AND AS I REFERENCED A
FEW MINUTES AGO OR JUST ONE
PERCENTAGE POINT AWAY FROM ONE
OF OUR TRANSFER GOALS AND THAT
WOULD BE FIVE YEARS EARLY AND
IT'S BEEN ACHIEVED THUS FAR BY
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS ON MANY CSU
CAMPUSES IN THE COMPUTING
TALENT INITIATIVE. IS JUST ONE
OF THESE- AND SO THE US WE
WOULD PREFER TO SEE INVESTMENT
IN- IN THE TRUSTEES PRIORITIES
AROUND GRADUATION INITIATIVE
AND MORE BROUGHT MORE BROAD
EFFORTS AND ADDITIONALLY THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE PROVIDE SOME ONE TIME
FUNDING TO EXPAND THE COMPUTING
TALENT INITIATIVE TO OTHER
CAMPUSES WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
ONE TIME FUNDING- DOES CREATE
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE START A
PROGRAM AND THEN POTENTIALLY HE
STARTED. ON A RESEARCH ON OTHER
KEY. IF WE TRY TO START THAT UP
SO I THINK OUR PRIORITY AGAIN
WOULD BE TO FOCUS ON. THE
TRUSTEES ADOPTED BUDGET. AND
THEN LASTLY AROUND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROMOTING INCLUSIVE
EQUITY BY TEACHING AND
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN
A PRIMARY FOCUS OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL TO THIS
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM WIDE- IN
RECENT YEARS. AND THE ONSET OF
THE. PANDEMIC REALLY AMPLIFIED
THE AWARENESS OF ECO IN. AND WE
SAW A TREE. RESPONSE BUYER FACT
IN. IN A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PARTICULARLY AROUND
THAT CONCERNS ABOUT THE USE OF
HIGH SPEED INTERNET AND DEEPER
CONCERNS ABOUT EVERY ASPECT OF
INSTRUCTION FROM COURSE CONTENT
TO LEARNING ACTIVITIES. SO THIS
RESOURCE COULD CERTAINLY
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT IN THESE ARENAS-
AND WE ALSO THINK IT WILL HELP
TRANSLATE BACK AS WE BEGIN TO
RE POPULATE OUR CAMPUSES. AND
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THESE ITEMS WE WILL HOLD OFF
AND- INTEL THE- MAY REVISE.
WITH THAT NEXT I KNOW MR MEDINA
I REALLY INTERESTED IN THIS AND
SEE ISSUES PERSPECTIVE ON THE
FINANCIAL AID REFORM ISSUE
NUMBER TEN. AND SO- IF WE COULD
HEAR FROM THE CSU. OKAY HELLO
AGAIN- STILL LOCAL HONG STILL
THE ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR
FOR STUDENT AFFAIRS AND
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT WITH THE
CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ON THE CSCS
APPROACH TO FINANCIAL AID AS
WELL AS SHARE OUR PERSPECTIVE
ON THE PROPOSED CAL GRANT
REFORM. FINANCIAL AID IS ONE OF
SIX PILLARS THAT THE CSU WAS
IDENTIFIED TO ADVANCE OUR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AN INITIATIVE
DESIGNED TO INCREASE GRADUATION
RATES AND ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS
ACROSS OUR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES. THIS IS PREMISED ON
THE PRINCIPLE THAT STUDENTS
TIMELY PATHWAY 2 DEGREES
COMPLETION RELIES ON
PREDICTABLE AND RELIABLE
FINANCIAL AID SUPPORT FROM YEAR
TO YEAR. STUDENTS ALSO NEED
FINANCIAL AID SUPPORT THAT IS
RESPONSIVE TO THEIR SHIFTING
REALITIES WHETHER SHORT OR LONG
TERM THIS IS WHY ACCESS TO
MICROGRAMS AND EMERGENCY GRANT
AID IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT ASPECT
OF FINANCIAL AID SUPPORT. AS
THE LARGEST AND ONE OF THE MOST
ETHNICALLY RACIALLY AND
FINANCIALLY DIVERSE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS IN THE NATION THE CSU
IS COMMITTED TO INCLUSIVE
EXCELLENCE THIS MEANS ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS TO REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES.
EXPERIENCE EQUITABLE HIGHER
EDUCATION ACCESS AND ATTAINMENT.
WE SERVE A NOTABLE PORTION OF
HIGH NEED LOW INCOME STUDENTS
IN THE STATE IN FACT OUR
STUDENT BODY REFLECTS SIMILAR
SOCIO ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS AS
THAT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MORE THAN
HALF OF CSU STUDENTS RECEIVE A
PELL GRANT AND 83% RECEIVE SOME
FORM OF FINANCIAL AID. THIS
MEANS THAT EVERY YEAR NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND CSU
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES RECEIVE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
WITH THEIR EDUCATIONAL COSTS
WHILE ATTENDING A CSU CMPUS.
UNLIKE MANY OTHER UNIVERSITIES
WHICH PRIORITIZE LOANS IN THE
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGING THE CSU
AWARDS GRANT AID FIRST THIS
FACILITATES UPWARD SOCIAL
MOBILITY BY REDUCING THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF BORROWING
PARTICULARLY GIVEN OUR
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION OF FIRST
GENERATION LOW INCOME AND
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS. GRANTS CAN INCLUDE A
COMBINATION OF FEDERAL STATE
AND INSTITUTIONAL AWARDS. IN
THE CASE OF THE CSU A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF STUDENT
INSTITUTIONAL AID IS PROVIDED
BY THE STATE UNIVERSITY GRANTS
PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
SUGG. THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
ESSENTIAL NEED BASED GRANTS TO
BOTH ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND DREAM APPLICANTS.
SOME WAS ESTABLISHED WITH THE
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION OF
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS NEARLY FORTY YEARS AGO.
ABSENT AN INCREASE IN STATE
SUPPORT IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE THE CSU BORDER TRUSTEES
APPROVE THE FRAMEWORK FOR NEW
STUDENTS AND FINANCIAL A POLICY
THAT ALLOCATES ONE THIRD OF NEW
REVENUE DUE TO TUITION RATE
INCREASES TO SOCK. THE CSU
COMMITMENT TO SUCK FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY IS MORE
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF OPERATING FUNDS OF
THIS NINETY MILLION SUPPORTS
CREDENTIAL AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS. THIS IS A REAL COST
WHICH IS CHARGED TO EACH CAMPUS
WHERE THE 8% IS ENROLLED IT IS
A LOT MORE TO COVER THE COST OF
SYSTEM WIDE TUITION AND MAY
COVER UP 250% OF CAMPUS BASED
MANDATORY FEES THIS LATTER IS
LEFT TO CAMPUS DISCRETION. AND
THIS IS FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN ESSENCE THE
STUDENTS TUITION AND A PORTION
OF MANDATORY FEES ARE PAID BY
THE CAMPUSES OPERATING FUND.
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY IS BASED ON
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION
WITH THE PRIORITY GIVEN TO
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WHEN THEY
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION OF
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS.
ELIGIBILITY AGAIN IS BASED ON
THE FAST OR DREAM APPLICATION.
SOCK FUNDING IS A FINITE
RESOURCE AND UNFORTUNATELY MORE
STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR SUGG
THEN THERE IS AVAILABLE FUNDING
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND SO YOU SEE
STUDENTS RECEIVE SOME SOCK AID
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY. IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I PROVIDED A GENERAL OVERVIEW
OF CC FINANCIAL AID AND I'M
HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AT THE
CONCLUSION OF MY REMARKS. I'D
NOW LIKE TO RESERVE MY
REMAINING TIME TO PROVIDE THIS
UC'S PERSPECTIVE ON THE CAL
GRANT MODERNIZATION AN EQUITY%
FRAMEWORK OR AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX SPONSORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MEDINA AND MCCARTY.
GIVEN THE DEMOGRAPHIC PROFILE
OF THE STUDENTS WE SERVE WE
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THE CSU
REMAINS FIERCELY COMMITTED TO
THE GUIDING PRINCIPLES WITH
WHICH WE BEGAN INTERSEGMENT ALL
EFFORTS TO REFORM THE CAL GRANT
AID PROGRAM AND WE APPLAUD C.
SACKED. FOR LEADING WITH THESE
PRINCIPLES THEY INCLUDE MAKING
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA CLICK HERE
TO STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
ADDRESSING THE TOTAL COSTS OF
EDUCATION TURN SURE HIGHER
EDUCATION ACCESS FOR
INCREASINGLY RACIALLY
ETHNICALLY IN FINANCIALLY
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATION. AND
PROVIDING ADEQUATE FINANCIAL
AID TO SUPPORT DEGREE
COMPLETION THE REAL ALL THE
YEARS. AS SUCH WE APPRECIATE A
NUMBER OF ELEMENTS THE CURRENT
ITERATION OF THE CAL GRANT
REFORM PROPOSAL THESE INCLUDE
THE SIMPLIFICATION OF
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
STRAIGHTFORWARD SIMPLE. THE
INCLUSION OF STUDENTS AND ALL
OUR COHORTS BEGINNING WITH THE
FIRST YEAR OF COLLEGE THIS IS
CRITICAL. AND THEN LASTLY
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS TO COMPLETE A FAST SO
OR CANNOT THIS ALLOWS US TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE ALL
AVAILABLE FORMS OF GRANT AID
FOR EACH STUDENT. WITH A
PROPOSAL THAT HAS SUCH. WIDE
RANGING IMPLICATIONS THIS
YEAR'S WOULD LIKE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL STE. THAT WE ENROLL
OUR EMPOWER ACT. AND BENEF. IT
IS OUR HOPE THAT I'M DISCUSSION
AND FURTHER COLLABORATION AND
CONSULTATION WE CAN SUPPORT
NEEDED REFORM WHILE STILL
ENSURING THAT ANY MAJOR
TRANSFORMATIONAL
TRANSFORMATIONAL INITIATIVE
SUCH AS THIS ONE IS SUSTAINABLE
FOR THE CSU WITHIN OUR VALUABLE
RESOURCES. AND THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CAN ACCURATELY
IDENTIFY THE TOTAL COST OF THIS
PROGRAM OVER THE LONG TERM. AS
SUCH WE RECOMMEND THE FOLLOWING
NEXT STEPS FOR CONSIDERATION.
WHAT. A COMPREHENSIVE MULTI
YOUR MODELING PROJECT ANALYSIS
IN ORDER TO ASCERTAIN HOW THE
CONCEPTUAL FRAMEWORK WILL
TRANSLATE IN REAL WORLD
APPLICATIONS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
NOBODY CAN COVER EVERYTHING AND
WE'D STILL LIKE TO UNDERSTAND
MORE FULLY THE CONSEQUENCES OF
SUCH FACTORS AS AN INCREASE IN
FASTER COMPLETION AS WELL AS
UPCOMING CHANGES TO PELL
ELIGIBILITY IN PALO MORE LEVELS
AMONG OTHER SCENARIOS FOR
INSTANCE YOU'RE MODELING CALL
ALSO HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
FULL IMPACT ON OUR STUDENTS
BOTH THOSE ENTERING THE PROGRAM
IN FUTURE YEARS AND THOSE BEING
GRANDFATHERED IN SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER SERVE THEM. AT A MINIMUM
FINANCIAL ACCESS TO THIS YEAR'S
FUTURE CURRENT OF MATTER THAT
ALLOW STUDENTS AND FAMILIES TO
PLAN AHEAD FOR THE COST OF
COLLEGE. INCREASE ACCESS FOR
SOME SHOULD NOT BE A CHEAPER
CONTENT POTENTIAL REDUCE ACCESS
FOR OTHERS. SECOND WE WOULD
REQUEST A HOLISTIC
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL HAS BEEN
KNOWLEDGE AS AN INITIAL STEP AN
IMPORTANT INITIAL STEP. A LONG
TERM PLAN WITH PROJECTED
MILESTONES WILL ALLOW US TO
EVALUATE IMPACT FROM A STUDENT.
INSTITUTIONAL AND STATE WIDE
PERSPECTIVE. ENSURING COLLEGE
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY HAS
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
CORNERSTONE OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA THE
OTHER CALL THE CORNERSTONES ARE
EXCELLENCE EQUITY ENTERTAINMENT
AND THE CSU WILL BE MOST IN
FAVOR OF A PLAN THAT
APPROPRIATELY BALANCES ALL OF
THESE FOUNDATIONS. WE ALL HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO BE RESPONSIBLE
STEWARDS OF THE STATE'S
RESOURCES WE BELIEVE STRONGLY
THAT A COMMITMENT TO THIS KIND
OF CHANGE MUST BE SUPPORTED BY
ADDITIONAL DATA AND EVIDENCE.
IN CLOSING WE WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO THANK THE CSX STAFF AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MEDINA MCCARTY
FOR ALL THAT THEY HAVE DONE TO
ADVANCE THIS CONVERSATION FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
FINANCIAL ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION WE ARE
EXTREMELY ENCOURAGED BY THE
THOUGHTFUL RECOMMENDATIONS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO ENGAGE ACTIVELY IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS. MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND I KNOW WE'VE HAD. ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR STAFF
AND SEES YOU IN THE STATE
COMMISSIONS REFORM PROPOSALS
BUT I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT
THAT THE CSU SYSTEM IN YOUR
ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS WOULD WOULD BENEFIT.
IF WE EXPANDED CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY IN OTHER WORDS- YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE
COMPETITIVE A WORD FOR PEOPLE
ARE COMING OUT HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEN. I'M SORRY WE HAVE
ENTITLEMENT AND THEN YOU KNOW
COUPLES THERE THEY GET THE
COMPETITIVE AND THE ODDS ARE
ONE INTENT OF GETTING AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO COME KNOCK ON YOUR
DOOR AND POTENTIALLY GET- YOU
KNOW YOUR SON GRANT TO HELP PAY
PAY THEIR SUPPORT- AND THEN WE
ALSO WANT TO FOCUS ON PAYING
MORE. THAN JUST TUITION THE NON
TUITION COSTS SO THOSE TWO
THINGS I THINK THAT WILL BE
EMBRACED BY YOUR SYSTEM. AND SO
THE RIGHT HERE IS THAT IS THAT
WE PROTECT ATTEMPTING TO
UTILIZE SOME OF YOUR
INSTITUTIONAL EIGHT SO WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY ON THE FLIP SIDE
EVERY MISSING IS IT THESE DO
YOU THINK THAT WE SHOULD JUST
LEAVE. THERE IT THE- YOUR
RETURNED EIGHT ALONE AND NOT.
YET USE THAT TO TRY TO ADDRESS
IS LIKE WE ARE WITH YOU SEE. OR
SHOULD. WE DO THINK THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE TO GO TO THE
GENERAL FUND AND FIND OTHER. TO
UP TO FIND THAT PIECE REFORM. I
CAN'T HEAR YOU. SORRY I MUSED
ASSUMES DIFFERENT FEEDBACK- SO
I DID I WANT TO FIRST START BY
REITERATING THAT WE SEE MANY
MERITS TO THIS PROPOSAL. R. FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT I CITED SO
I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR THE
SECOND PIECE IS THAT WE JUST
ARE SIMPLY NOT SURE SO FOR
EXAMPLE THERE MAY BE INCREASED
ACCESS IN THE INITIAL- SHORT
TERM YEARS BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
LOOK AT LONGER TERM WHAT WILL
HAPPEN. AND THERE'S SO MANY
MOVING PARTS RIGHT THIS IS NOT
A SIMPLE DIRECT LINEAR FORMULA
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- THERE
ARE BOTH WAYS IN WHICH WE WILL
HAVE STUDENTS ARE INCREASE
ACCESS. TO GRANT AID TO SUPPORT
TUITION AND FEES BUT THEY'RE
ALSO POTENTIALLY SOME STUDENTS
WHO AS A RESULT OF THIS NEW
FORMULA WON'T RECEIVE THE SAME
AMOUNT OR RECEIVE LESS. THE
OTHER IMPORTANT THING THAT IS
COMPLICATED I THINK FOR US
WE'RE MODELING WOULD BENEFIT IS
THIS INTERFACE WITH THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE SO WE BEGAN THIS
ENDEAVOR IN PERFORMING CAL
GRANTS. BY TRYING TO CONSIDER A
MODEL THAT THE STATE BASED AID
PROGRAM WOULD TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
ALL THE COST OF ATTENDANCE AND
WE UNDERSTAND THAT IN THE
CURRENT FINANCIAL VARMA IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO ENGAGE AND CHANGE
THAT IS THAT SIGNIFICANT IN ONE
FELL SWOOP. BUT WITH THAT SAID
THAT MEANS FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
TRULY PACKAGE WITH THE
CONSCIOUSNESS ABOUT THE
ADDITIONAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
BEYOND TO REGION AND FEES WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HOW MANY
STUDENTS. ARE WE WOULD BE
LOOKING TO HAVE TO PACKAGE AND
PROVIDE THOSE ADDITIONAL A
GRANTS WHAT WE'RE COMMITTED TO
AS WE RECOGNIZE HALF OF OUR
STUDENTS COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
STUDENTS. EIGHT PACKAGING IS
POTENTIALLY DISRUPTIVE TO THEIR
PATHWAY TO THE FOUR YEAR DEGREE
SO RIGHT NOW THE CURRENT MODEL
IS TWO TIERED AND IT'S
DEPENDENT AWARE YOU ARE
ENROLLED. AS OPPOSED TO THAT
THE STUDENT THEMSELVES IN TERMS
OF THEIR FINANCIAL CONDITION SO
THAT MEANS FOR EXAMPLE A
STUDENT RIGHT NOW ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE RECEIVES. A
GRANT IN AID TO SUPPORT COST OF
ATTENDANCE ABOVE TUITION AND
FEES I THINK TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT CONTINUATION FOR THAT
STUDENT WHEN THEY TRANSFER TO
THE CSU THAT AT A MINIMUM WE
WOULD NEED TO CONTINUE THAT.
ARE COMPARABLE LEVEL. AND
ACCOUNTING FOR ANY CHANGES IN
THEIR FINANCIAL SITUATION. OKAY
THANK YOU PEAK. YES GOOD THE
THIRD YEAH- PIECE I THINK IT'S
JUST RECORD THAT WE HAVE
ANOTHER MOVING PART WHICH IS
THE PELL GRANT. AND SO WE HAVE
DIFFERENT ELIGIBILITY RIGHT THE
PELL GRANT IS AVAILABLE FOR SIX
YEARS AVAILABILITY TO SEE
SECOND TOTAL RIGHT BETWEEN C.
SACK TO CAL GRANT TO AND CAL
GRANT FOR. ITS FOUR YEARS SO
WE'RE INTERESTED BECAUSE A
NOTABLE NUMBER OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE GOING TO TAKE FIVE OR SIX
YEARS TO GRADUATE WHAT WILL
THAT ADDITIONAL ONE OR TWO
YEARS. LOOK LIKE IN TERMS OF
RECALIBRATION OF HOW WE ARE
WARNING AID TO AGAIN MINIMIZE
DISRUPTION TO THE STUDENTS
PATHWAY 2 DEGREES SO WE JUST
HAVE QUESTIONS THAT I THINK CAN
BE ANSWERED. WITH MODELING AND
A CLEAR SET OF ASSUMPTIONS OF
WHAT WE ALL BELIEVE WE'RE GOING
TO THE MODEL AND THEN. PLAY
THAT OUT INTO THE OUT YEARS.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SYSTEM AND THIS IS A MULTI YEAR
EFFORT BUT- A FEW THINGS- ONE
WE THINK THAT NEW RESOURCES
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO EXPAND FINANCIAL
IT ONLY HELPS OUR- QUEST-
BREAKS MORE. MONEY ON THE ON
THE ON THE TABLE. TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THE MATHEMATICALLY IT
PENCILS OUT. IN INTO YOU KNOW
WE ARE INCREASING MONEY ENDS
AND FINANCIALLY THIS YEAR
ANYWAY. THROUGH THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT AND SOME OTHER-
EFFORTS SO- IN POTENTIAL THIS
IS A YEAR OR TWO TO REALLY RE
RE WORK AND KIND OF REVISION
FINANCIAL LATE TO. PICK UP THE
PIECES THE PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
MISSING OUT. AS WELL AS
ADDRESSED THE NON TUITION COSTS
OUT. THANK YOU WHEN THIS WAS
INFORMATIONAL AND- WE WOULD
WHAT WE NEED TO MOVE ON WITH
THE HEARING- OTHER STUFF
SCHEDULED FOR TODAY SO WITH
THAT THAT CONCLUDES. THIS PIECE
OF THE- AT THE HEARING WE NOT
PUBLIC COMMENT- THE PUBLIC CAN
CALL AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
DEDICATE- ONE MINUTE PER.
PERSON EAGER- NOT SHOWING
PEOPLE HAVE WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY BUT- THAT AT
THE OUTSET. SIXTY SECONDS PER
SPEAKER- CALL NUMBERS.
1-877-692-8957 AGAIN. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO TWO. ACCESS CODE ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. I
WITH THAT MODERATOR. WE HAVE
SPEAKERS TO TESTIFY. OKAY THE
SPEAKER LINE SHOULD BE OPEN AND
I'LL GIVE INSTRUCTIONS WHEN YOU
ARE PROPERLY. THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. YES
PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU LADIES
AND JUMP ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU WISH TO OUR- MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND EIGHTEEN
TO EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
ACCESS YOUR LINE QUICKLY AND
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER SO YOU
CAN ASK YOUR QUESTION. SO AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION
PLEASE PRESS OR SAY. THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME YEAH. AND OUR
FIRST PROPER SYMBOL COULD BE
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AT SEVEN THIRTY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SUPPORT
LIGHTING AND I'M A STUDENT. AT
UC SANTA CRUZ AND- YOU THAT
THERE'S OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
INVEST. I. AT THE END OF THE
RESPONSE THAT LAWMAKER CONSERVE
YOUR THAT THE YOU HAVE POWER AG.
HI EDUCATION ALL THE PASSAGE
THREE NINE. WHAT. WHEN ASKED
ABOUT BOND ONLY WAY IT COULD IT
WILL ALSO. BUT THERE IS A
POLITICIAN WITH MAKING IT WITH
IN THE MOVIE AFTER AND
INTENTIONAL BECAUSE THAT IN THE
PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS THAT
EXACTLY THAT DOLLAR. YOU ARE
GOING SUPPORT. PROGRAMS IN
ORDER TO CLOSE THE EQUITY GAP.
APPLICATION TO POWER IT OFF HI
EDUCATION AGAIN. A BIG ISSUE
HAPPENS LOCAL PROMPT THE- I
WILL WITH A PRIEST- WHAT'S THE
THAT THE ACTIONS OF DOCTOR IT'S
A PROGRAM. THANK YOU. WITHOUT
ANY YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS UP.
NEXT THANK YOU NEXT. SPEAKER
AND JUST A WE SIXTY SAID
SPEAKER AND SO- YOU TO WRAP IT
UP AT SIXTY WILL HAVE TO AND
HAVE THE MODERATOR CUT YOU OFF.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. SURE WE
GO TO LINE FORTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON WOULD TAKE ON BEHALF
OF THE CAMP FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDER PUBLIC
TODAY INTO OF THE BUT PROPOSAL
TO RESTORE BASED ON CUTS THE UC
IN THE CS. THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE STATE BUDGET
RESULTED IN DEVASTATING TRIGGER
CUTS TO THE UC AND CSU WE
STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO RESTORE BASIC FUNDING CUTS
TO BOTH THE UC AND CSU TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
REMAIN ON TRACK TO MEET THE 60%
ATTAINMENT GOAL BACHELOR'S
DEGREES AND TO ENSURE THAT THE
YOU SEE AND SEE IF YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO MEET GROWING
CAPACITY DEMANDS FOR STUDENTS
SEEKING A COLLEGE DEGREE. TO
HELP LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO CREATE A
DUAL ADMISSIONS PATHWAY TO THE
UC AND CSU WE APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A DUAL
ADMISSIONS PATHWAY THAT
PROVIDES GUARANTEED ADMISSION
TO STUDENTS AND STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS PACKAGE
SHOULD BE BUILT ON THE EXISTING
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
PATH SO THAT. RATHER THAN
CREATING ADDITIONAL COMPLICATED
PLAYERS STUDENTS HAVE A CLEAR
ROADMAP TO SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSFER WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA
HAS THE PROPERTY NEEDED TO
ELEVATE AND SUPPORT AT T.
TRANSFER PATHWAYS WITH A
DEMONSTRATED HISTORY OF
BENEFITING OUR STUDENTS WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN ACCESS TO THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE RESTRICT BURKE
AND- UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
UTILIZED AS WELL ESTABLISHED
PATHWAY AT THAT MISSION
GUARANTEED. WITH A HIGHER GPA
THRESHOLD IF APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. ONE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GOING. HELLO
MY FORTY EIGHT CAN YOU ME YES.
YES ONE MINUTE ALL RIGHT I'LL
HURRY ACCORDING TO A JULY SEVEN
TWENTY TWENTY AT FIRST ARTICLE
UC CHANCELLOR MICHAEL DRAKE WAS
SELECTED TO REPLACE JANET
NAPOLITANO DRAKE RECEIVES A
BASE SALARY OF EIGHT HUNDRED
AND NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
PELLICANO'S BASE SALARY OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. SIMILARLY ACCORDING TO
A SEPTEMBER TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY AND SOURCE ARTICLE
JOSEPH CASTRO WAS CHOSEN TO BE
THE NEW CHANCELLOR OF HE ASKED
YOU TO REPLACE TIMOTHY WHITE
WHO'S EXPECTED TO RETIRE AT THE
END OF THE YEAR CASTRO WILL
RECEIVE SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
PLUS A MONTHLY HOUSING SALARY
OF SEVEN HUNDRED. OF SEVEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS AND A MONTHLY
ALLOWANCE OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS
HOW IN THE WORLD CAN YOU
LEGISLATORS JUSTIFY THESE KIND
OF SALARY AND EXPENSE
COMPENSATION AND THEN TURN
AROUND AND TOP AD NAUSEAM ABOUT
SUPPOSEDLY EQUALITY AND EQUITY
HOW IN THE WORLD OF THE SALARY
REPRESENT ANYTHING BUT
INEQUALITY IN IN. EQUITY
REMEMBER. SAID RIGHT THE EAR
HEARING THAT WE COULD SPEND THE
INTO BUDGET SURPLUS UPGRADE
AGING. BUT IT'S TO WOULDN'T BE.
YEAH MOST OF THESE KIDS
LEARNING NINETEEN. THANK YOU
YEAH WELL YOU. YOUR MORE MONEY.
NINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
AGAIN WHY MINUTE SIXTY SECONDS
WAS BIG THANK YOU. HI MY FIFTY
ONE YOU ARE OPEN- YES I'M FIFTY
ONE ARE YOU THERE. I THINK WE
JUST. I THINK WE'LL- NO THIS IS
DIFFERENT LINE AND YOU NEED TO
LISTEN TO CALPERS AND STUFF
CUTTING UP MY FACE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER SPENT MORNING
STRUGGLING TECHNO IS I THANK
YOU WITH HER HERE OR CALL CLASS
SHE HAS ALREADY TO PULL PLUG
LEAVE THE STATE OF PERMANENT.
DURING HAS BEEN TO YOU DAVIS
FOR THEIR A BETTER MEDAL AND
SHE IS A OF STUDENT YOU WOULD
BE DREAM MAINTAIN A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD ALREADY PURSUING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSE IS THE
KIND STUDENT WANT IN YOUR CITY
BUT HE WON NOTHING TO DO YOU
YOUR FROM TECHNOCRACY. HE WILL
NOT BE REPLICATED TO LEARNING
ONLINE ONCE YOU SUBMIT TO YOUR
GARBAGE VACCINE MANDATES SHE'S
DECIDED THAT SHE WOULD LEAVE
THE STATE PERMANENTLY PARKED
ACTUAL EDUCATION NOT THE
GARBAGE BEING DISHED OUT BY
THIS CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU NEXT NEED
TO LISTEN. TO CALIFORNIANS.
WASTING MONEY AND WE- IS THE
GENERAL WE LISTEN. NOW IT IS
THE JOB THANK YOU NEXT WEEK-
MIND FORTY FOUR. MY FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD WELL MIRJANA
HELLO MY OUR LACK I'M FROM THE
AGAIN EVERYTHING INDIAN MAY
THIRD YEAR PUB HEALTH MEDICAL
STUDENT AND YOU CAN DIEGO WHERE
IF THERE THE PRESS. I THINK
THAT THE OF NEED AMERICAN IT IN
FIND TO ASK THAT YOU PRIORITIZE
HEALTH ACT. AND WORK FOR THE
AND COURT THEY GOT BALL BY
REQUEST THE CRIME I AM THE
HEALTH INDIA THE AVERAGE YET
THE SCHOOL MEDICINE MY WAS ONE
OF FIRST HEALTH INDIAN FABRIC
BECOME A TO THE NINETY NINETY
NINE. I THINK PEOPLE IN THE
FROM HEALTH CARE BELIEVE WE'RE
MORE WITH SPECIAL TRAINING. WE
SUPPORT THE YOU CAN REQUEST FOR
NEW CARD. AN AFFIRMATION OF
POLICY HELP AGAIN P. AND THE
YOU KNOW LAND GRANT MISSION
THERE ARE HUNDRED AND NINE TRY
HELLO. THE INPUT BUILT OUR OWN
SHE A PROGRAM LIKE THIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BYE. FIFTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD RIGHT.
I'M NOT BE HOW ABOUT. DR ED
HIRED. CO AND- ORGANIZED.
UPLIFTING URGENT BUDGET. FROM
DOCUMENTS TO THAT. THE PETS. OF
UP AND EDUCATION ALL. UNDER
WITH THE VENTURE. WOULD BE-
RESTRICTED TO THE PEOPLE A
GREATER. YES ARE LEADERSHIP
NGUYEN. TO FIND CREDIBILITY IN
KICK BACK CAL. THE DOCK.
STUDENTS MATHEMATICALLY YOUR
MARKET WE TWENTY. DOLLARS A
DIRECT EMERGENCY. TO A DOCUMENT
AGAIN CALIFORNIA. AND PRIVATE.
NOT COLLEGE IN THE BERKELEY.
AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE HOW THAT.
DISTRIBUTE THE SAKE OF THAT. AN
IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS STAFF AND FACULTY AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND YOU
SEE. A DOCTOR TODAY ARE
COUNTING ON YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE BUDGET INTO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR ACT TO PRIORITIZE NEEDS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. THANK YOU MISTER WE
WILL ALIGN THIRTY NOW. GERMAN
PARTY MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M KEVIN CORRIGAN
AND A SENIOR ATTENDING WOULD
RETIRED GOING IRVINE MET MOST
STUDENTS OUT OF HIGH AGED SOME
EIGHT OR UNDER ABOUT THE CAREER
PATHS FOR. AND MANY DO NOT HAVE
AFTER ACCESS PROTECT IN FROM
DURING HIGH SCHOOL YOU CREATING
A DEAL AND MISSION PROCESS WE
YOUR CALL THE LIKELY INHIBIT
THOSE ATTENDING COMMUNITY FROM
ACTUALLY BEING TO PER THEIR AT
ENDEAVOR. AS MANY STUDENTS
EITHER OUT COMMUNITY CALL
REPORT CALL AND CAREER. HAVING
APPLY TO COMMUNITY CALL AND YOU
PROGRAM HIGH WILL LIKE TO TURN
STUDENTS FROM CONSIDERING
TRANSFERRING YOU THINK. IT
RELATES TO THE OUTCOMES WILL TO
ALL MY COURSES IN TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND HAVE BEEN
A PART OF CON ONLINE OPTIONS
PRACTICAL THE NINETEEN DROPPED
HIGH. ONLINE COURSES TAUGHT IN
TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY FOUR ONE
DO NOT MEET THE THAT INTO
ESPECIALLY GIVEN PROFESSOR AND
TEACHERS WERE GIVEN A SHORT
MONTHS TO PIVOT THEIR
CURRICULUM TO A NEW YEAH THAT
YOU PREPARED FOR DEVELOPING THE
MEANINGFUL I THIS. AND FULLY
DEVELOP UNLIKE WRITTEN WILL
COME TO WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK. HEALTH POLICY
LEADER TO ENSURE ACCESSIBLE AND
HIGH QUALITY HEALTH CARE. HI
ANTHONY MICHAELS BY TRAINING
SYSTEMS CHANGE HEALTH ADVOCACY
AND DIVISION. ALREADY IS A
CRIME YOU I AM SURE THAT I HAVE
LEARNED THAT THE A HUNDRED
FIFTY OTHER. STUDENTS ACROSS
STATE. BY HOSTING. AND WHY
CALLS BACK TO. CONDUCTING
AROUND. AND FREE ISSUES WORK
TOWARD TIME FACULTY. THE
QUESTION TODAY THE NOT AND THAT
SHOULD BE PASSED BUDGET REPLY.
THE QUESTION IS HOW MUCH DO.
TRUST AND- HEALTH. INVESTING IN
THE PRIMARY THAT WILL BE CLOSER
TO. AND TO. WILLING AND KEEP.
OF HOW. LAST MARCH. COMMUNITIES
PRIME GRANT OF UNDER. STUDENTS
BY. TO GO. TO IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNITY. PLEASE PRIORITY HELD
BACK. HOW CARE ACT. AND WILL
FOR STATE OR CITY BY. THE
GOVERNOR'S. WITH I WANT TWELFTH
NINE MILLION DOLLAR. FOR YOU
COULD PRINT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. EVEN EXTRA
HARD FOR MYSELF AND MANY OF MY
PEERS WERE ALSO THE FIRST MAN
FAMILIES TO ATTEND SCENE WE'RE
ALL DOING OUR BEST TO KEEP UP
WITH THEIR STUDIES WHILE ALSO
PRESERVING MENTAL HEALTH. BUT
IT CAN BE CHALLENGING
ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR FINANCIAL
SITUATIONS AREN'T CERTAIN. THE
ONLY OTHER STUDENTS STRUGGLING
THE COURSE CABINET
MINISTRATION. TOOK PLACE OF
COURSE DURING THIS DIFFICULT
TIME IN PART BECAUSE THE NEEDS
OF OUR- COMMUNITY. OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH STORY PARKING
OF THE SEA AND INCREASE THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK- ONE FIFTY TWO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MIA MCIVER I TEACH
AS A LECTURER AT UCLA AND I
PRESIDENT IF YOU SEE A T.
REPRESENTING CONTENTION
TEACHING FACULTY AND LIBRARIANS
AT ALL UC CAMPUSES. WE WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE TO
RESTORING THE TWENTY TWENTY
CUTS THE STATE BUDGET WE ALSO
WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
UC'S DROP RETENTION STATISTICS
CAN BE VERY MISLEADING WHEN IT
COMES TO UC LECTURERS FOR THE
UC DEDICATED TEACHING
SPECIALIST. LECTURERS TEACH
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF STE STUDENT
CREDIT HOURS BUT SUFFER FROM
EXTREMELY HIGH RATES OF FORCD
A TURNOVER WERE HIRED ON SHORT
TERM PART TIME CONTRACTS
WITHOUT ANY COMMITMENTS TO
CONSIDER US FOR RENEWALS THE
AVERAGE LECTURER TEACHES AT THE
UC FOR LESS THAN TWO YEARS MOST
SERVER PER YEAR OR LAST BEFORE
THEIR ARBITRARILY AND
INVOLUNTARILY DISMISSED. THE UC
MAY SEEM TO RETAIN AND EVEN
EXPAND LECTURE POSITION BUT
INDIVIDUAL LECTURE THEY'RE
FUNCTIONALLY LAID OFF AT A
STARTLINGLY HIGH RATE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND OF MY LECTURER FACULTY
COLLEAGUES LOST THEIR JOBS OVER
SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY IT'S BAD
FOR LECTURES AND IT'S TERRIBLY
DETRIMENTAL FOR OUR STUDENTS.
EDUCATION SUFFERS WHEN THEIR
TEACHERS HAVE NO STABILITY WE
ASK YOU TO HELP US HOLD YOU SEE
OKAY ACCOUNTABLE FOR BRINGING A
FAIR AND TRANSPARENT RE HIRING
PROCESS DO YOU SEE LUXURY BUT
TAXPAYER MONEY SUPPORTS HIGH
QUALITY TEACHING FACULTY JOB
THAT THE UC THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT BIGGER MISTER
MODERATOR YOU THERE. I VERY YOU
AND WE ARE GOING WIND NOT FOR
MR MR MY- YOU ARE YOU CAN YOU
HEAR. I AM HERE AGAINST ME YES
SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO HEAR THE
FINAL ELEVEN SPEAKERS IN THE
QUEUE RIGHT NOW- NO ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS AFTER THE ELEVEN
PLEASE THANK YOU. UNDERSTOOD
THANK YOU OKAY AND WE WILL GO
TO. OKAY WE WILL GO TO ONE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATIE LITTLE
AND I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU. THOUGH IT WAS NOT
EXPLICITLY AGENDAS TODAY WE
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE BASE LEVEL AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE UC
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES DIVISION. THE WORK
COMPLETED THROUGH THIS
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND
ADVISORY AS THE ORIGINAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
HELP CALIFORNIA GROWERS
INTEGRATE CLIMATE RESILIENCY
PRACTICES. INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT BIODIVERSITY AND
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES ON FARMS AND
RANCHES. THIS IS CRITICAL AT
THE STATE AND CONSUMERS ASK
MORE OF OUR FARMING COMMUNITIES
AND WE RIGHTS TO MEET THE
CHALLENGE. THE FOUR H. YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS ARE ALSO
FUNDED THROUGH UC ANR AND AS WE
NEED AND WANT TO SEE THE FUTURE
OF FARMING TO BE MORE
REFLECTIVE OF THE STATE. TOP
WAYS TO FUTURE CAREERS IN
AGRICULTURE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO
WINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CINDY HILLARY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION YOUR MAIN SUPPORTS
THE INCLUSION OF FOLK FUNDING
FOR AN EXPANSION OF THE UC
PRIME PROGRAM YOU SEE PRIME
PROGRAMS ARE KEY TO EXPANDING
THE DIVERSE CITY OF THE
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE AND
REDUCING THE FINANCIAL BARRIERS
TO A MEDICAL EDUCATION.
ENABLING MORE DIVERSITY AND THE
MEDICAL WORK FOR IS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT TO ENSURING
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CARE
OVERCOMING COMMUNITY MISTRUST
OF VITAL HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
SUCH AS VACCINATION AND
MAINTAINING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER DURING
YOUR HEARING THANK. THANKS
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE WILL LINE TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CARE MCCARTY IN THE
NUMBERS THE BUDGET SECOND
READY- MY NAME DEREK MILLION
I'M HISTORY PUBLIC POLICY
SENIOR UC SANTA BARBARA- I WISH
TO SPEAK TO DATE BECAUSE ACT
ELDEST SON IMMIGRANTS THIS PAST
YEAR IT'S BEEN A VERY STRESSFUL
TIME. FOR MYSELF MY YOUNGER
BROTHER WHO IS ALSO CURRENTLY
YOU SEE STUDENT UC DAVIS. I'M
NOT MAY COUNTIES I PERSONALLY
HAVE NOT STATE THAT COMPLETING
MY SCHOOL WORK NO MATTER
ALLOWED ME TO GRADUATE LATER
THIS YEAR I STRONG AS I CAN
WHILE ALSO HAVING TO ASSIST MY
FATHER. WELL HIS OWN BUSINESS
AND DOESN'T SPEAK ENGLISH VERY
WELL WE'RE PLANNING FOR
BUSINESS LOANS AND GRANTS SO HE
CAN MAINTAIN MY FAMILY'S
PRIMARY SOURCE OF INCOME DURING
THE CURRENT ECONOMIC SLOWDOWN.
ANY POTENTIAL TUITION INCREASES
TO PUT IT SIMPLY WILL
FINANCIALLY HURT NOT ONLY MY
OWN FAMILY LOCAL SO ME AND MY
FELLOW PEERS WHO DEPEND ON YOU
SEE EDUCATION FOR THE CHANCE TO
MAKE BETTER LIVES FOR
THEMSELVES. IDEA PROSTATE
LAWMAKERS TO RESTORE FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET THE UC SYSTEM SET
THE SYSTEM AND STUDENTS AND
STAFF MEMBERS WOULD AND CAN
ONLY SURVIVE IN THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES TO CONTINUE. TO DRIVE.
THANK YOU THANK SPEAKER. FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
BAILEY HENDERSON AND I TEN UC
BERKELEY I WANT TO START BY
SHARING MY APPRECIATION FOR
COVERED HOUSTON'S RESTORATION
OF OUR BUDGET BUT THIS IS JUST
ONE STEP FORWARD I'D LIKE TO
ALSO THANK YOU WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING
IN THEIR OWN COMMENTS THE STATE
THAT PROGRAMS- IT TO THE
FAILURE PROP SIXTEEN IS MORE
CRUCIAL THAN EVER THE FAMILY DO
SOMETHING TO ADDRESS THE EQUITY
GAP. BETWEEN COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA I NOW THIS BODY IS
CURRENTLY COULD BE CONSIDERING
CREATING A DUAL SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
WANT TO TELL YOU SEE BUT
THERE'S NO PROOF THAT THIS WILL
HELP THE PEOPLE INTENDS TO WE
HAVE THE REPORT AFTER REPORT TO
DESCRIBE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAM UNDERSTATE HAVE.
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT HAVE DEFENDED THIS
PAST DECADE DESPITE CONSTANT
USE THE INVESTMENT THIS TIME
THE STATE GOVERNMENT STEPS UP
TO SUPPORT EQUITY ON CAMPUS
THAT'S WHY THE UTSA. IS ASKING
FOR TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENT. THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING PLEASE. THANK YOU WE
WERE LYING TO SEVEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
WE CAN'T OKAY HI MY NAME IS
DOMINIC KEVIN SHIELDS I AM A
PROUD GRADUATE MYSELF OF UC
DAVIS IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
MY WIFE IS APROUD GRADUATE OF
UC BERKELEY AND UCSF- JOINT
PROGRAM. CURRENTLY I'M A
PROFESSOR AT THE UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND I RUN A
RESEARCH LABORATORY HERE WITH
THE GOAL OF PREVENTING
ARTHRITIS WE RECENTLY ALSO
STARTED- STUDYING THE EFFECT OF
COVERT NINETEEN ON I JOIN A
JOINT AND BONE HEALTH- I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE LAWMAKERS TO
RESTORE THE FUNDING CUTS TO THE
UC THE UC SYSTEM'S CONTRIBUTED
TO EDUCATION. AND RESEARCH ON
IT IN A WAY THAT ARE RESPECTED
AROUND THE WORLD- YOU SEE IS
UNIQUE IN HOW WELL IT INCLUDES
STUDENTS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND IN
MY ROLE AS AN EDUCATOR I TRAIN
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
SCIENTISTS AND I SEE FIRSTHAND
HOW YOU SEE AS AN ENGINE OF
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR SO MANY
FRIGHTENED YOUNG- MOTIVATED
STUDENTS. THE UC SERVICE AT
THIS NEED IN A WAY THAT IS NOT
MET BY OTHER RESPECTED
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE STATE
SO AGAIN I'M CALLING TO ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT RESTORING THE
CRITICAL FUNDING TO THE UC- IT
FOR THE C. IN THE STATE BUDGET.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE PROPOSAL
ANNOUNCED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP AND THE GOVERNOR
THAT WOULD FULLY RESTORE CUTS
MADE TO THE UC AND I HOPE THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AS
BUT- BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK- ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU
HI MY NAME IS JOANNA HEDRICK
WHEN I GRADUATE S. B.
SACRAMENTO I'M ALSO ACCOUNT
FOR. THEIR ANSWERS STUDENTS
WITH FINANCIAL AID STUDENT. I
DO I DO NOT SERVE STUDENTS
BASED ON RACE OR WHATEVER BOX
YOU WANT TO PUT PUT STUDENTS IN.
I TALKED TO YOU ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THE COST OF TUITION AND
FEES AN ONLINE FORMAT. I SEE A
GOAL OF ATTAINING A PIECE OF
PAPER RATHER THAN IN EDUCATION
AND LIFE LONG CRITICAL THINKING
SKILLS. AND JOB SKILLS. IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO GO TO COLLEGE
THEY SHOULD HAVE ACCESS. AND
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO BUT
COLLEGE IS NOT THE ONLY OPTION
WHY DOESN'T SEE IF YOUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ALSO
PROVIDE EDUCATION OR TRAINING
ON TREAT. OTHER STUDENTS THAT
GET FULL AID PACKAGES THAT
COVER ALL TUITION AND LIVING
EXPENSES THEY ARE IN GOOD
SHAPE. BUT I TALKED TO A LOT OF
STUDENTS THE ONLY GOT LOANS AND
HAVE LITTLE OR NO FAMILY
SUPPORT. YOU LOOK AT THE DEBT
THE STUDENTS TAKE ON FOR AN
UNDERGRAD DEGREE AND HOW THAT
LIMITS THEIR FUTURE SUCCESS. I
DO HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT- THE CSU SYSTEM. I KNOW
I THE STAFF. YOU KNOW WE WORK
REALLY HARD TO. ASSIST IN
HELPING STUDENTS SO.
DISCONTINUED SORT REPORT HERE
COLLEGES AND STUDENTS EVERYBODY
WORKING HARD TO HELP STUDENTS
MAINTENANCE TO OPERATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT BIGGER. LINE
FORTY ONE YOU ARE UP. I'M FORTY
ONE PLEASE ON YOU. LOPING ALONG
WITH A LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MCCARTY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S EDDY
TEACHING CLASS AND I'M A JUNIOR
ATTENDING MARKET HIGH SCHOOL
AND IRVINE ORANGE COUNTY
PLANNING TO APPLY TO BOTH YOU
SEE AND SEE IF YOU SCHOOL IN
THE NEAR FUTURE INCREASING
AMOUNT OF ONLINE COURSES
OFFERED AS PER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUIREMENTS- THAT
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PROGRAMS MAY
BE NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE
STUDENTS. WHO ARE NOT
PHYSICALLY ON CAMPUS
SPECIFICALLY IN THE AREA OF
MENTAL HEALTH TEACHERS IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL WITHOUT
HAVING SPREAD CONCERN OVER THE
STUDENT GROUP ONE COULD BE
CLASS AND- THE IMPACT ON
VIRTUAL COLLEGE STUDENTS MUST
ALSO BE VERY HAPPY IF NOT
HAPPIER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTOR UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS TO PRIORITIZE STATE AND
OTHER FUNDING IN ADDITION TO
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
PROVIDE MORE ACCEPTABLE MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES ESPECIALLY TO
STUDENTS ATTENDING SCHOOL
VIRTUALLY ENTER REPORT THAT
PROGRESS. THANK YOU THANK. YOU
THANKS BAKER. THE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I'M SICK
TWO. YEAH HI IS THIS LINE SIXTY
TWO YES PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU ONLY LEFT YEAH GREAT GREAT
I GET MY MINUTE SO WE LISTEN TO
YOU FOR OVER FIVE HOURS AND YOU
GIVE US SIXTY SECONDS TO SPEAK
WHEN YOU DECIDE NOT TO TAKE IN
MORE COLORS YEAH YOU EXPECTS
CALIFORNIANS TO CONTINUE TO
HAND YOU MILLIONS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF OUR
MONEY TO WASTE ON AN UTTERLY
FAILING HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
NO CHISNALL. AFTER LISTENING TO
THIS SHAM OF THE HEARING I CAN
NOW OFFICIALLY AT HIGHER
EDUCATION TO AN AREA WHERE THIS
LEGISLATURE IS UTTERLY SAILING
CALIFORNIA RIGHT ALONG WITH THE
EDC PC BMB AND SO MANY OTHER
DECAYING CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS TWO MILLION IS THE
NUMBER OF SIGNATURES THAT WE
HAVE COLLECTED TWO WEIRD
OURSELVES OF THIS CRIMINAL
GOVERNOR AND ANY OF THE UNIX OF
EAGER PLEASE. NEXT WEEK- THANK
YOU. LINE SIX- WINDS FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TRIP- MCCARTY I'M REALLY SORRY
YOU HAVE TO JUST HEAR THAT-
THAT WAS DISRESPECTFUL I
APOLOGIZE ON BEHALF OF EVERYONE
WHO WAS HEARING TAX- MINING BY
JOHN I AM A DEVELOPMENT OF THE
FIVE NATION DIRECTOR FOR YOU
SINCE YOU'RE A SUSPICION HERE
TO SPEAK. TO YOU IN FAVOR OF
THE STATE THAT PROGRAMS IT HAD
QUITE A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS
HERE ARE JUST SHOWING ARE IN
CAN BE ADDED SUPPORT FOR THE
PROGRAM YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN A CHAMPION FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN THE PAST SO- I WANT.
ANYMORE YOUR TIME BUT WE WOULD
LOVE BE A TO HAVE YEARS AGO
FOR. THE COMMITTEE SUPPORTS-
TWENTY DOLLAR ON GOING OF THE
PROGRAM WE THINK- GIVEN GIVEN
THE KIND. AND EVERYTHING OF
GOING ON. THIS WOULD BE EXTRA.
IN SUPPORTING OUR- ATHLETES
BECAUSE READING IS THE SUCCESS
OF OUR STUDENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO MORE SPEAKERS ARE
LINED UP- THIS IS OUR FINAL.
FINAL QUESTION. YEP OUR FINAL
QUESTIONERS. PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY WILL COME. FROM WIND
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EACH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN.
MON WRAPS ON OF THE- FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. FIRST WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO FULLY RESTORE
THE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION CUT THAT TO GET YOU
SUSTAINED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET HOWEVER WE NOTE THE
REDUCTIONS WERE MADE TO COURSE
OFFERINGS AND FACULTY POSITIONS
WE WILL NEED TO RESTORE THOSE
POSITIONS AND COURSES IN ORDER
TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS WELL.
SECOND ONE SECONDLY WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH INCLUDES A
HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION AN ONGOING GENERAL FUND
TO PROVIDE A 3% INCREASE IN
BASE RESOURCES. THIRD WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR FIFTEEN MILLION PER STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY
NEEDS- WE BELIEVE THE MOST
AFFECTED MECHANISM FOR
INCREASING THE AVAILABILITY OF
QUALITY STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO HIRE. MORE FULL
TIME TENURE TRACK COUNSELING
FACULTY. FINALLY WE SUPPORT THE
TEN MILLION TO PROVIDE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FIRST
YEAR CSU FACULTY. WE WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND ARE BUDGET LETTER THANK YOU
AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU. YES
THANK YOU RUN GREAT HERE VOICE
I'M GLAD TO SEE YOU'RE BACK IN
THE EDUCATION ADVOCACY BUSINESS
THANK YOU I WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN. THEY DIDN'T TERM IT
DOES CONCLUDE OUR.